opening the hearing on house bill 1391
establishing a secure psychiatric
hospital
advisory committee the chair recognizes
representative weber in for
good morning mr chairman and committee
members thank you very much
uh the chairs here are much lower than
my name is lucy weber i represent
cheshire one the connecticut river towns
of walpole westmoreland chesterfield and
hinsdale
and i'm here today to introduce a bill
brought by
leader cushing
establishing a secure psychiatric
hospital advisory committee
as you all know this is an issue that
leader cushing has worked on for many
years
his concerns are
that the secure psychiatric facility as
it has been for many years has been
located inside the prison
and
the
new hampshire hospital but their
behavior is such they can't stay there
but
the concern is
the facility and
the
uh issues of
whether any therapeutic benefit for
patients who are civilly committed can
be achieved in that setting which if you
have seen it is very very grim
what was proposed was a committee
of of members of the house and the
senate
to uh advise on
uh the location construction building
and and implementation of the uh
of a new secure psychiatric unit that
would not be part of a prison
and
that process is underway
i think there is still work to be done
in terms of
uh
how things are set up and how they will
be run but
i think that as matters have evolved
the time for the advisory committee may
be
nearly over now and by the time a bill
gets passed
that that ship may have sailed so
with that i will take any questions if
representative gay thank you
uh how much
and thank you for taking my question
how much
do we have to
you know we need to turn your microphone
on
is this better yes much better okay
uh what actually is the heavy lift that
we have to do because you know the needs
been there for a long long time is it
that we
need to raise
appropriate a lot of money
well my understanding and there may be
other people in the room who know this
better than i do because i did not
become prepared to give you the
background the whole thing but
uh
the issues over the years have been
first of all that it's a very small
number of patients it's a very large
appropriation of money
it the security that whatever is built
needs to be secure and safe
which means that
if you're looking simply at a cost
analysis the cost per patient is
enormous
now what has happened over the course of
the years and i i'm not aware of all of
the specifics of this so i apologize but
i'm introducing this as a courtesy
is that
we have over the last year and a half
made arrangements for
more building at the concord hospital
site more beds at various other sites
and the hope is to rearrange placements
in a more appropriate and more
therapeutic manner
the concerns that leader cushing had is
that
whenever we get into a budget crisis
this project although very important is
the first one that falls off the radar
so
his
concern
is making sure that there are people
around who are working hard at keeping
people's feet to the fire and keep them
going forward
and getting people who are civilly
committed out of the criminal facility
as chairman of oversight
i've had conversations with commissioner
shibanet
on this issue
in general but also in the context of
the state acquiring hampstead hospital
which is literally half a mile up the
road from where i live
subsequent to that a facility partnering
with portsmouth hospital to be cited in
epping and an additional project just
got the newspapers here some of those
are secure facilities or some of them
have secure places or wards or units in
them
so it looks like
his efforts over years
are being realized and in this time when
we have a lot of money available it
looks like the plans are going forward
and
when i first was running
he was one of the first people i met who
was in the legislature and we talked
about this a lot
and i think
perhaps he's seeing his
vision his hope his dreams in the
process of finally being fulfilled
let us hope it continues to move forward
mr chairman thank you so much for your
testimony
i'm going to end the
hearing on
house bill 1391 and open an executive
session on the same
i will be moving itl but i'll let you
know how i'm going to write the blurb
the committee report if this should pass
itl
will be very laudatory and appreciative
of his great work over the years
this will not be so much the bill failed
as it will be your hopes of triumph and
that's how i'm going to write it should
this pass
so the chair moves as i can do
itl the bill
could you please explain why
why what
why would you want an itl is there
already a committee
no it is to establish a committee that
is no longer needed
oh because we've already accomplished
what the goal was i think so yeah
but i'm waiting for a second would
somebody wish to second
i do too
representative mckay would like to
second that now we can discuss
this
if there's any questions or any
discussion it doesn't have to be a
thank you mr chairman
the um
new hampshire hospital
the original problem was
from the city of concord did not want
that placed
up behind the brown building
and that became a political issue
all of that is behind us
and the need for a committee
is
is not needed that the oversight
committee has that responsibility
already
so that the necessity for a committee
and you've already stated over and over
that nobody wants more committees
at this point
so i would
hope that the itl
will pass
the facility will
be built
and the oversight committee will serve
anyone else representative shapiro
yes thank you mr chairman um i'm
ambivalent about this bill
however i would like to point out that
the expansions that
were talked about in terms of hampstead
hospital and
other things that have done to make
inpatient room
i think are a little bit different than
what's being talked about in terms of um
this new hospital which would have to be
a forensic hospital
um because it is really has to be built
to deal with um people who are dangerous
serious danger to themselves in a
serious danger to other people
i'm hopeful that there will be you know
plenty of advice given in other from
other avenues about how this should be
built
but we are talking about a very specific
facility and
while i know there was some money
devoted to this last year or the year
before
i'm very hopeful that it'll actually
move forward and there will be a
specific facility because
people in the old facility are not only
not being taken care of properly
but they are being essentially
imprisoned in a correctional institution
even though they have not been convicted
of any crime which is the real issue
here that we're trying to solve
so
i'm ambivalent about how to vote on the
bill but i think that
this is an important thing and i'm not
sure we're completely over the hurdle in
terms of moving forward thank you
i would like to ask um
john williams as
legislative liaison to come on up and
clarify
chairman pearson thank you very much and
we're just reminded we're in executive
session not a public hearing john
williams from the department of health
hi i'm ellen lapoint i'm the chief
operating officer at new hampshire
hospital
i'm paula matas i'm the director of
medical and forensic services for the
new hampshire department of corrections
and am the director of the secure
oh okay
now that you've got your story straight
yes
[Music]
would you answer the uh representative's
concerns may i ask for the
representative to please state the
um do you yield
i think what we'd like to hear
are the plans for the transfer of the
secure psychiatric unit and and what is
being proposed going forward and how far
we should probably have done that in the
hearing but
there were no more pink cards so here we
are sure so i'm happy to update you on
where we stand with this project right
now um i do have a high level of
confidence that everything is moving
forward
as new hampshire hospital is concerned
we are working diligently with the
public works department
and this project is a design build
bid project so at this point we are
coming to gnc on wednesday tomorrow with
the proposed
design firm that has been selected
through the rfp process
and seeking approval of that company to
start the design of the forensic
hospital we anticipate that design phase
to take us through the summer of 2022
at some point in 2022 we will be working
on
creating the rfp
to
seek the construction company and
bringing that to governor and council
for approval once that selection has
happened we are also working diligently
with the
concord community we've had one
so far out of a series of
several
um
six or seven scheduled at this point
community calls that we're hosting with
the members of concord and it's an open
invitation for anyone who wants to join
those calls and so far we've had second
call is happening in
january 31st later this month
and we had a wide range of attendees at
that first call and that actually was
recorded as well so for anyone who might
be interested i'm happy to provide you
with the link
to youtube to hear that session
and again we'll be having another call
and we have been presenting to the
community the importance of this project
um and answering some concerns that they
have about
you know maybe misinformation or fears
related to the project and so far that's
been very well attended and a lot of
great questions have come forth and
we've continued to offer a forum for
questions to be asked by the community
in between those sessions so that we can
come to the table
prepared to answer any questions at the
next presentation
and then we also have another
presentation scheduled in march of 2022
may and or june depending on how things
unfold and then
three other sessions that are currently
scheduled between 2023 and 2024
and again we're entirely open to
scheduling other sessions or you know
really listening to the community
feedback but i do agree that at this
point things are moving forward we're
working diligently with the design
company
as well as starting to work with experts
in regards to what the programming and
setup of the facility should look like
to best serve the population
and to just add to that very detailed uh
information provided to committee uh for
the record that was ellen lapointe alan
lapointe from the department uh and you
probably are aware that the uh this is
actually been part of not one but two
budget uh cycles that we've now
obtained i want to say around 38 million
dollars in funding so that has already
taken place in addition to that this
issue was actually um reviewed
legislatively as a committee very much
like the one that you see that
representative cushing thoughtfully
brought forward but has already taken
place as part of the process to develop
a plan for the sununu excuse me the
secured psychiatric uh facility so i'm
going to ask miss mattis from the
department of corrections and she could
[Music]
so thank you for including me um so the
um
tell us your first name please miss
paula paul p-a-u-l-a mattis m-a-t-t-i-s
thank you
so again thank you for the opportunity
to speak the
department of corrections currently has
a secure psychiatric unit which is not
part of the new hampshire state prison
for men but is on the grounds of the new
we are
ready
and
willing and able to assist
the department of health and human
services and their plans moving forward
i think our bigger role of course will
be at the point that they are ready to
open their new facility
to that facility as a reminder
respectfully to the committee the secure
psychiatric unit that is currently
operated by the new hampshire department
of corrections also serves as the
inpatient facility for residents people
who are incarcerated throughout the
state of new hampshire so there are
people receiving services there
appropriate treatment from qualified
mental health and behavioral health
professionals to
meet the needs of those who have been
incarcerated who may have a mental
illness and acute phase of their mental
illness so again the department of
corrections
is very happy to collaborate with dhhs
as we move forward in effectuating this
these laws
thank you all
thank you paula for your many years of
service in a very difficult
position
my pleasure thank you is this transfer
from corrections to department of health
and human services is that is that
what's happening or
is this a facility that's
yeah
so
this is obviously the facility
as was outlined earlier um is still
under planning and construction hasn't
been constructed yet so it is my
understanding until that time
the secure psychiatric unit as
established by previous uh policy makers
will continue to operate as it has and
we will continue to again collaborate
with all the people who rely on the
secure psychiatric unit for that level
of care
for follow-ups
is the end result going to be a transfer
or is it going to stay as it is
so the end result will be a transfer of
some of the populations currently served
by the secure psychiatric unit
follow up the uh i don't think you're
getting my question i may not be i
apologize yeah and i'm just going to
pretend that i'm working for the
department of corrections for a few
seconds some of the population that are
being served by the secured psychiatric
unit come through the criminal process
they've actually been adjudicated and
they come in and because of the fact
that they meet the otherwise criteria
for
being forensically
want a better word dangerous
that it also serves an additional
population that is that starts off
perhaps at new hampshire hospital but
not through the criminal process through
a civil process but they become of a
level of acuity uh that they have to be
transferred for a higher level service
at the secured psychiatric unit so i
hope and i'm going to look at miss
mattis because she's got that look in
her eye that either i got it dead right
or she's going to clarify so
i apologize to you representative mckay
i misunderstood so the secure
psychiatric unit
in short currently as it exists serves
many masters
we
people who have been convicted of crimes
who are sent to state prisons or houses
of corrections and need the
level of inpatient care because of an
acute mental illness are served there as
well as people from specifically the
developmental services committee
community who may be seen as dangerous
people who are at new hampshire hospital
who the hospital requests transfer to
the secure psychiatric unit because of
dangerousness primarily to others but
occasionally to self in addition we also
serve those who are
adjudicated ngri or not guilty by reason
of insanity which is another court
process and then finally this is rare
but it does occur there's a level of
civil commitment in our state that came
into being
a decade or so ago
called the sexually violent predator act
and that under rsa 135e
people who
have been incarcerated for a sexual
offense and are seen as
having a mental defect or condition
resulting in continued dangerousness
will go through a court process and then
be if found to be a sexually violent
predator will be remanded to the secure
psychiatric unit so in general
no quite frankly specifically there are
five major populations served not all of
them are going to be transferred to this
new facility
the secure psychiatric unit as we know
it today will obviously change but will
still be needed because there are other
again
populations served
i apologize for my confusion earlier on
one more question okay
what i'm trying to get at is that
will this new facility
come under the
responsibilities given to the oversight
committee
i can answer that through an email from
commissioner shibanet to me as chairman
of oversight
we are building a secure psychiatric
hospital this spring slash summer
this hospital will leave the supervision
of the doc
and fall under dhhs
yes sir representative weber
[Music]
that's clarified what i was hoping to
clarify my my concern was making it very
clear that the new facility to be built
will be under
um dhhs and and the concord hospital
this is actually an exact session i
and so the question has been
moved and or the
it's moved and seconded to itl
house bill 1391 establishing a secure
psychiatric hospital advisory committee
representative leon yes
representative mcmahon yes
representative acton yes representative
gay yes representative cushman yes
representative folsom yes representative
kelsey yes representative king yes
representative cole fault yes
yes
representative weber
representative mckay
representative
snow is absent representative knurk yes
representative soloway
representative cannon yes
representative nutter upham yes
representative shapiro
yes
representative woods yes representative
merchant
yes representative pearson yes
20 nothing 20 nothing
and i will write the committee report
please remind me okay two or three times
thank you
this uh ends the exact session on house
well i don't think so but i'll ask uh no
objection to consent good thank you
consent
thank you for bringing these up in a
timely manner everybody
open the hearing on house bill
1044 relative to policies required for
health facilities and special
care service
licenses
and uh we have
representative uh yeah very in for
mclean correct i am not a uh i'm
representative ross berger represent the
town of litchfield and southern
manchester awards eight and nine um i am
not the prime sponsor on this bill um i
did draw short straw when mark told me
that he couldn't make it today um so i
will not hold myself up as an expert on
this issue i'm doing a courtesy to my
seat mate
who did a lot of door knocking with me
so i think he was cashing in those uh
he's cashed in that favor today
um what this bill does is it allows um
a facility to take direct payments uh
for from services
when speaking with representative mclean
he
sold it to me as a price transparency
bill so as this committee is extremely
aware
new hampshire has some of the highest
health care deductibles in the country
some of that comes from a lack of
understanding of what things cost
and the reason this was near and dear to
me was
about two or three years ago i went to
the hospital under the advice of my
doctor who believed i was having a
stroke
i believed i was having bell's palsy it
in the course of that they did a i
believe it was a cat scan
and found a
cloudiness on my brain which the doctor
in the emergency room told me might be
brain cancer
um so i in talking with the doctor um i
said well i don't think it's brain
cancer
you guys have already missed one today
so i think you're going to miss two i
said well what should i do he said well
you can go get an mri right now and i
said get an mri from the emergency room
or
what or could i go get an external mri
and he said well you could get an
external mri it would probably be a lot
cheaper i said what does an mri here
cost he said well i don't know
and so i had a very
blunt conversation with him i said well
let's say doctor you are right let's say
it is brain cancer i said uh what's a
week going to be to wait to get an
outpatient mri says in ankle matter
so i got the outpatient mri and i do not
have brain cancer thankfully it was a
previous injury that i knew about um
so
doctors zero ross too that day
um
but um
so that's how mark mark sold it to me
and what it does is it allows a facility
to set up a very simple direct payment
in lieu of all of the other options that
they are required to take
the the negatives that i saw from this
bill because was that
you know if
a facility wants to enter into this
there might be less facilities on the
market i highly doubt that will happen
um because
everyone is going to be a medicaid
medicare insurance um the amount of
people that would probably take
advantage of should be very low
however
i believe it would create tr price tax
would create price transparency which i
think we desperately need
you guys know a lot more about health
care than i ever will but i do know that
our system is inherently broken and one
of the biggest ways it's broken is just
how things are priced differently for
different people for different reasons
and i don't believe that that's right so
that's why i signed on to the bill
there are people coming up behind me
which will be much
better at answering the technical
questions because i am not going to once
again do not hold myself up as an expert
in this field at all um i'm i'm willing
to take a stab at it but please do not
be offended if i
choose to uh punt
uh doctor excuse me oh yes yes i like
this
representative barry um
is it not a law in new hampshire that
prices should be posted and readily
available so
that doctor could very quickly consult
what his facility would charge you
i would hope so once again not an expert
in this field
so you you're probably correct
uh may i ask representative kenner who
or that he can ask a question of his own
choosing well i had planned and asked a
question but i mean i think one of the
difficulties in trying to get prices is
it all depends on what your insurance is
because they each negotiate different
rates and when they negotiate different
rates they also consider that
proprietary information that they don't
want to disclose that's what one of the
concerns was about the posting of prices
so i think it's very confusing but
you're right there was a ruling that
came out
a few years ago to require transparency
uh and have lists i don't know exactly
how well that's all been implemented yet
you may now ask your own question okay
thank you very much um
and i appreciate your pinch hitting
thank you for doing so you did a good
job and you did allude to a very
important factor that many of the
hospitals a large proportion of their
patients are
medicare and medicaid and we refer to
that as a payer mix for the various
things do you have any uh
thoughts about the implications for our
critical access hospitals
when we are going to skim off the high
revenue
paying patients
leaving them with only the low revenue
that is likely to lead to their closure
since they run on razor thin margins
they're thereby
losing access to obstetrical and
emergency services in many of our
hospitals that serve as critical access
hospitals do you have any concerns about
that uh yes but i think to the greater
point i mean specifically i do know
because my dad worked for the largest
health care provider in the state of
texas he actually worked with
insurances on how they set these prices
and i don't know if the statistic is
true it's probably 10 years old now but
he told me
this was back when i was in high school
that medicaid and medicare typically pay
like 80 percent of actual cost
um he said it was way underneath i don't
know it might be lower
so i i guess my my counter
you are you are correct in your
assertion uh there's no denying that my
counterpoint would be that's a problem
with medicaid and medicare that this the
state or this or the um the program as a
whole has to address is why it's not
properly paying for the services that
it's using those costs are already being
passed on
um
to the other patients including myself
i'm having health insurance right
you know that's how that works because a
hospital at the end of the day as much
as they may not like to admit it is a
business
and they do have to make payroll and i
do know from the business world that if
you're losing money on one customer it's
representative merchant was next and
mr chair thank you
and also representative thank you for
taking my question
it says in here direct payment
now does that imply that
i paid the bill but then i turned around
and sent the bill to my insurance
company to get reimbursed because that's
a back door into what you're trying to
avoid um no because it says is not
reimbursed or otherwise paid by a third
thank you this this i think everybody's
been trying to get at this but i'm going
to try and get at it a different way
uh
you talked to us a great deal about the
lack of transparency and fees and costs
and the concerns that everybody has that
one person is charged differently from
other people but isn't it true that this
bill
by its own wording
doesn't say anything about fees and
costs it just exempts
those facilities
who take direct payment that's
unreimbursed by anybody else and only
take that from having to serve anybody
who can't show up with their cash in
their hand
that's all this bill does it does
nothing to address the issue of the
differential payment problems is that
correct uh correct but you would still
if you're making a direct payment you're
still going to be able to find out what
you're paying so it's the the underlying
concept is still there but it's a fair
point
representative
thank you mr chairman and thank you
representative for being here and
presenting the bill for our colleague
as we're discussing this discrepancies
in payment um i think that the
difference between state reimbursed the
medicare and medicaid firs and insurance
companies makes a lot of sense but here
we're looking only at people who are
paying cash who will know what they're
paying for
so do you see these people paying out of
pocket as the people who are the ones
making up the cost of the of the
medicare and medicaid in the critical
access hospitals or do you see these as
just
a smaller group not the ones who are
being paid by insurance with all of
those big premiums behind them and
therefore not draining off
off our hospitals i view this as a very
small subset um if if if this were to
become law i would still have health
insurance we wouldn't go to a cash
system myself
thank you just like you don't have to
have car insurance but you know what i
renewed it last night
representative woods
uh thank you mr chair and thank you for
taking my question
we're talking dollars
but
in the midst that it is also quality was
there any discussion
uh when you were talking with your
physician or anybody else for that
matter
about the difference between the mri at
the hospital
versus the mri at the other facility
yeah so this is actually my favorite
part of the story i'm glad you brought
it up i got the exact same mri i would
have i still went to the hospital for
the mri
i just scheduled it
follow up follow up when you say you got
the same mri uh how would you interpret
that
it's the same machine at the same
location i don't think cmc has that many
mri machines
uh what about the
hospitals have different mris
uh are you aware that
a particular note uh called the power of
the magnets called tesla
saying that you are now way outside of
my scope well this is critically
important i'll give you an example why
this is critically important and it
should be transparent to patients and is
not i'm a retired
orthopedic hand surgeon
i've done a lot of technical things in
hand
a patient comes in workers comp
and
needs a wrist
evaluation by sending for an mri at a
facility that i know has the correct
tesla
the insurance company says no
you're going to go to another facility
that tesla
the magnet is not sufficiently powerful
to give the data the data came back norm
or the reading came back normal
i said no
the
magnet is not a sufficient size to give
the proper reading
for that for this particular entity the
basic uh
i was able to get it uh cleared through
workers comp hearing to get a higher
tesla which showed a terror in his
what's called the tfc in his wrist
that is critically important and it can
be for other entities as well
so i i
certainly understand the economics and
that should be transparent
and evened out but i think the patients
also need to be aware
that the physics that involved in mris
is not the same just because they have
an mri it's not the same in the next one
the tesla power can vary dramatically
in the same facility because they have
multiple mris representative would you
believe that i i would yes yes i would
thank you mr chairman and thank you for
allowing another question
my question is when
we're seeing people that have to jump
through the hoops of going through one
mri machine before getting to the one
that's correct by being in a direct
payment model and people choosing to
pursue their care through this direct
payment can they avoid that first one
that's the f that's the insurance first
gatekeeping step in order to receive the
proper quality of diagnosis without
having to do all of these different
checks in order to make sure in order to
do what right now people are doing to
limit cost in order to seek the
appropriate level of care the first time
correct it allows for the direct
purchasing of medical procedures so that
would be one of the medical procedures
that you could directly purchase and not
have to deal with the bureaucracy of
your insurance company or another
workers comp claim
thank you
representative gay
so this would mean that you would get
the service and if you have your own
insurance you would fight over the
insurance later but you would get the
service no no you would not so if if you
if you go through your insurance you
can't option you can't exercise this
option because that's a as
a
representative merchant pointed out or
was making the point it's uh that would
be a reimbursement later so you would be
you'd be circumventing that um so no you
could not do that okay representative
thank you mr chair and thank you for
taking my question
so what's to prevent a patient today
to go into a hospital any medical
facility
and pay cash to begin with because in
the world of pharmacy which is my
background
we have times in which the patient can
pay cash and avoid using their insurance
company so they don't come into the
bureaucracy of the insurance company
that they chose and said to do it by
cash why could this happen in this
situation too where patients would walk
into a er anywhere else if they wanted
to
pay cash and ask the questions
correct so they i i i will assume that
answers that is that they probably could
i do not know the answer to that i'll
let somebody behind me do that however
what this would do is allow a facility
to only take cash if they so chose
representative folsom
thank you chairman pearson and thank you
representative barry oh sorry i'm
just a clarification on the whole are
you reimbursed
over the holidays i was visiting my
brother and his wife
decided to purchase some health
insurance they looked around
and what she ended up with is once a
month
she receives the name of a person and
their address and she writes a check to
that person
and it's a cost sharing type of thing
and
so if she then goes to the doctor runs
up some bills
then she starts getting
checks ev every month until that's paid
off from people around the country
that's reimbursed but it's not through
an insurance company is there a way to
loop that in
so that would probably require once
again not holding myself up an expert on
this field um but it does say or
otherwise paid by a third party i would
consider that a third party but once
again
i think that's a question the committee
needs to solve
it's a very good question it sounds like
a good system i might be
maybe might be asking for some addresses
later
thank you mr chairman thank you for
taking my question would you believe
that i recently had to get an mri
and it needed to be done quickly
i
contacted a local hospital
uh in near my home
and they wanted fifteen hundred dollars
and i contacted another facility not
near my home and they wanted eight
hundred
so i was
able to choose
which facility i wanted to go to and i
did pay cash i had no insurance at that
time would you believe that i i would
believe that in fact um i believe
um one of my favorite people to watch in
the medical field is
nick valus with bedford ambulatory
and one of the things that he prides
himself with
is
is lowering the costs of ever of common
procedures and making them more
accessible to everyone um i think he had
one of the first uh
uh open mri machines is what they were
what they referred to um my
my fiancee and now wife had to it may
have been with some other i hope it was
an mri machine
um
and my my fiance my wife keep saying
fiance we were married in april um she's
extremely claustrophobic so she when she
had a workers comp issue she went there
so i'm very supportive whenever we can
reduce the cost of medicine especially
through the free market
and it's such a
intrinsically
flawed system to begin with and there's
just so much i don't even know how you
guys deal with it all it's it's so
tangled up and
it's no wonder why it's grossly
expensive representative barry we really
being a quick study on this subject but
we do have a couple people behind you
who are probably a little bit more
expert i am more than happy to stop and
get out of the hot seat you might like
to yield to them thank you he's yielding
the chair recognizes paula minihan from
the new hampshire hospital association
she has handouts and she is rising to
good morning mr chairman members of the
committee for the record my name is
paula minihan senior vice president
state government relations for the new
hampshire hospital association
representing all our hospitals in the
state we are opposed to this bill we
have concerns that this bill would
impede access to services if a health
care facility is not required to have a
charity care policy in place
we also have questions about the intent
of the legislation and what the sponsor
is attempting to address
the statute being amended by this bill
is specific to health care facilities
licensed under rsa 151 colon 2.
roman 1 a or d and every person holding
a special healthcare service license
under
151 colon 2e
those include hospitals and facilities
such as ambulatory surgery centers
hospice facilities urgent care centers
and or birthing centers
in addition healthcare special
healthcare license would be cardiac cath
laboratory services open heart coronary
artery bypass
graft surgery and mega voltage what i
did not name
was
what representative berry was talking
about radiology services are not
licensed under the state of new
hampshire so
um
if people want to go and well first of
all like representative merchants said
you can go and pay cash wherever you
would like if you choose not to use your
insurance what this does is really
bypass the requirement for charity care
policy and i think that is a very
dangerous approach to
allow health care facilities to not
provide charity care policies that is
fundamental
to ensuring access to care
and um so you can pay out of pocket if
you want but again
that's
the charity care policy is really what
is impacted by this that it would allow
the state of new hampshire to license
facilities and not require them to have
charity care policies i think that's
that is something that um
is
i think really problematic um it also
would allow for these types of
facilities to exclusively provide
services to persons who make direct
payment and to not have charity care
policies as i said
we of course the hospitals fall under
this policy or the statute provide care
to all patients regardless of their
ability to pay
we do not believe it's in the best
interest of the patients seeking care in
these facilities to not be assured that
the facility maintain a charity care
policy and to rep to representative
knurk's point
that this would be
a negative impact to all facilities and
certainly the critical access hospitals
because their margins are so low
and their
payer mix of medicare and medicaid are
so high as well as uncompensated care
so again
this is would really negatively impact
them i'm also not aware of any licensed
health care facility that only accepts
payments directly from a patient that
would mean that the facility would not
accept any form of insurance including
medicare medicaid and third party
we do not believe this bill is
appropriate and we ask that you find
this bill in expedient to legislate it's
worth noting this exact bill was
introduced last year by the same sponsor
and heard in this committee your
committee voted 18 to 3 in expedient to
legislate but due to time constraints
during the house session back in
february of 21 the bill was special
ordered to the next session day and was
ultimately not voted on it was we always
call it the miscellaneous category
that's where this bill landed last year
so um we asked that you vote this in
expedient to legislate as you did last
year i'm happy to answer any questions
but i did want to address a couple
things i think it's
people use the word getting
priced differently by different care
there is no different pricing um
hospitals have a charge master which is
about 50 000 codes um probably more um
representative merchants shaking his
head um and so the charge is a charge is
a charge what's different is the
reimbursement and so in addition so i
think that's important to
to acknowledge that they're not charged
differently they're charged the same
what an uninsured person gets because of
the law that's on the books in new
hampshire is they have a discounted rate
if they are if they're
what's called self-pay actually what's
kind of been i think kind of ironic is
hospitals have to fall under that
self-pay policy which reduces their
reimbursement their
their what they
bill to the individual that's
uninsured
but a lot of other um
facilities don't it doesn't apply to
them um so i think that's kind of ironic
um the other thing is the no surprises
act um is what everyone's talking about
that is the transparency bill that was
passed by congress and is being
implemented as we speak
the hospitals
there's a bunch of
parts of that that went into effect in
21 and now the carriers
in 22 just this month are responsible
for certain components of it it's very
complex lots and lots of components to
it
you will find the hospitals have to and
they do
by law they have to
post their charges on their
websites which they do um i will readily
admit it's um it's a bit cumbersome
because i mentioned there are 50 000
codes so it's it's a bit cumbersome but
that is what the law says so
um
and then in addition to that hospitals
do provide
services and they they answer questions
for individuals help them if they have a
question i would contend that a patient
financial services person is better
equipped to answer a question versus an
ed doc relative to what an mri would
cost but
um
regardless it's on their website so i am
happy to answer any questions but again
our hospitals have worked diligently to
ensure that they are providing care to
all members
of the public and
again i i encourage you all to go on
their websites and i'm happy to answer
thank you mr chairman and thank you for
taking the question and being here today
i know reimbursement is a really
challenging issue and it's one that i've
dealt with a lot in the past i'm curious
what percentage of care is paid at the
charge master rate
relative to those that are discounted
off through either the
reimbursement rates the self-pay
discount the cms and the medicaid
discounts do we have anyone paying full
vote
likely not
i mean no because they either fall under
insurance or they they
raise their hand they say i'm self
i don't have any insurance or on
self-pay and then they are required it
doesn't matter if you're a millionaire
or if you um
just happen to not have any insurance
and unable to pay for it uh able to pay
for insurance they must by law
provide them that discount so i think
basically no one's paying
charge master rates
follow-up
and as a follow-up
when when prices are going to be
provided will it be that charge master
rate and so then people pretty much know
what they're maxed out on for the
payment but they can't but they're not
sure where it'll actually fall
it i am not an expert when it comes to
the no surprises act my prior job before
i did this job at the hospital
association um 20 years ago was working
in reimbursement so i as i am as well
very versed in this but not in the last
six years so
um
they um again you i encourage you to go
on their websites and see and the
insurers are also responsible for for
providing that information i believe
they actually have to show what
depending on what your insurance is what
the um what the
balance is that you would be due but
remember they're very high deductible
plans now so
that has nothing to do with a hospital
that has to do with your insurance
but for self pay
again the there are self-paid discounts
if you go to the department of insurance
website you will see what those
self-paid discounts are on their health
cost website that is another really good
resource that i know this committee has
had
presentations by the department the
self-paid discounts are right on the
website so that is also um
um for anyone to to
access thank you i would have needed
cardiac care if i had to pay the 80 000
build for my leg it was only 25k
representative soloway
thank you mr chairman
milligan always good to see you nice to
see you
um
24 hours
the way the bill is written
it says unless the facility
exclusively
provides services to persons who make
direct payments for services
exclusively
does this mean
that a healthcare professional
a physical therapist occupational
therapist speech therapist um
perhaps even you know a camp surgeon who
can hang a sign out in their office
saying we do not accept
insurance
you must self-pay
and therefore we can charge what we want
to charge does this then create a
two-tier system in which people who have
the ability to pay out of pocket
get private services
people who rely on health insurance have
to go to different providers
and these i'm going to call them
entrepreneurial
providers
thereby avoid the cost the paper
processing cost of filing for insurance
is that what happens well
this bill wouldn't do that per se
because it's the statute they're
changing um physicians physical
therapists speak all the professionals
that you mentioned are not don't
don't fall under the statute this is
health facilities they fall under oplc
they fall under their individual
clinical licenses um so they're not
licensed that way in the state of new
hampshire they and that's considered
what i think
representative marsh would call
concierge medicine right um so
that is allowable um now um and i i know
that there are some um certainly
positions um that that offer that like
you said you have to you i don't quite
understand the
mechanics but i think you either pay a
monthly fee i'm looking at
the doctors in the in the room you pay a
monthly fee maybe an annual fee and then
you get certain number of visits and
then whatever it is um so
direct primary thank you yes i call it
concierge medicine but
my my daughter always corrects me she's
a family doc and she says no it's direct
primary care mom my wife is a family dog
and we do it for poor people because we
don't have any rich people coming to us
[Laughter]
um
so
i don't know that i answered your
question except that's not what this
bill does i guess um and it's still
allowable i would say but we can open a
facility
that offers a wide variety of services
that comes under this bill it just has
to be a facility we can open a
corporation we can have offices we can
have a building
does that then become a healthcare
facility
as i was just looking at the
department's website i will
they license for instance residential
care facilities they license um
nursing homes they license laboratory
walk-in centers urgent care centers ascs
laboratories hospitals they don't
license um
a doctor's office they they just don't
um if it's an if it's an ambulatory
surgery center like concord orthopedics
has an ambulatory surgery center that
has to be licensed the doctor's office
per se
um
home care um hospital i mentioned
um so
that's the difference it's just kind of
not a quirk but it's just you that's
just the way our licensing statute works
um
what i think this does is establish a my
concern is this establishes in state law
that the that the department would
actually license facilities that don't
take all comers that don't um accept
patients that can't can't pay
that don't accept medicaid it it just
that doesn't make sense to me that the
state of new hampshire would support
that when they are
they they focus the department of hhs
focuses on trying to take care of the
most vulnerable in our population thank
you for your wisdom has been ahead you
representative cushman
thank you mr chairman and thank you for
taking my question
so as we're having this discussion um
what's coming to my mind is so in new
hampshire there's no opportunity for
alternative health care systems to prop
up that do not take medicare and
medicaid
so we are restricted to all of our
you know pretty much the majority except
direct primary care offices
to
following medicare and medicaid uh the
centers for medicare and medicaid
services regulations
so that means that all of the health
care workers who were disenfranchised by
the biden administration cms mandate now
have no
have a very limited pool of
options when it comes to employment
is that what i'm
so
for the state of new hampshire um they
are they have to be licensed
to provi as i stated all those
facilities if you want to open a
facility and again in order to ensure
that there's access for all
then they must be willing to accept um
care for have a charity care policy they
i do not and i
henry littman is here the director of
medicaid so he can answer
better than i i don't know that they
must take medicare and medicaid
to be a licensed health care facility i
have to i actually
they don't henry's shaking his head no
so they don't
so you're when you mention the biden
mandate you're referring to
their requirement that all
all facilities that actually accept
medicaid and medicare services ensure
that their
their staff is um
in order to provide safe care uh have
are vaccinated so again if they're
medicaid and medicare which all our
hospitals are
they do fall under that requirement
follow-up
so
um it is my understanding that they are
required they are required to accept all
pay sources um so that would include
medicare and medicaid but um
on the
subject of uh so excuse me can i answer
that question so a nurse practitioner
can
i just ask the nurse practitioner you're
just you're saying what i
what i didn't didn't say what a nurse
practitioner can can practice um
independent in the state of new
hampshire so they don't need to take
they could practice independently right
but hospitals and uh ambulatory surgery
centers we can't do that without
accepting medicare and medicaid
we can't set up those kind of facilities
under this section without accepting all
payers
so there's no option to set up
alternative health care systems in new
hampshire that don't take
medicare and medicaid and therefore have
to follow those regulations
so
again i'd have to look at the licensing
regs but you do not have to you have to
take
all comers
in order to be
a licensed healthcare facility so my
follow-up question
was
to the point of a mandatory charity care
policy
i am a direct primary care consumer and
there's nothing requiring my physician
to have a charity care
option or policy in place but they do
offer
a sliding scale and uh doesn't
the idea of a mandated charity fly in
the face of what charity actually is
um
i believe it
ensures access to to care for all so i
think i just that's my position okay the
chair's
fascinated by this discussion and i'm
sure it will come up again and again i'm
not quite sure that it needs to come up
right now on this bill
so let's focus very narrowly onto this
bill in our questions representative gay
thank you thank you very much
line five
says unless the facility exclusively
provides services to persons who make
direct payment so that would say that
this is not in the category we're
talking about a facility that is not in
the category that excludes charitable
uh charitable what is the right phrase
charitable charity care plan charity
care so this bill doesn't even talk
about establishing a facility that would
provide only
direct care and not charitable
so
i think i think we're putting in another
the facility no if you read the current
law is the first part that's not bolded
adopt and enforce a written policy to
ensure that the facility provides its
services to all persons who require the
services regardless of their source of
payment that means
um
all that you accept all
and those that don't don't have
insurance and those that do
i
and there is
looking at the bill i'm just leaving
you may follow up yes thank you uh
this is just saying
to me this is this bill is saying that
you can provide services to people who
but they can't
do this unless they are offering
charitable care
i
i'm not reading it that way oh these
double negatives are difficult so and it
says
so this is under health facilities
licensing statute it's a pretty big
statute and
so a piece of it is relative to
what representative mclean added unless
the facility exclusively provides
services to persons who make direct
payment for services he doesn't define
well he does actually a direct payment
is one that is paid
directly by the patient and is not
reimbursed or otherwise paid by a third
party
so
that is saying what that would mean is
that the facility does not have to
follow does not have to take all comers
if they only do direct payments
and that means that you would not accept
medicaid medicaid and and not
one more i read exactly the opposite
okay because it says you would allow all
i can see in this bill is that you allow
people to come and purchase
a service
but there's two caveats one is the
facility
has to provide services for everybody
because it's exclusively
can't make direct payment they can't
just say we're only going to take people
who make direct payment
and the other caveat is that they can't
even have insurance where some policies
some of these bills that we've studied
before
you could go
to a and pay directly and submit your
paperwork yourself to your insurance so
this has two caveats in it to me it
sounds like it's perfectly
perfectly fair and safe and it would not
impact the hospital that's trying to
uh except for their particular cost
their that one patient
they still have to provide charitable
care because
they can't even use a facility that
exclusively provides services to people
who make direct payment
i'm i'm going to wave off what i hoped
was a clarification and save it for your
executive session i think that's wise um
we are and urge others to do the same
and i would thank you i agree with her
uh representative leon was next
thank you thank you again mr chairman uh
this looks that it's only in 151 to f1
the charity care is in the section too
do you see this applying more broadly to
all of the rules or simply about
requiring all payers because the way i'm
reading this you they still need to
provide
they need to provide adopt publicize and
apply an assistance plan for persons the
uninsured doesn't matter in this or who
do not have financial resources to pay
for the facility services due to
financial hardship
i'm going to let my testimony stand on
thank you mr chair but on the wisdom of
representative weber i also wave off
representative canaric
i was actually suggested we might see if
somebody from dhhs might be able to
provide the clarity on this but
we went through this two years ago and i
have one year yeah
okay representative acton
i thank you mr chair and not thank you
paula again for taking our questions
my question is regarding the charity
care policy itself
you know in in and i was in medical i.t
for for 10 years so i i'm familiar with
a lot of this too it seems like everyone
i talked to outside of the system says
it's fundamentally broken
those inside the system defended um
rather staunchly my my concern and maybe
i'm wrong but
it seems to me that the charity care
policy
is maybe used to shut down innovation
from the insiders that are already
working to to shut down any type of new
innovation new offerings to uh people
because of this onerous charity care
policy is can only be handled by the big
guys so
the affordable care act and um you know
believes that all everyone should have
access to services and hospitals support
that and believe
robust charity care policies for all
facilities
ensure that there is no um
um you know
cherry-picking of um of those that are
unable to afford care so we we support
charity care policies for all and i'm
going to thank ms minahan for her coming
up here and then i'm going to call on
greg moore from americans for prosperity
new hampshire to come up and he's
thank you mr chairman members of the
committee
for the record my name is greg moore i'm
the state director with americans for
prosperity in new hampshire and i'm here
to testify in support of house bill
1044.
um first i want to acknowledge the
sponsor and he is like a dog with uh
bone with this particular
piece of legislation um he
he will get on top of you and
we support this legislation frankly we
would support much broader deregulatory
uh
work in this space but we do believe
that as a former speaker once told me
that if he hit enough singles you score
still score runs so i think this is a
positive step
i think there's a little bit of a lot of
questions raised so i think there's a
lot of history that that
probably should be raised in terms of
context so that the committee
understands
uh back prior to 2016
we had what's known as a health
facilities review and licensing board
which we
most people will call a certificate of
need board we had what we call the con
board prior to 2016.
and
that con board basically served as a
boardware if someone wanted to get a
a facility wanted to open a facility
they would go to this board they would
petition this board in order to get what
amounts to a permission slip in order to
open a facility
that the process to on why not began in
when the legislature passed a law to
phase out the certificate of need board
that was brought at the behest of one
particular provider who wanted to come
into this state that's the cancer
treatment centers of america um and and
whether you like the certificate of need
board dislike the certificate board it
was definitely a bulky and cumbersome
process when i was working as a director
at dhhs
this is back in the pleistocene era that
only i think representative mcmahon and
representative mckay may remember um i
actually had a chance to participate in
a number of these uh health facility
review and licensing uh committee
meetings the uh the bottom line is the
bottom line is is that the legislation
made the decision in 2011 to
unwind the certificate of need board
and in the process of unwinding a
certificate of need board there was
legislation that was brought forward
in 2016 that that created this section
right here so that's how we got to where
we are in terms of in terms of the
timing
um
and i remember that the process to
unwind in 2011 because i was working for
the house at the time so that was that
was uh that was a process to to get
there
our
medical needs are evolving very quickly
particularly after 2014 with sort of the
implementation of the affordable care
act which basically has changed the
healthcare landscape
one of the consequences of which here in
new hampshire is we have a number of
people who have these high deductible
health plan bills
health plan
insurance
and as well as some other health care
innovations like direct primary care
which is an evolving subject i know
representative folsom mentioned her
friend who has that
and certainly enough people some people
are beginning to go that route uh
typically what you get with a with a
concierge care or direct primary care
treatment plan is you get a high
deductible health plan i.e a
catastrophic policy on top of your your
concierge care direct primary care
payment
and so what is creating is an
environment here in the state where we
have a large number of people having
these hierarchical health plans
according to new hampshire business
review new hampshire has the highest
usage on a percentage basis of high
deductible health plans and perhaps more
concerningly they have uh they have uh
the the highest deductibles among family
plans of any state in the nation so we
have a lot of people who have these
plans and sometimes they have
direct primary care underneath them
sometimes they have
an hsa underneath them but frankly
there's often a big gap between what
you're paying out of pocket before you
hit that cap
so
i know representative mclean is looking
for solutions to try to solve for that
problem i think he might have a high
deductible health plan so i think he's
walked a mile in these shoes so i think
he's looking for opportunities for more
transparency as well as an opportunity
to allow people to offer more affordable
care for people who are paying up until
they hit that that i mean after they hit
after you hit your cap you become fairly
price insensitive right because then the
insurance company is going to carry the
rest of the rest of the load but up
until you hit that point there is
definitely a case in which you can be
paying five ten thousand dollars out of
your pocket which is a significant
impact for a lot of people and i will
just tell you at a personal level as
someone who's in the public policy run
we do a lot of polling this is a
consistently top three issue the the
cost of health care among new hampshire
citizens so
what house bill 1044 is looking to do is
to try to create a vehicle outside of
the regulation that was created in 2016
to allow for people to have have
facilities and again facilities are a
whole host of things that the department
licenses
whether it's medical imaging like mri
and cat scans or lab work uh there were
a lot of things that would come in at a
price point well below
what what people who are taking these
high deductible health plans are would
see and they would benefit from a more
transparent lower cost alternative
as they as they go about doing this i
will tell you that as representative
leon pointed out
this bill
affects section one of 152 151 2f it
does not affect section 2 relative to
charity care that's still in place
and
one of the other things i think to the
point representative dr konnick pointed
out about critical access hospitals this
does not affect um
this does not affect
uh 198.2
uh
198 colon 2 which is that 15 mile radius
surrounding a critical access hospital
uh so that that still would be intact so
that this would be unchanged in order to
build a facility within that 15 mile
radius
you would still have to go through the
198.2 process in order to be able to to
get that so
allowing the for these direct
direct payment model of facilities
that you would still you still just
couldn't drop it into that 15 mile
radius so they would still have those
protections so i think it's important to
address that because i think that was an
issue that was raised a year ago and i
think but i think that that the
legislature has taken a pathway to
protect those critical access hospitals
and it is that 198 to
protections that are in there and this
this bill does not change any of that so
what this bill does i think
you're not
no one's going to build a direct payment
hospital no one's building a
acute care hospital and says we're only
going to take cash
i think what you're looking at are those
facilities that are again under what
we're seeing these high deductible
health plans capped at and i think so i
think what you're looking at are lab lab
work
some medical imaging and maybe like a
colonoscopy i think that's probably the
sum total of what you're seeing because
as i said once people hit those caps
of their high deductible health plan
they become fairly price insensitive and
so that i think is
is an important thing to consider as
well and i've already talked for quite a
long time so i'd be happy to take any
questions from the committee
representative
yes thank you very much and thanks for
pointing out the 198.2 i i served on the
committee that worked on that
bill the thing that you kept making
comments about high deductible health
plans
but i thought we all agreed that this
was only if the person was paying
directly for services
and so therefore that's totally
irrelevant because it's not going you
know if you have a hydrational health
plan you've got a health plan
the way you meet your deductible is
you've got to submit those charges to
your insurance they don't cover them
but you're still submitting them if you
don't submit them then that high
deductible still sits there because it's
not getting whittled away it gets
whittled away as your as your
dem as your requirement or your payment
your bill does not get paid by the
insurance that's your cost sharing
so
that argument doesn't carry any weight
this is for people who are going to walk
in and play what we used to call cash on
the barrel
you're going to walk in and say i i want
to do this so
and i appreciate the 15 mile thing but i
have to confess for those of us in the
north country we drive over 15 miles to
get anywhere for anything
and with that in mind uh the even though
that
helped a lot with the
urgent care type of setting
and that's a lot what that 1982 is about
do you still not think that there would
be a potential that we are going to skim
off the high revenue producing
patients from a
from critical access hospitals who are
running on razor thin margins or in the
red as their normal
situation
and leave them without the revenue just
with the lower revenue or the charity
care
for you thank you for the question uh so
as the first part of the payments to a
facility
the payments to a facility that took
direct payment only
would still be able to add up to your
deductible
but your insurance company isn't going
to know about that it is not going to
credit you to your deductible because
the way it gets credited to your
deductible is that it is submitted to
the insurer
they refuse to pay it because it's under
your deductible
i will say that that other states that
have offered cash only models have not
seen that experience
um but to your
to your your question about uh about the
critical access hospitals i've certainly
spent a lot of time working through that
when i was when i was with the
department
um
obviously they get enhanced medicare
reimbursement
um
they've been taken care of from the
medicaid side as well um and they get
some enhanced reimbursements there so
that they're they're getting um a number
of enhancements
but i would say that the policy the
legislature has set for protecting
critical access hospitals is the 198
cohen ii that is a policy that
that this committee and the legislature
as a whole has taken and i i think that
you either have a policy or or then your
policy is wrong
um and you
then then you find ways to adjust 198
too but
i would say that that there are a lot of
other areas in the state in the southern
tier of the state that frankly could
benefit from having a new opportunity
that ultimately
would be harmed by not having that
opportunity
and my advice to you is that if you're
concerned about the critical access
piece would be to
bring some legislation relative to 198
too
follow
up have to do with special uh license
facilities those are
mega voltage radiation and freestanding
radiology and so on i was thinking that
i'm
it's just special health care services
so it's broader than hospitals
but the critical access designation
which which comes from the from the from
cms
um actually i think 198 statute has to
do with school money i think we got the
wrong number i do know which one you're
talking about but i'm blanking on the
number right now oh okay i i apologize i
was reading reading a title from from
senate bill 481 it is rsa 151 for
yes
and as you can see in the the
certification it's a cfr which means
it's a federal designation
that's in uh bullet six
yes but if i recall
okay
i'm not sure we might we probably should
do this offline because we're wasting
time during the hearing yep um so thank
you though so
thank you mr chairman and also thank you
for taking my question
because i asked the same question that i
asked miss minahan
i first of all commend what you're
trying to do as far as greater
consumerism and health care and trying
to bring down the cost healthcare i just
don't know if this is the way to go
about doing it
my concern is and the question to you is
that what is to guarantee that when a
patient goes into a cash paying only
facility that they will actually pay
less than going to another facility that
doesn't have only cash paying customers
number two
when you have a patient today who can go
on to many websites
and decide like i think representative
lima delemus did you can go on and look
for different
rates and prices if you will today so as
a cash paying customer with a high
deductible today
i can go out and look at what the lab's
going to charge what the
mri is going to be and so forth and do
thank you for the question
it's funny i was working in 2004 at the
department when we put together the
health healthcare pricing and
transparency um website with the
department of insurance it was a joint
effort between the two
and i think that that is a dramatically
underutilized tool
that said i would say that
if you're going to take cash
then it's not it's necessary that you
have to be completely transparent about
what your costs are
to the point of of earlier speakers
there may be a charge master but how
much you're paying is going to be a
direct relationship to
your insurance company of the new deal
they've negotiated with the facility
or medicare or medicaid
although those folks don't usually pay
out-of-pocket costs but but if you're if
you are insured
if you are insured
that the amount you will pay will vary
can vary quite widely from the charge
master
follow-up
thank you my understanding is on the
website i'd be wrong about this
but there's also a list there for
self-pay what the cash price would be if
you're paying it in cash so therefore if
i'm a
paying customer
i have access to the data today to make
an intelligent choice without going
through a change in legislation uh yes
and that and that actually is to your
earlier point which is that if there
were facilities that took direct payment
only
you could go and compare their prices
with uh with the prices of other other
more traditional facilities so you would
have that ability and again i think that
i tell people all the time which is that
website is dramatically underused and i
and and frankly if you saw that that a
more traditional facility could offer a
better price to a cash-only payment i
would say that i would say that that
that's great too
i think i think giving consumers more
options is a great thing
the chair has asked
house committee services if they would
do some research prior to our executing
this bill as to what other states are
doing on the same thing and they
responded that they would be doing such
research
representative cushman
thank you mr chairman and thank you mr
moore for
taking my question
uh so concerning the
15-mile rule
and the idea
of
lowering payments
wouldn't it be
looking at this from a free market
perspective
the
decreased administrative costs of not
having to
provide insurance and have that overhead
would likely result in lower prices for
the consumer it may not guarantee that
they would be lower than surrounding
areas but
knowing that there is that price
comparison it would incentivize those
price those
facilities to offer lower prices and
wouldn't that couldn't that be a benefit
for people in the north country
especially when there would be a charity
yes downward price pressure always helps
consumers i think that's that's just
makes sense uh
but i i would say that i would say that
uh
there has been there have been some
studies done that showed that medical
billing and other overhead costs can
amount to up to 35 of health care costs
so that's an overhead that everyone has
to carry there's a
a trade group for independent physicians
that recommends for each individual
physician that they have
uh two assistants to focus on things
like billing
so think about that kind of overhead
versus
versus uh the
sorry opportunities uh opportunities
perhaps to get outside of that system
and lose that overhead and you could
so to get back to the specifics of this
bill
am i correct in thinking that all that
contrary to what was implied
by the previous questioner
currently
all the facilities with this kind of
license
have to have a charity care policy
and what this bill does
is it exempts
these are the words on the page here
what's already in statute the stuff
that's not in bold says that every
facility with this kind of license
has to adopt and enforce a written
policy
uh
that that the to assure that the
facility provides a services to all
persons who require the services
regardless of the source of payment
um
for services provided to everybody so
they have to have a charity policy
that's what the law is now
because that's the stuff that's not in
bold
all that this does is it exempts from
that policy
the requirement to provide charity
services
it exempts those services who
are pure cash only
services so isn't it true
that
the savings
let me back up a bit um
what
what what they're
trying to get at
is two kinds of savings one is
uh
not having to
have the billing personnel available to
uh
do
all the billing and the 550 000 billing
codes and they also get the savings of
not having to take people who don't pay
so that's what this bill does it exempts
simply exempts the facilities
that only take direct pay so it's only
for one
specific
business model
within
this group of licensees is that correct
thank you for the question
representative uh
as far as the first one i guess broadly
to simplify this bill right now if you
wanted to open a facility a health care
facility which is
the whole list you could go regardless
of the type of facility regardless of
the type of facility if you wanted to
open one that took direct payments only
it would be illegal in the state of new
hampshire so this legislation would
legalize your ability to open a facility
to do that as far as the charity care
it's unfortunate that
that the language of the bill only
includes section one of rsa
151 2f
because section 2 of that very same
statute reads that in order to get a
facilities license in other words in
order to get a license from dhhs to open
a facility you must adopt publicize and
apply an assistance plan for persons who
are uninsured uninsured or who do not
have financial resources to pay a
facility of service due to financial
hardship this legislation does not touch
does not touch that statute okay so
what section one is so that's section
two what section one is is
uh again back um back in 2011 when the
cancer treatment centers of america
wanted to come into new hampshire
um and when they wanted uh to
to uh
basically get rid of the certificate
need board which again took took five
a little historical context is
is that the cancer treatment centers of
america do not take
all payers and i think that there was a
great concern that ctca
would come into new hampshire and put a
lot of pressure on the other oncology
providers across the state and so
my impression sitting through the the
the
sitting through the
for the senate bill 481 hearings and the
discussion surrounding it was that it
was in part to ensure that that one
provider not come to the state of new
hampshire
in fact it was said that fairly
explicitly on the senate side
it is the chair's belief that the last
question and the answer to it
spoke directly to the bill
we've gone down various quite
interesting but time-consuming bunny
trails so now i'm going to thank you mr
moore and i am going to bring this
hearing to a close
and
have at it folks the committee services
is going to give us some information and
on we go
we are very late and i apologize for
having a very slow gavel on
bunny trails
we now
open the hearing on house bill 1526
relative to income eligibility for in
and out medical assistance the chair
recognizes the prime sponsor our very
own representative snow and i would say
to someone in the public the only part
of the pink card you did not fill out
was your name
and i'm going to walk it down yes thank
you so while representative snow comes
thank you mr chairman
and thank you members of the committee
for your patience i'm sorry about my
late arrival today but it was for
unavoidable circumstances and i'm glad
that i was able to get here before the
bill actually began
this is house bill 1626 and it reads
that this is relative to the income
eligibility for in and out medicaid
i thought before we began talking about
this bill there are some new members of
this committee that weren't here last
year
when we looked at the original bill
which was 1639
and that was a bill about in and out
medicaid and adjusting
the
the income eligibility for that
particular benefit that was affordable
what the what we were seeking to do was
to find a way for persons
low-income persons
who were uninsured
who had income that was slightly above
the maximum income eligibility threshold
as standard in other words they earned
maybe a little bit too much or quite a
bit more
than what the income eligibility would
allow
however they also had ongoing medical
expenses
and uh that were medicaid eligible if
they had medicaid
that went well beyond the what they
could afford to pay out of the income
that they had at this time
this has been in place for a number of
years
and it's worked out extremely well
however the one factor about it is the
that maximum income eligibility
is set at for a single individual
is set at 591 dollars a month
which means that if you were under 591
dollars a month you're automatically
eligible
for that service however if your income
goes a little over that
and yet you have expensive medical
expenses what this bill allows you to do
is to spend down on those expenses that
you now
incur
until you reach that threshold and from
that point on you do receive the
medicaid benefits for the rest of the
month when we passed 1636
the
income eligibility we worked closely
with the department of health and human
services this committee did and others
to come up with a new threshold the new
threshold and i'm not going to talk
about larger numbers i think if we want
to get into details about that we can
have the people from health and human
services answer that but i'm going to
just talk about the single individual
the threshold for them went from 591 up
to 901 dollars a month
that means that what we were saying is
that people who fell in between
those two things if they were earned
more than 591 but now earned less
than 901
they would be eligible to be moved from
the medicaid in and out program
into the regular medicaid program and
turned over to one of the three managed
care companies that manage the benefits
under the medicare program and that has
been seen by this body and the
department is a more effective way to
manage medicaid programs under the in
and out they're still operating on a
fee-for-service basis because that's
really the only way they can do it
what with this bill is when when we
passed this it by the way
1639 was passed by this body
in fact it was the lead bill
in that whole health care bill
that went
went to the
fiscal committee to be determined
in house bill 2.
house bill 2 and considering it
liked the bill i think i hope from what
i understand they like the bill but felt
they couldn't afford it so what they did
was they suspended the additional money
didn't change the bill it still remained
with the old
threshold
but they said for the next biennium the
old threshold would take place
what we're attempting to do when we work
on house bill
um
is to seek
a repeal of that suspension for the
second year of this biennium
so we can move from the 5 91 threshold
to the 901 for the second year and then
according to the statute it
automatically goes to the new thing at
the beginning of the next biennium which
was what it was originally called for so
that's relatively simple
i'm not going to spend an awful lot of
time on it because the detail work
i i have to applaud the staff from
health and human services henry lippman
and his staff did a phenomenal job in
working with us and working this out and
there's a fountain of information when
you ask i know where he stores all that
information and he's he's also got what
do you call it
when you can call up information and it
just comes right away
he's got yeah he's really got that in
his head
in any case uh
there are
i think one of the things that we need
to understand is under the old thing it
was a real burden for many of the uh
for many of the uh
clients that we serve
they become very anxious when they're
not sure if they're in or out with their
benefits
when am i going to be qualified to get
my benefits
this for them would solve that anxiety
that they might experience and also
the other is it creates a huge problem
for the providers of services for people
with severe and persistent mental
illness
and there's a
large number of them that are on the in
and out program of the people are on in
and out for a variety of different
reasons they all aren't because of
mental illness there are a lot number of
other
medical problems that can
be brought into being for that and i
don't have really any information about
that but they would but there was a
there's about 2500 people with severe
and persistent mental illness that the
community mental health centers are
required to provide service to under a
contract that we have and that we have
to serve them or they have to serve them
regardless of their ability to pay
so when people are out of their benefit
the mental health centers have to
continue to provide all their services
until they reach that threshold
and then from that point on
they are able to collect
now you need to understand when they're
in the out part of it when they're not
we're not only losing the state money
that's part of medicaid we're also
losing that 50
federal share
and in 2019 and i believe last year i
haven't seen the exact figures for last
year but i can't imagine that it went
down last year with all that's going on
in mental health
the mental health centers lost over
seven million dollars
in
bad debt
that they had to eat as part of their
budget
this bill would substantially reduce
that
by taking and the estimate is and the
best estimate we can come up with is
somewhere between 30 and 40 percent of
the people that are now
being treated uh
within and out would automatically move
over because their income would now be
below that 901
they would automatically shift over to
that fif to that managed care option
with medicaid
which in a lot of ways is is much better
and
that that would substantially reduce the
amount of bad debt that these another
that work with these people
that aren't affected by this pharmacies
cannot fill prescriptions for people
unless they have the cash to pay for it
so imagine the trickery of being a
client and knowing you have to pick up a
prescription
and the challenge to mental health
centers if some these are people who are
often requiring rather intensive
services
to help them maintain a level of
recovery that's optimal for them
and often they have to take medications
to control the symptoms that make it
difficult for them to achieve that
some of these medications are extremely
expensive
so mental health centers and others that
provide services have to look at how can
we be sure
that the majority of these prescriptions
are written during a period of time when
they're on the in part of the medicaid
program
when we have to do like with a new
client when we're not sure
then you really have to hustle sometimes
you're looking for free samples from
sales people sometimes you're looking
for help from the actual drug company
sometimes you'll look for alternatives
but it's it's a tricky business
and requires a lot of staff time and a
lot of frustration i worked in this
field for 48 years i've been retired for
eight i'm very glad i don't have to deal
with this kind of a problem every day
from now on but we have some people here
today that are continuing to deal with
this and i think they're
in a much better position to speak to
the frustration that providers feel both
because of
the
loss in debt and also the problems
caused by other providers
uh
i i think at this point i'm just trying
to think if there's any other very
important
points that i should make at this point
i think there are people in this
audience that are in a much better
position to answer your questions
than than me and so i'm gonna
maybe i didn't cut a chart i'm known as
a big talker but
in any case i do think i will
sit down but i really ask for your
consideration this is a group of people
people with
severe and persistent mental illness
is a group that i've worked with all of
my career and i worked i was a social
worker in
mental health field for 50 years
these are people
who i have developed a great deal of
respect for
they are people who are strong
they're persistent
and they're dealing in a circumstance
in a world beginning to understand
what
the world they're living in stigma has
improved substantially in the last few
years but ladies and gentlemen we got a
long way to go to have these people be
being an equal footing with all the rest
of us that suffer various illnesses i
have very little stigma because i have
to walk around on a walker
but i have if i have problems with
chronic depression that stigma still
exists
this will be a big step towards helping
them move ahead in that and i'm getting
the high side for my chairman and i
should be quiet and i will
thank you
so much we are honored to have you in
our committee with your years and
decades of experience
are you yielding questions i will be
happy to answer questions but i do think
technical questions are much better
directed towards mr lipman or i did see
in the audience uh the director from
lakes region would that be the mr
lippman who is in the process of filling
out a pink card i hope it is yes
we should have a standing order on a
pink card well maybe i think maybe
maybe maybe i should have referred to
usually i check with him first but mr
lipman is the man that i've
that i've dealt with over the phone and
in meetings all the way along
before we get to him though i'm going to
thank you and i'm going to ask for holly
stevens to come up
can we do that
from nami she's moved she's going to
give us a news update on her new job
do you want
uh laminate this
yeah can we raise the chairs because
you have to flip the chair over i think
to
adjust it let's see
yeah
we're not just now you feel like you're
committee where you are yeah forget it
when you wish to refer to the chair of
this committee in the negative please
thank you welcome and give us an update
you're working for a different group now
yes holly stevens i'm here for nami new
hampshire i want to apologize i don't
think i have enough copies for everybody
i put in 26 to copy it and i think i
counted them and there's like only 13.
so when i get back to the office i am
going to email
i will give my copy to
i will yeah and i can give my copy um to
now that we're squatters in this great
room we have a photocopying machine
right through that wall so we're good so
i do apologize still getting used to the
new equipment um
thank you for allowing me to testify
today
my name is holly stevens and i am the
director of public policy for nami new
hampshire
um the national alliance for mental
illness
um
and
chairman pearson did ask me to provide a
small update on
the transition that nami is going
through right now
some of you may know and some of you may
he ended his tenure as executive
director as of last friday
deputy director susan stearns is now the
executive director
and ken is transitioning into retirement
he will be with us for the next few
weeks um to help with that transition
helping to get me up to speed as well as
uh
uh executive director susan stearns up
to speed so
that is the uh the update um and i am
here today um in support of house bill
representative snow did a great job in
describing what this bill would do and
it is a bill that was passed
um
two years ago
and then was
suspended last year and i just want to
say that this was a great exercise in
legal research with me trying to figure
out all the moving parts of what was
going on with this bill
as far as repealing a suspension but
that is what it's doing it's repealing
the suspension
that was passed last year
and
according to
the
analysis and fiscal note that the
department did
in october of 2021 there were
granite staters that were subject to
this
income spend down
and
about and not about 998 of those
individuals
so about one-fifth
would no longer be subject to it if
the increase were to go into effect and
that's i mean it seems like a small
number
but to those 998 people this is huge
um as representative snow mentioned many
of these folks live with severe and
persistent mental illness
and they require monthly services
through the community mental health
centers or other mental health providers
as well as
many of them do require prescriptions
and
if they
aren't able to obtain their
prescriptions
then they could require services that
are a lot more costly than those
prescriptions
in the past when i worked for new
futures my my testimony concentrated a
lot
on the providers who were providing
these services
they would
give the bills
to the patients the patients would bring
those bills to the department of human
health and human services
this they would then turn on medicaid
but the community mental health centers
would never receive payment for those
services that were provided
but in addition to that
there are a number of individuals with
severe and persistent mental illness
who don't go and
get their treatment in the beginning of
the month um
because of the fact that they feel like
they can't afford it because they don't
have
medicaid at that time
and they have to spend down
with
medical bills
to
591 dollars for an individual
and so
591 dollars is essentially what they
have
in their pocket to live on for that
month to pay rent utilities
food
any other necessities that they need and
this would raise that to as you heard
901 dollars
there was a 2021 new hampshire
residential rental cost survey report
the median rent for a two-bedroom
apartment in new hampshire is fourteen
if you can find it
yes there's point six the point six
percent of occupancy rate
um so you it is difficult to find them
but when you look at that it's fourteen
hundred and ninety eight dollars per
month
for rent
and this increase would allow people
to
have essentially 901
so
you know
when you look at that it's 901 is not a
lot of money
um
591 dollars
and even for the individuals who
would still be subject to the in and out
they wouldn't move to the managed care
the
there's
575 that would still
5075 that are still in the in and out
program but for those individuals
they would only have to spend down to
the 901
which means they have an additional 300
or so in their pockets
in order to pay for gas
in order to pay for those prescriptions
at the beginning of the month things of
that nature um
so
in addition to the monetary cost you've
got the administrative burdens you've
got you know not only administrative
burdens for the providers
who don't know exactly when
their patients are turned on and off
they have to actually
check daily to see whether somebody's
medicaid has been turned on during the
month or whether it's still off but
there's a huge administrative burden for
the patients
um
you know they have to hold on to every
single bill
so that they can bring those to the
department or send those to the
department
in order to show their spend down
um
and i know just for myself you know
collecting my own medical bills
is is uh it's a process you know and
having to keep them all in one place and
then and then get them to the department
in order to get your medicaid turned on
and they have to do this every single
month
um so again you know this this all this
bill does is repeals the suspension um
that was passed last year this is a bill
that had bipartisan support
back when it was originally
passed and was supported by the senate
and the governor
so just here today to
provide some of the
content of the bill and what it would
mean to these folks
and to urge you to
consider it
strongly and urge you to
vote ought to pass on it and i will
answer any questions that folks have
thank you counselor representative mckay
thank you mr chairman and
congratulations
on
your promotion i'm i'm reassured by
the fine people that have taken ken's
place
i don't know if you know that there was
a front page story
in the concord monitor two or three days
ago about ken norton
and his very open
discussion about his struggle with
suicide
almost all of his life
where he included the comment that
he wasn't so much
that he was going to commit suicide it
was when
i find that very touching
and in dealing with stigma
that this man with such
capacity
was so open uh
with that struggle over his life so
thank you for
giving me that chance to make those
comments yes sir
questions
seeing none thank you very much and
thank you i know we'll be seeing you
again
chair recognizes maggie pritchard
the card says two to three minutes i bet
you have a
handout
good morning and thank you and i'm going
to be very brief because god bless you
for sitting here this long on this kind
of detail i will tell you that house
bill 526 i am a
ceo of the mental health center up in
laconia and plymouth it's called lakes
region mental health and i'm the
treasurer of the community behavioral
health association
i am here in support of this bill
because it does lift the suspension for
which we would be able to move the
needle a little bit for poor people
make no mistake this isn't just about
people who have severe and persistent
mental illness this is about poor people
needing access to health care and the
way they can do that is to be able to
have enough money to have insurance to
pay for their health care if you have
five hundred dollars a month to spend
and you need asthma medicine or you need
anything else and you have to spend the
other dollars that you have in your
pocket on that do you pick that or do
you pick food for your belly do you pick
that or do you pick a better apartment
with lights and heat that work
so i just want to implore that you lift
the suspension and that you think about
the access this creates for poor people
to get health insurance when they need
it and not have to make terrible
decisions about whether to take medicine
or get the health care that they need or
end up in a costly emergency room
because they didn't get what they needed
thank you and if you have any questions
i'm happy to answer them but i just
wanted to be quick and say this is like
motherhood and apple pie you should do
it
we're making a video to instruct people
on how to be brief would you be in it
this is wonderful
and uh the chair now recognizes don
landry and henry lippman
we're we're thinking of laminating the
card and just keeping it up here is that
right
for the record henry lippman medicaid
director
thank you mr chairman members of the
committee i'm going to try to not repeat
any ground that's been covered here um
to try to get into that club of brief
testimony
thank you um
i think the underlying issue
with the income limits is they've not
been updated for about two decades
and so the 590 figure that talked about
i guess secondly with respect to our
fiscal note
i
was reading over the bill that's
published online the 5.4 million dollar
number that's
represented there
is what our sort of midpoint estimate of
the cost of this
i did note way down i think there was
some translation issue that we need to
correct with lba that
our range was 3.8 to
7.7 million and i think the 3.8 got cut
in half to be the 1.9 million um so i
think we need to connect with lba to see
whether it was something that we
communicated incorrectly but if you look
at the core of the note we did talk
about it being 3.8 to 7.7 5.4 represents
a midpoint
currently um individuals under the
public health emergency situation that
is declared federally
individuals
during this period of march of 20 which
will probably run to at least through
april
of mid-april and possibly another
quarter potentially
based on what i'm seeing happening at a
federal level
that individuals who
during this period have
who
meet the level of qualifying to be on
medicaid have continuous coverage at
this time so this bill
moves to begin this in 23 which i think
is appropriate given
the uncertainty about the
enrollment in medicaid right now
medicaid is
at the start of the public health
emergency was about 178 000 it's now
almost 236 000 as of last week
and so i think that you know it's
responsible to
if
there can be funding found for this
program to to implement it in 23 when
hopefully we'll be in a different place
with the with enrollment in medicaid
the
reference to
the number of individuals of almost a
thousand individuals who would move into
the status of
being able to get continuous coverage
you know at least on an annual basis
you know we've seen that number go up
and down a bit but i think the 5.4
million is a is an estimate that we're
we're comfortable
based on looking at pre-pandemic and
what's going on in the pandemic period
i think a lot of the other points have
been uncovered i think the policy is
something that the department supported
we had sought in the budget process to
get uh an appropriation to to implement
the program
um you know we we want to implement it
you know we can't implement it without
are you prepared to take questions
absolutely representative folsom
thank you chairman pearson and thank you
for taking my question i have a lot of
older people in my district
who own their homes
and
due to the fact that our homes are now
skyrocketing in
quote-unquote value
because of the lack of homes for sale
they're now their taxes are just going
through the roof
they're all on on
incomes that could easily fit into here
but they happen to own their home
is does that knock them out of this
program
i'm going to let don who's our
eligibility expert
no homes are generally an excluded
resource in the um
eligibility determination wonderful
thank you representative leon
thank you mr chairman and thank you for
being here to answer questions i want to
clarify that the 5.4 million dollars is
for half a year so that midpoint
estimate would be 10.8 i just want to
make sure i might stack straight
so the 5.4 is the general fund amount
for a full 12 month period 10.8 would be
general land and
federal participation
thank you
any further questions representative
mckay
i don't believe there's a single person
in this world that understands
everything about
medicaid but you get very close to that
the
situation about the fiscal note
very likely
could
have to do with the cost of living
increases that have occurred
in the interim
is that accurate
i think what i was saying representative
was that
the
i think the reason that this bill is
important to the as you heard previously
is because the income limits have not
been indexed over the years and that the
590 number was probably
established in the 1990s and the cost of
living
means that it's tougher for people to to
live on that 590 and what this
bill would do is increase those limits
so that people would have a
more reasonable but certainly not
um excessive amount of of income to live
on to afford you know rent and taxes and
so forth
the the fiscal note issue is i think
just an
interpretation of
wow
thank you
and thank you folks thank you
and with that
bring to a close the hearing on house
bill 1520
and now open the hearing on house bill
1662 related to privacy obligations of
the department of health and human
services
this was a
project
of
joint
legislative dhhs
oversight committee and most of the
co-sponsors of this bill
and the prime sponsor
are members of oversight we worked hard
and long and
the result is what you see before you so
representative edwards you took point on
uh thank you mr chair uh i'm uh
representative jess edwards uh
representing auburn chester and sandown
and
i appreciate the opportunity to
introduce really the only bill i'm the
prime sponsor of this year
i've narrowed my focus because i think
this bill is that important i consider
this to be landmark legislation and and
i'll i'll try to explain why
uh i
i think in order to understand my
perspective on this privacy bill i that
you ought to know that for the last 10
years of my civilian career i was a
privacy and security officer at um
eastman kodak and then when that spun
off to be care stream i became the
global privacy and i.t security officer
and then i had a nice offer from
phillips to move me into the area where
i was a global project officer for
privacy and i.t security so i i have
about 10 years of experience working for
medical device manufacturers
and seeing how the corporate structure
is managed to run
a good solid privacy program
and and what this bill does is it is
intended to
introduce
privacy structures into the department
of health and human services
so that they can
continue to evolve and routinize
their privacy standards policies
practices and the like
as the chairman mentioned
this work that led to this bill
got
started
as an hhs oversight project
in hb2
there was concern in both houses
that the closed-loop referral system
had gone
too rapidly and had been overlooking
some privacy issues and so
hb2
called a timeout on the expansion of
that system until we could the
legislature could conduct a privacy
audit of
the department's practices and as a
were in general and specifically as they
related to the closed loop referral
system
i would like to make sure that everyone
understands that was an incredibly
cooperative and collaborative
exercise i worked primarily with the
dhhs
i.t director mr david wieters
and i was very pleasantly surprised not
surprised i was it was it was it was
great
understanding how much
he as a it professional understood
the the need for privacy and for for
those of you that don't know the
distinction
what we worry about oftentimes is i.t
security we want to make sure nobody can
hack our
systems
and so in order for
data to be secure in your privacy rights
you must have i.t security but if you
don't also have the policies in place to
ensure that individual privacy rights
are protected they can be overlooked so
it is entirely possible to have i.t
security without privacy and so this is
this bill is attempting to make sure
that we have a very much a
privacy-centric focus in what we do when
we're managing data
as you know in 2018
a rare thing happened the new hampshire
state of new hampshire
approved an extension of our
constitution to give us a a right of
privacy
basically it says that we shall be free
of governmental
intrusion into our privacy um
and
uh and so what what what this bill is
doing is trying to
take the next step given that we have a
constitutional amendment to have our
privacy protected
what should the department of health and
human services be doing
in order to have the infrastructure for
them to
keep growing and maturing
in the in the privacy models
so um so i'd like to walk you through
the key components of this bill
um
now the scope of this uh is the
department of health and human services
could it have been the entire state of
new hampshire yes it could have but um i
believed that
based on my work with the hhs oversight
focusing on dhhs
i had developed some expertise in the
state of
of the
administrative methods being used there
and did not feel comfortable
extending those
assumptions extrapolating what i knew
over to doit
should be noted that
doit could do much of this on their own
without legislation so if they think
this is a good idea and i hope they do
then
i don't think they need to wait for the
legislature
i'm not going to read the declaration of
purpose
that starts out the legislation i do
want to focus on the last few sentences
starting at line seven where it says
excuse me
the department has a responsibility to
demonstrate to the public the state's
commitment to actively and overtly
respect private personal privacy
including privacy of personal
information and as a side note they need
to demonstrate that commitment in order
to show that we respect
the privacy right that got established
in the new hampshire constitution
so establishing and maturing a culture
of privacy
is core to successfully driving future
efforts to implement and enhance privacy
policies procedures and practice
continuous improvement requires
appropriate governance and policy
leadership
and so that's really what this bill is
intended to do is to
set in place internal to the department
not subject to external review
but
uh but definitely subject to the
leadership of the commissioner um a
governance structure that's consistent
with the way corporate america
treats uh this in their
grc standards
okay so
starting at line 15
talking about the
privacy and information technology
security governance board
again i want to point out that this is
an internal board this is not a board
that's subject to
legislative oversight you know we may
have some questions that this board may
have some answers but but this is this
is a structure that they need in order
to do the job right
um
going down
into the membership
i you know personally i'm flexible on on
exactly who gets uh listed here
um what what the goal was was to keep it
from getting too big
you know i i think the perfect committee
size for this is about seven
you know and and this is a little long
for that but but uh if the committee
here were to want to adjust this at all
uh i would just ask you to make sure you
remember that this is a strategic
internal
governance committee that should be led
by the commissioner or a direct delegate
when she's unavailable so so even if
she's unavailable i think she still
needs to be accountable for the delegate
if you want to know how this contrasts
with where they were when i did the
closed loop study
their govern they had sort of like a
governance committee but it was
consisting of two i.t security
professionals
and and getting back to the earlier
discussion you can have
security without having privacy so this
is meant to um
i want to emphasize maybe for the third
time that this is a dhhs controlled
process
um from on page two from lines
three down to 18 there's a description
of the duties i don't have to read any
of those i think they make sense if the
committee has any questions about any of
there is no reporting to the legislature
they are expected to post
their minutes
on a public-facing
site somewhere just so that people know
what's going on
[Music]
now
the next lines 20 and 21
i think are controversial and
the legislature
numerous times and i know this committee
has picked up numerous times the debate
on whether or not
i.t systems that collect our personal
data
should be opt in versus opt out
and
if
and for the you know the short story of
that is opt-in is perceived by privacy
professionals as being more respectful
of an individual's right to privacy you
have to explicitly say you can use my
data and you can use it for the purpose
that you've told me about
opt-out is basically the assumption that
any rational person would want their
data collected and used for a legitimate
purpose and so
many of the systems
in dhhs have been set up as an opt-out
and that's offensive to me as a as a
privacy professional but it's an ongoing
debate
and i i don't want this bill
slowed down over that argument because
there's a separate bill coming from the
other house i think that's going to deal
with opt-in opt-out so if if we were to
amendment amend this and mr chairman i'd
be happy to go work on an amendment
before you accept this i guess on friday
um but but uh i would i would propose
the elimination of lines 20 and 21 to
get rid of the opt-in opt-out debate
representative edwards we would not be
executing this on friday because this
group does not meet oversight meets on
friday
well good we can talk about her friday
okay
um
now
uh
that would neces if you deleted 20 and
21 that would necessarily uh make it
moot that lines 20 and 30 are in there
as well so they they could just be
dropped
then we get to line 31 where it's called
risk management and
[Music]
under risk management there's something
called a privacy impact assessment for
privacy risk management and so um
so the the so the department is
currently undertaking
a privacy impact assessment on
the closed loop system it's taken them
some time to get it done they've had
issues with the contractor and
contracting and the like but i i think i
think
where's
okay so so maybe maybe that became uh
mood along the way um because i i know
they quit funding the activity that
initiated all the concern but we just
funded for 84 000
their conduct of a privacy impact
assessment for the vaccine registry
there was a perception that many people
in the public are very nervous about how
the vaccine registry is going to be used
so they're working on a pia
now what a privacy impact assessment
does in general
the information that's needed by the
organization and then it does an
analysis a data collection uh
effort to
to understand how data gets collected
how the permission to get the data gets
done
uh how the data gets into the system in
a secure way how
uh it's encrypted in transmission and in
rest
um
how it gets processed and used and all
the way through the life cycle to where
it looks at how you how long you uh
retain the data and how you destroy it
when you're no longer needing it you
have to have a
plan to kill it at some date so privacy
impact assessment looks at all of that
and then assesses the risks to the
privacy
and then comes up with mitigation
strategies to reduce the risk
and then it should identify
the risks that can't be mitigated that
we just accept you can't we we live in
an inherently risky world so you can't
mitigate all risks but you should
understand
the ones that you have
retained
so that's a the privacy impact
assessment now
i'll jump
over something and i'll come back to it
line 12 on page 3
is intended to
authorize the hiring
of specialists
in order to do a good privacy impact
assessment
you uh i think an individual needs to
understand
the technology very well to be fluent in
i.t security issues and needs to be
affluent in privacy laws and certainly
fluent in all the
privacy policies and standards and so
uh in talking with um
with leaders in dhhs i think the
perception is that these people don't
necessarily exist today so they'd have
to go find some special skills and hire
them in
um the ols came up with labor grade 24.
i i have no clue i don't know what a 24
is
so if some smart person goes no that
should be a
24.3 i i
okay i don't i don't really care about
that
um
now i'll come back to
oh so if you don't like the privacy
impact assessments being done because
you don't think they're worthwhile and i
would disagree with you but if you don't
like that then we shouldn't be hiring
these two people because these two
people are really meant to handle the
workload that is new
that if we require these privacy impact
assessments so no pia no people
um
then the part of this i'd also recommend
that we just delete in an amendment is
on page 3
lines 10 through 11.
no state or federal funds shall be spent
on any system that does not have a
completed assessment and plan after
january 1 2024
i i think
the intent there is good is to say hey
we're serious about these pias do do
them
and if you don't do them you can't
implement the systems so that's that's
what 10 and 11 attempted to do but i i
think that's something that's open to
discussion with the the department just
to make sure that
you know that this isn't too brutal you
know that
none of this is intended to harm the
department or hamstring the department
this is just meant to give them
the tools people infrastructure
so that they can continue to develop and
continue to mature one of the things i
noticed in the closed-loop referral
audit
was that
they had a tremendous number of the
privacy considerations
throughout sprinkled throughout their
overall i.t project implementation but
there wasn't one coherent one cohesive
uh view of how
we're trying to protect privacy with
each it system so so this is intended
you know there's there's this concept of
an organizational privacy maturity model
uh we're not the worst
we're we're okay
but if we want to become respectable if
we want to do pay proper homage to
our constitutional right to privacy then
we would enable the department to mature
more so
so that's what this bill is intended to
do
i'm happy to take questions
questions for the representative
representative cushman
thank you mr chairman and thank you
representative
uh would you be willing uh what would
you think of having the meetings not
only have the minutes posted but also
have them open to the public and subject
to 91a
uh
i'm i'm
let me think i have not anticipated that
question and it's a fair question i um
it's an internal meeting i'm i'm not
intend i'm not intending it to be
legislative in nature and i'm just
wondering
if they had a particular privacy
incident that they needed to review and
they needed to start sharing you know
names of people who may have had
violations
both the employees and the and the
people who had their information exposed
i that that should not be public so
um so i like the minutes idea because
they can take the time to ensure that
they sanitize it to the point where
they don't inadvertently release privacy
information uh to the public so follow
up
um so what while in the 91a we can go
into uh you know non-public session
um maybe that would be appropriate for
those situations but for like regular
meetings where they're doing assessments
of the system i i i wouldn't be opposed
to that i i just i just don't want to um
make this so scary to dhhs to stimulate
opposition
i i i do want to get this in place
but i don't know that that would be
scary
thank you and thank you for taking my
question as as a follow-up to that which
i hadn't really thought about
i'm wondering
as you have delineated the difference
between security and privacy
if one of the concerns
uh with having the actual meeting be
public is not only the release potential
the discussion potentially of somebody's
personal and private information in the
context of a particular issue but also
is there not a danger that
part of
what they're looking at is the security
aspect and the security aspect
is not something you want
discussed i think that's a valid point
in um
and i'm kind of i'm kind of rusty and
and i and i i think he got a really good
point there um
um and so i would i would want the
people currently working in the field to
talk about the threat of saying too much
about how the data is secured yeah
thank you representative
i if i could though i don't think this
bill
gets it gets tripped up on that issue i
think this bill operates without
getting interfered with with the concern
you just raised
follow-up
and and
would you believe i was only
expressing my concern as to the actual
broadcast of meetings right not
the internal operations of of the bill
right all right
okay
very good i just didn't want anyone to
think that this bill suffered from a
weakness
related to revealing too much about
security strategy no i i don't have that
concern unless we are broadcasting
meetings which at which those concerns
might be
being discussed uh yes ma'am these tend
to be pretty high level this governance
board stuff tends to be policy related
they don't really get down into the
weeds but but they
could
representative canarch
thank you
actually uh before my question i'll just
comment yeah when i was in the cunning
is this when i was in the county
delegation meeting we went into
non-public when we talked about the
security for the county jail for the
same reason
my question was
this bill as you point out establishes
two labor gate grade 24 employees but
the fiscal note identifies the need for
about a million dollars more to
implement this
uh they talk about um
because of the privacy impact of being
about 470 000 the chief privacy offer
officer around 200k and
uh resources for identifying systems
235. so the question is
uh do we i don't see an appropriation or
how do we pay for that yeah i think
that's an excellent
question and hopefully the the people in
division three when they get this as a
second bill we'll take a look at the
fiscal piece i i i can only tell you
that my focus has been on um
coordinating support for
the
how to do things not how much they'll
cost
that's the point at which we could find
out what grade 24 means yeah exactly
representative folsom
thank you mr chair um thank you for
taking my question is there a required
um reporting to dhhs i mean from dhhs to
the
um
hhs advisory
board so so i i don't want to step on
the chairman's toes but hhs oversight
has tremendous latitude and what it uh
asks of the commissioner to come report
on i i have not viewed this as a routine
reporting issue and and the reason i
avoided saying that there's a routine
reporting issue here
i want the department
to own this
to feel like it's theirs and not the
legislator legislature imposing
something on them and
and it's it's my
organizational systems belief that if
they they have ownership of this
then they'll actually
do more and do better with it than if
you know they thought they were being
whipped into compliance
representative woods
uh thank you mr chair and thank you for
taking my question
um would this
implementation of this
oversight in terms of the data the data
is processed internally would that
impact the actual functioning which i
think is under my understanding is that
hhs is trying to develop a broad
database such that the functioning is if
i need a service a
and i put my data in
and then later on
i keep that same service grant but i
need another service
i don't have to
re-enter through another portal and they
can use my data from that first portal
and make it more efficient yes sir will
this impact that in any way okay so so
by deleting the whole opt-in opt-out
section i'm trying to avoid
that
so that we can get this bill put into
place get to start the first step
started
to answer your question in a way in
which i know the answer i i can tell you
about
corporate america when
we collect data
we are required to do an opt-in we have
to get an affirmative acceptance by the
person that they will relinquish control
of their data to us
and
as we do that you can imagine a sheet of
paper or could be a web
screen of some kind that tells them
things like
if you give us your data this is how we
will use it
we will not use this information for
anything other than what we say
now to you on how we'll use it and in
fact our commitment to you is if we
identify another purpose for this
information we will have to come back
and positively get
your permission again for the new use
so
so it's very
controlled in
corporate marketing and the marketing
people that would come to me got really
upset because they just wanted to let's
you know we can build better products we
can provide better services i i don't
know how i'm going to need this data in
the future just let me have it
no no it's it
it all starts with the principle that
the the data is like a car
you know representative cannon controls
her car
if i'm going to come borrow her car i
need to tell her
exactly how i'm going to use it and
where i'm going to go and when i'm going
to return it
and it's sort of that kind of a respect
and if all of a sudden i decide i want
to go to pittsburgh because my grandma
is sick i can't just take off to
pittsburgh so so that analogy is meant
to address your question can the data
once collected be repurposed
uh in a way that is outside of the
consent agreement
no
representative cofoult
thank you mr chairman and thank you
representative
for taking my question
um i didn't see a definition here of
personal information and i know under
hipaa there are there's a pretty clear
definition of pii personally
identifiable information
is it the intention that this would
apply to
[Music]
personally identifiable information as
hipaa does for example or that that it
would apply to any personal information
including that that has no
personal personally identifiable
data points attached to it
so
the first draft of this had about eight
different definitions in it and i went
to different sources to get those
definitions
and
everything was going swimmingly i was
pulling down expert definitions from
international standards boards and then
the u.s
international standards organization and
all of that
and then everything was great until i
started noticing that some of the
definitions for the same term were
different
and so what i decided to do was to punt
and and allow
this governance board who's charged with
having the authority to establish
policies
to establish the definitions that
they'll use if you talk to privacy
people about what personally
identifiable information is they
generally will say the same thing
whether or not they're quoting the exact
same definition
other questions
thank you mr chairman also thank you
representative edwards taking the
question um
what's to prevent
the department now
to create a governance board without
going through legislation if it's an
internal
to the department
what's to prevent preventive department
today
from creating such a board
uh i i think they could certainly do
that just the same as i mentioned doit
could um i think if they want to
have somebody support the governance
structure and able to also do pias they
want the money associated with the two
personnel
slots because this is new work in a new
subject matter for which you know the
people who do understand it already have
full-time jobs so so i think i think
it's
while they could certainly do it
their ability to execute on it without
the manpower may be an issue
thank you um so basically we're looking
for appropriations more than a policy
i i'm so sorry i i couldn't quite make
out your son so basically if
understanding
right now what we're looking for is the
money not so much that
you know the department can possibly do
this now but they do need the funds
which i totally understand but
are we co-mingling a policy creation of
an internal department with
appropriations
yeah i i
i think if they weren't so darn busy
they would just want to do this and the
purp the value of the legislation
is there's a little carrot and a little
stick you know there is definitely a
thou shalt aspect to it but there's the
carrot too saying hey you know we
understand it's new work with new
subject matter experts and we'll support
that so
hopefully it's a win-win
since i can't ask a question i'll make
it as a statement
[Music]
this means the people are involved in
the process not just those quote
nameless bureaucrats somewhere unquote
the people as represented by us
have a big stake in the privacy
so yeah the department could do it but
we're in on it too
that wasn't a question
yes
representative mckay next
thank you mr chairman
you you mentioned a labor grade but
didn't know the salary
i'm pretty sure that at the back of the
red book
it lists
all of the categories all of the
salaries
and it even lists them by
commissioner deputy commissioner
so i'm pretty sure that's the red book
if not it's the black book
and we all know what the red book is in
we may know what they are but i i have
never broken one open but uh but i i
suspect we'll break something open in
division three
representative weber
thank you mr chairman thank you for
taking my question
um
i guess what i'm looking for i think
that the um
amendments you suggested go a long way
to leaving some of the concerns i had
initially and i i appreciate
the
narrower focus of what remains
what i'd like is a little bit of
clarification on the one hand
we have the very important privacy
consideration that that we know about
on the other hand we are not dealing
with corporate america we are dealing
with
often dealing with a vulnerable
population not always but but sometimes
dealing with a vulnerable population in
need of services
and
the
concern for
a population which may not have as good
computer services
telephones cars everything else
how are we balancing the very valid
privacy interest
with the concern about making sure
that we are not putting roadblocks
in the way of services
for people who very much need the
services but may not be really good at
dealing with
the forms the permission slips and other
things and i i'm wondering if
uh it's contemplated that
there may be
differing
dimensions of permission about what
people might give
their permission for or whether somebody
is going to run up against the roadblock
of every single time they need another
service they're going to have to start a
process all over again which was the
so i think that's a valid question
talking about different points of view i
i happen to believe that even old senile
and feeble people should have their
privacy rights proactively protected but
the conversation that we would have
around that would probably be part of an
opt-in versus opt-out conversation
and so i'm trying to not bring that
conversation into this bill
by recommending that we delete the
opt-in opt-out section of this bill
so there'll be another bill don't forget
your question because we'll be in
another bill from the other house
dealing with opt-in and opt-out and i
think that's a good time to have that
question now in this bill the way this
would get dealt with your question would
be dealt with would be that internal
government's governance structure would
be taking a look at the information
requirements that they're trying to
satisfy and and making the determination
of whether it should be opt-in or
well it's more a matter of personal
privilege i just want to make sure
i i want to make very sure that it's
understood that i am not being
dismissive of the privacy rights of
anybody in this state no
but i do want
to ensure that as we are setting up
protections we are also not putting
roadblocks in their way and i i thank
you for the answer that is
uh that that's still yet to be
determined and and it's part of an
ongoing process i just want to be sure
it's not lost in the shuffle thank you
right and to stick up for corporations
they also deal with the same population
and they still
worry about
proactively protecting privacy so it's
you know at phillips when we were making
medical devices we
we were using those medical devices on
the vulnerable population that i think
thank you representative and the last
yep thank you i i appreciate i'm going
to be available for questions anytime
after the hearing um and i'll see you
friday mr chair thank you and i'm going
to be putting an amendment crew together
to deal with
uh the little this is in that's and
they'll be working with you and perhaps
some others
to uh polish up anything we need to
uh my my hope would be that that would
be a continuation of the collaborative
process that we started with dha hs
around the closed loop system
that would be my hope as well because
that was our not only our intent but i
think our
that's how we did it
that's all you led it thank you thank
you uh reppers uh thank you
representative calling chair calls um
paula minihan from the new hampshire
hospital
association she has
copies of a handout written testimony
and the card says she is in opposition
good morning mr chairman members of the
committee paula minihan
representing the hospital association we
have concerns about this bill but the
section that we were concerned about is
the section um regarding notice consent
and data subjects because of the fact as
representative edwards indicated it
changes all of the data sets to an
opt-in consent requirement
if that were to be removed if that's
what the
committee agreed to do um then we would
be um
okay we don't have any comments with the
rest of the bill so that is the specific
section that we were concerned about and
my test as my testimony indicates
um
changing this to an opt-in would be um
extraordinarily um burdensome and
problematic from our perspective it
would be a monumental undertaking
undertaking um so i sounds like we'll
have a different we'll have a separate
conversation about that in the future
but if that were to be removed then um
we don't have any concerns
outstanding concerns with this bill
and the chair recognizes uh
questions
yes go ahead
yes liam thank you very much for taking
my question what sort of data
would be extremely burdensome to get
permission oh
and an opt-in instead of another it's a
it's the function of changing um the
requirement of everything that goes to
the department would need to be an
opt-in versus an opt-out so that is just
that's
a big big big change follow-up follow-up
what kind of data
um
i don't i can't articulate all of those
right now because i would need to
um so any data that the department um
requests for instance all the medicaid
data for instance um if the hospitals
have to submit data to the hospitals
to the department relative to
medicaid they hospitals work with the
department on many many projects so i i
really again i can't articulate any
specifics right now um but if that were
to be removed um and again i think this
will be a separate debate in a future
hearing so i'll just
leave it at that thank you so much
the chair recognizes and i'm on a roll
on pronouncing french names danny goulet
or dennis
roulette dennis if the chair if the
chair would agree i was asked to
hear david
yes please david weeder's first
and that's a german name and i know i
got it right
thank you thank you mr chair and members
of the committee my name is david
weeders i'm the information services
director for dhhs
and
i just want to start with we definitely
at dhhs have a privacy by design privacy
culture
and
have a stress on the importance of
privacy for the individual's data that
we collect store
retain
share and leverage for the services that
we render in the state of new hampshire
we registered initially in the
opposition of this bill but as
representative edwards testified
earlier the removal of the section on
page 219 lines 19 through 30
would essentially alleviate most of our
issues with this bill so we do agree
with having a privacy governance board
within the department
the membership
we would be looking to
ensure that we would be able to have
either those members or their delegates
right now it doesn't state an option for
delegates so we would be looking to have
that
statement in there so that if they were
unavailable we could still convene the
meetings and move forward
the component that we addressed in the
fiscal note worksheets was
combining
the recommendation for two additional
staff along with our existing subject
matter experts and this actual time it
will take to perform the privacy impact
assessments that you find on
the section requiring privacy impact
assessments on all our systems
and there was also another section in
the fiscal note worksheet addressing how
much time and effort it would take to do
the actual review of the system's
impacts of opt in
so we would be
that fiscal note worksheet a component
of that would be removed
if you remove line glide items 19
through 30 for the opt-in
considerations
the the only other component that i want
to make sure that this committee is
aware of is when we looked at the labor
grade 24 for those two positions and
based off of our current ability to
recruit staff we believe that labor
grade 24 which is an estimated um
salary of 49 354 and 50 cents based off
of our current hiring strategy
yeah that's the current estimate
would be too low for us to be able to
recruit the individuals necessary to do
a concerted effort in in terms of the
importance of privacy and the impacts
and needs of the security associated
with that
our recommendation in the fiscal note
worksheet was to hire two business
systems analysts two positions which are
labor grade 32
and a starting salary on grade one of
step one of 69 000 907 and 50 cents
with the addition of a chief privacy
officer
which would be working
with and at the direction of doit's
commissioner on commissioner dennis
goulet
to help us not only take this privacy
governance board for dhhs but take it to
the next level for the whole state
and so that would be a combination where
we would be looking to try to
leverage this privacy governance board
to set the standards for which
the state can look at privacy and that
we would have the positions necessary to
start that process
i'm happy to take any questions any
questions
thank you mr chairman thank you miss
whitaker taking my question
so where would the chief pharmacy or
chief privacy officer reside in
department of health and human services
and the department i t
shared how it and number two
it's not really addressed in this bill
as far as any funding for it
so two questions i guess is one is where
should it reside structurally and then
how do we fund it
so i'll
make my recommendations but i'm sure
commissioner goulet will might have some
also suggestions behind me um but
i believe our conversation was that we
would recommend it structurally to be
residing under or directly to
the commissioner of doit
so there would be a statewide impact
privacy impact as opposed to a dhhs
focus
and if the funding for it we have not
identified but we would be looking to if
this bill would be looking to
address that funding that would be an
area or we could look for future
representative cushman thank you mr
chairman thank you for taking my
question
um i know that the representative didn't
want to make this bill too scary but
would you be opposed
a lot of people have concerns about a
fox guarding a hen house and i think
public participation would increase
confidence in this program would you be
opposed to having
the meetings being subject to 91a and
having some public involvement in this
so thank you for the question and
that's a very good question and our goal
is to be as transparent as possible
however in order to achieve good privacy
and security for systems we would need
to have open honest conversations that
could not necessarily be public because
it would put the individual's data
within the state of new hampshire in
jeopardy
being making that public showing
vulnerabilities that we're trying to
address
and so it would
it could potentially
impact the ability for that privacy
governance board to actually
pass meaningful policies and procedures
because it would not be able to review
that vote those security and privacy
concerns at the detail it would need to
if it was a publicly held hearing so
those are just some concerns that we
would have but as representative edwards
indicated if we stayed at a very high
level
and didn't
drive into the weeds and we had a
separate meeting to do that
that's something that could be
considered follow-up
um
you may not be very familiar with um the
91a public meeting portion of the law
but it does allow for
non-public sessions within a public
meeting so that those um
those issues could be discussed outside
of a public meeting and only what is
necessary to disclose
later after the issues are dealt with
they can be made public are you would
you believe that
thank you for the question i am aware of
the
opportunity to have a public and
non-public sessions we would be we would
have to structure the meeting such that
we could go to a non-public session in
order to not
unnecessarily
change the momentum of the conversation
so it may cause some erratic
behavior of what's public and what's
non-public
initially and but we would have to form
and say here's what our agenda is for
public and then here's a non-public
representative gay thank you
thank you mr chair and thank you for
taking my question
this is a piggyback to
the questions
that representative cushman just asked
you
i
since y'all are
sinchalla are dealing with policy
rather than specific individuals
i assume that if you
i this is a question but i'm saying it
like a southerner with the question mark
at the end
uh would
would you believe
whenever you'd have to go into the weeds
as you said
which i assume means talking about
particular people and conditions
that sounds like it would be a part of
the non-public discussion but as policy
setters it seems like
that's not a violation at all of
individuals
policy is going to apply to everybody
and so
it seems
wouldn't it wouldn't it make sense that
it can be publicly discussed
and certainly not ever mention a person
but
but the policy is what we're all
concerned about and really happy that
this is y'all are working on it
but
i'm having a hard time thinking that
most of this would be
too
thank you representative um
if i understand your question properly
um the the components of what would be
public and what would not be public is
definitely a challenge so the policy
would be public it would be something
that we would publish publicly on our
website
however some procedures of how we handle
the privacy and how we handle
the
actions and milestones report of gaps
and mitigation plans to
to provide the procedures
may not be public so that we don't
unnecessarily
give
a person that doesn't have the best
interests of the individuals or the
systems that we operate in mind
then the information to
leverage that vulnerability against the
state of new hampshire
once upon a time a long time ago i was
considered an ethical hacker and i would
use that information against people and
show their vulnerabilities by hacking
their system just with that social
information that you're sharing of how
you secure or provide privacy to systems
so it's a really balanced a good
balancing act to address
but i certainly understand that the
public hearing component of policy
should be public and in recording that
component
anyone else
thank you so much and
dennis goulet
and on the bottom of the card it says do
it and i've come to the conclusion that
means department of information
yes that's correct mr chair
my name is dennis goulet or duni goulet
thank you thank you
i'm the commissioner for the department
of information technology
uh so first of all i want to thank
representative edwards for his
leadership on this important issue um
when i started in state government in
2015 there was not a single chief
privacy officer in state government um
and today there are 24 states that have
one
so it's you know that
you know the importance of that has
grown a lot
um i i registered in opposition but as
as mr weeders had pointed out with the
with the proposed amendments um i would
withdraw that opposition
i did want to address i i'd spoken with
representative edwards about you know
kind of the statewide approach and and
we
we didn't necessarily agree on that but
i think we're we're trending in the
right direction here in our discussions
um
his focus was on hhs and i understand
that it's it's half of what i do every
day so
it's a pretty big part of whole of state
and the data that we collect in hhs is
is you know significant so so i
understand the attention there i wanted
to bring up the the statewide concepts
there's some great questions that have
come up and i think i may be able to
help with the answers one of the things
is is that i really would like to see a
structured
privacy
you know
function in the state of new hampshire
that has some accountability to it and
i'll i'll contrast
our cyber security structure because
it's it's more mature it's been around
for a while
and i agree with representative edwards
security and privacy are different so we
have in the state a um cyber security
advisory committee
which is a it's not a public meeting it
has representatives from all of the
agencies as well as the other branches
of government and what we do there is we
vet cyber policy we communicate we share
information we vet cyber policy and one
of the vetting processes is
hey we have this new thing we want to do
to protect ourselves
will this break anything
because we don't want to you know i
heard the question come up um
i think from weber was you know um you
know what will get broken by this so and
sometimes we think we have really good
ideas and then we bring them up to there
and then and then these and the folks
take it back to their agency leads and
they say oh wait we can't do that this
way because it'll break things but if we
do it this way
um it won't and that that helps achieve
that balance between you know perfect
cyber security would be i would just
turn my computer off and leave it off
and then i'd have great cyber security
but i wouldn't be able to do anything
privacy is similar uh in in that respect
so we you know i think the idea of a
statewide you know the doing in dhhs to
start with maybe a good good start and
you know i don't want to derail this
bill but my vision would be to have in
the have one that's um
that's statewide and is empowered so in
our enabling legislation the cyber
security advisory committee is empowered
and then there's a secondary committee
where we take these policies to which is
the
information technology council which is
also in statute in
rsa21r in the membership defined
and
we have the ability to cr to create
policy
that's both you know the development of
which is transparent so it is a public
meeting
we do go into non-public session when we
discuss cyber specific cyber security
issues
um but but generally i try to share as
much as i can
in those meetings um so i think that
structure is would potentially be a
really good model for how we approach
privacy in the state of new hampshire
and maybe we take baby steps and we
start out with dhhs
my vision for the chief privacy officer
is thus
it
i would like it to be an appointed
non-classified position
why appointed so so that the public has
the opportunity for input through the
through the governor's nomination and
executive council
process
because i think it's you know as as was
pointed out by multiple people this is
this position is is very
accountable to the directly to citizens
of new hampshire so i think that having
that transparency would be really good
and um
so i'd love to see that and then i'd
love to see us create a structure over
time where we
we have that
dual layer governance one one layer is
the
you know the overall like we cut we
could call it a privacy advisory
committee
and then coming up to an already
established body which is the
information technology council
um and and and that body already is is
has um
authority to create policy
and
so that that concludes my testimony and
happy to answer any questions there may
thank you mr chairman thank you very
much for taking my question i'm really
trying to clarify
um
i am very appreciative of trying to take
a global vision of all of this and i
appreciate it anytime anybody in state
government tries to take a global vision
rather than a siloed vision
but i guess my question to you is
are you saying that you
want us to take this bill and transfer
and
transform it into that global vision
or are you just
is it okay to support the bill as it
would be amended with representative
edwards suggestions
given that this is the health and human
services committee
and our
mandate is the policy of health and
human services
not the delivery of i.t services to the
entire state which
most of us have rather less
qualifications to address
thank you
while i was hearing testimony i was
thinking
that that those very thoughts and
i i think it would be perfectly
appropriate
particularly since you know hhs is like
half of what i do every day that we
that we go forward with this as you know
as amended work collaboratively with
representative edwards to amend it uh as
as suggested
uh talk about how we might um
define the chief privacy officer maybe a
little differently than we have but but
kind of keep it you know not try to boil
the ocean with it and then in next
session um i had been intending to
try to bring forward some you know more
broad
proposals uh in the next session um as
part of the budget process so i think
that would be an okay way to do it thank
you follow up
no i in his last sentence did it okay
anybody else
it's the budget cycle anybody else
very quick very quick question
thank you uh did are you saying that 50
of your work
is is uh covering the needs of dhhs
okay thank you miss your good luck
um i'd like to appoint an amendment crew
to work with representative edwards and
you would hook in no doubt uh mr wieders
and perhaps mr bouley and anybody else
you wish to and we call them
what
it's how it's spelled
all right representative cofould and
acton for two
um anybody on the other side of the
playground
well
didn't sure
thank you for volunteering and
all right thank you and he'll find this
out friday if not earlier
we'll work further on it
it just seems like he was involved in
so representatives cofould acton
merchant and
in absentia soloway
thank you so much and representative
edwards now here's the deal this has got
to be out of our door
by the 8th of february
it's an early bill i mean it's got to be
out by the 10th but the last day we meet
before that is the 8th to go over to the
absolutely wonderful people in finance
okay with that this um
hearing on
house bill 1662 is adjourned and we will
right
anyway
start
i've startled you haven't i
okay calling to order
house bill
looking at the
representative
who is seated there i am going to
we do have representative kirk
connert there sorry and also
representative vale
and either one or both rocks paper
would the people by the table please
relative
to qualifying conditions for the
therapeutic cannabis program the chair
recognizes the prime sponsor
representative dale
and representative
canuck the miranda warning you have the
right to remain silent this is time
thank you so much mr chairman good
afternoon mr chairman and honorable
members of the health human services and
elderly affairs committee for the record
my name is suzanne vale and i am a new
hampshire state representative from
nashua ward 3 hillsborough county
number 30.
i appreciate this opportunity to come
before you and present house bill 1619
an act that will add migraine headaches
to the qualifying conditions for the
therapeutic cannabis program
this bill was drafted at the request of
a constituent who has chronic migraine
headaches and although she wants to do a
trial with therapeutic cannabis she does
not want to trial with stigma
when i told her she could be certified
under chronic pain
she shied away from the diagnosis of
chronic pain because of the stigma
i found that argument to be valid in my
research she would apply
she said
if her condition were on the basis
if it were on the list of qualifying
conditions she was not comfortable being
under the diagnosis of chronic pain
because of the
situations that that can
make people think about you so stigma is
already a serious issue for those in new
hampshire seeking care for chronic pain
the misuse of opiates is widely
discouraged and patients are not always
believed in their descriptions of their
pain
alternative care though through our
outstanding program is still a frontier
where patients
encounter stigma including their own
they may have a condition that causes
them to be in chronic pain but they
don't have that diagnosis which is an
enumerated diagnosis in the idc 9
chronic pain syndrome
338.4
i searched the medical literature for
information about migraines
and the potential to be have these
symptoms alleviated
and i have provided you an article that
is an extensive literature review in
your email it is not in front of you
right now because i didn't make handouts
for everyone and i apologize for that
um
this is a really comprehensive article
and it can include citation that can
lead you into a deeper look if you were
to want to do that
and i have also sent you some
information about stigma there's a
handout that i sent to you as well
i told my constituent that i would go
ahead and file the bill because
we want to see if we can get her
diagnosis to be added so that she can
walk into the dispensary and say what
when i found when i um there was a long
list of medications that she told me
about that she has tried
and i know personally as a migraine
sufferer that the side effects of of
migraine medication are just profoundly
disabling
depending on how
difficult your migraines already are for
you
you're either seems to me like you're
easily treated with something that's a
generic or you're on a ride where you
have injections that cost 400 and up a
month
in order to try to control them and this
is on a trial basis which you may not
have
the affordability to do
so as state reps it is always awkward
for me to testify before you and ask you
for a medical decision about matters but
we're very fortunate to have the tcp
medical oversight board and um there are
people from the tcp
here in the room who can answer a lot of
our questions
the bill itself we've discussed several
times at the medical
at the mob meetings and we tried to find
an easier way to include people
who have a a chronic or an issue
that is so significant that they need
alternative care and what we want to do
is stop people from being deprived of
that care
and in my friend's case
the woman who came to me
there's
four years into it she's still her
headache every single day and she's a
professional
she's an upstanding community person who
is okay with being seen walking into the
dispensary but not as a chronic pain
patient but as a migraine sufferer
where there are specific items in the
dispensary that would be helpful to her
that they know about so i'll take any
questions that you may have
um and like i said there are experts
here in the room um i do want to just
quickly mention that
we all looked at this very carefully but
it looks like what we're doing here is
putting this
in as a symptom instead of as a
diagnosis
so we will talk about how we could fix
that
up the road
um
representative gay
thank you
what is the
diagnosis of a migraine
i never thought of that as a symptom i
thought that was a condition
thank you for the question
representative um
the diagnosis of a migraine headache
is
it's a full spectrum of diagnostic
criteria as far as i know that the
clinician has to check off in order to
make the diagnosis
as a symptom
a migraine is not just a symptom it's a
it's a it's a
it's a long-standing disorder for a lot
can be addressed by a lot of the
items that they have in the dispensary
follow-up
so you think the wording here must be
changed to be accurate i just think they
put it
i'm going to let people expand on that
more but i really should have caught
this because it talks about
all these symptoms here instead of
a diagnosis but we do have a list of
conditions
and
those conditions
are
many of them diagnoses such as the
chronic pain diagnosis the
the
irritable bowel syndrome crohn's disease
those kinds of diagnosis that have
icd-9 definitions
symptoms are part of the picture but
they're not the diagnosis itself
and i believe that we are going to have
some medical oversight board information
about that that you may be able to
expand on that more
thank you mr chairman i think i will
hold my question until we have the
expertise and
thank you enough
for the representative
any other questions for representative
vail
seeing none thank you so much the chair
recognizes
we all recognize representative jerry
kanark
and he's from the tcmob which i'm going
to say is therapeutic cannabis medical
first my apologies for trying to usurp
representative vale's
time in the chair
all my bills have been going very early
and i'm so used to introducing bills i
forgot this is not mine to introduce
so yes uh for the record jerry conor
carroll county district three
and i'm the chair in the legislative
liaison for the tcmob the therapeutic
cannabis medical oversight board now
first off
you may notice this is what i handed out
you may notice there's a lot of ink
there because indeed there were some
things we found after i'd already
prepared this and i will clarify those
for you
and because i'll be here for the
executive session i don't need to you
know send you another version of it
because i'll be able to explain it
so first there's a lot of people that
are new to this committee we haven't
done a condition bill for a while
the therapeutic cannabis medic oversight
board
is responsible for the oversight of the
clinical and the quality and the public
health-related matters of the
therapeutic cannabis program in new
hampshire
and tcmob is composed of the medical
director of dhhs
a can a rep patient representative an
atc clinic atc's are the
uh alternative treatment centers that's
the dispensary an atc clinical
representative and 10 medical providers
representing different specialties i
represent orthopedics and i serve as the
chair and as the legislative liaison
so our job is to advise the legislature
in dhhs at reviewing the medical and
scientific evidence pertaining to
proposing proposed qualifying conditions
but also
any other changes in the program which
have clinical implications
so because of this confusion
that representative gay was just asking
about
let me go into a little bit more detail
patients are certified to use
therapeutic cannabis by their provider
that's how the system works and you
don't just walk in and say i want to do
it you get certified to buy your
provider you're certified
that you have a qualifying condition
or symptom but
sorry and the way the law was written
and all the numbers are here on your
handout this part is correct
you have to have a qualifying diagnosis
that's under section one
and a qualify and
a qualifying symptom
or
some standalone conditions like ptsd and
chronic pain and autism spectrum
disorder
those are standalones where we if you
have that you don't have to have a qual
separate symptom
otherwise the way the law was written
and we're still living with is this and
is the conjunction and that makes it a
little more confusing
and the point is
yes uh to representative gay
migraine is a condition or a diagnosis
it is not a symptom and that is a what i
conceived to be probably a drafting
error that it was put into section one
it should have been in section 2 or be
in the section b that's the 126-10
number 1 9 b
which are the standalone conditions that
would have been more reasonable
now when tcmob is going to consider
adding a qualifying condition or symptom
or whatever
our normal process is to go through a
rather deep dive in the literature
and hold a public hearing
and then have a really robust discussion
of whether is whether or not there is
sufficient data
to approve a condition or a symptom as a
qualifying condition or symptom
cannabis actually has a very low risk
profile
and we have it approved for many
conditions
but it still should not be approved for
any new conditions if there's not
sufficient evidence
that it's uh that it is usable and the
reason for that is simply that it may
displace then the use of more
conventional treatments which may be
better for the person to use
it's the same argument that i was making
when i sat here talking about ivermectin
it's it's the reason to consider whether
you know you want to have real data
before you suggest use because somebody
may choose to use it rather than other
options
so in any case as we look at this
particular bill
tcmob did not go through a formal
process of literature review and a
hearing
on this proposal and the reason for that
is that we felt that this already fit
under the stand-alone condition of
moderate to severe chronic pain
the icd-11 international classification
of diseases-11 which was just released
in 2018 definition of chronic pain is
chronic pain is pain that persists or
recurs for longer than three months
that's the definition
and there are some categories
persistent
recurrent
and persistent with overlaid attacks
pain associated with migraine headaches
meets the ic idc icd oh my goodness i
did a typo i said nine
i'm so used to nine because that's when
i was in practice we're using that one
the icd-11 definition of chronic pain
because when pain
the pain is not always present that's
the persistent but it often recurs over
a period of more than three months
so we felt it did not require
independent statutory mention as a
so again you notice i use the word again
condition
if we are going forward with this this
needs to be moved to the
126-x colon 1 11b all those are the
various definitions one 126x1 of the
definition section because those are the
standalone conditions or it needs to go
in section uh
sorry
that 126 x
colon 1
9 a 1. those are the conditions but i'll
be here to guide us through that concept
if we're going to go ahead with it
that's just a drafting issue
um
now now it's time for the disclaimer
the disclaimer is that i have to point
out that this recommendation for tcmob
cannot be considered official
because we were not able to vote on it
due to our inability to meet an
in-person quorum at our meeting
most of the members of tcmob are medical
providers
on the day that we were trying to do
this and actually even the previous one
but on the most recent one some of them
could not get out of their office in
time to get to the meeting because of
clinical responsibilities we had people
who were covering for others because
they were out for with covet
and
uh and as would be expected with a group
of responsible dedicated medical
providers they also respect the need to
limit in personal in-person meetings
during a coveted search
because they don't want to they're
working frontline with patients they
could be infected they don't want to
bring it to a meeting they don't want to
go to a meeting become infected then
take it back to their patients
so the bottom line is we did have a
quorum if you include zoom but we know
that that's not currently allowable
and uh but if we
uh if we
so basically the refusal to use 21st
century
technology and zoom uh
precludes us from reaching a good
an actual official
vote on this and we have actually for
the last
uh few months have not been able to meet
quorum because of these
particular pressures
so
we did not avoid doing the hearing
because we thought we couldn't pull it
off
we just it's just the reality that i
have to report to you that this is a
discussion
we did not take a formal vote
uh we might be able to someday
so this is only our advice
and i'll take any questions if anybody
have any
representative soloway
thank you mr chairman and
thank you representative kirk and i'm
really glad to see you sitting in that
seat because you are
an adept legislator and i have a
legislative question
so
i am old enough to remember
uh beginning two terms ago when we
started to hear
a long list of bills
each of which attempted to approve the
use of cannabis for different medical
conditions
so
my question is is this the best way
for us to manage
including cannabis as
a therapeutic agent
for this wide variety of conditions or
is there a better way to do this that
would take much less legislative time
well actually if you read my report to
dhhs oversight from back last april
you'll hear exactly that kind of comment
that's what drove me nuts in that first
year too as we were legislatively making
this decision i kept saying this does
not make sense we don't have the
expertise because i kept saying that i
was invited in to be the co-sponsor for
the bill that developed the therapy
cannabis medical oversight board to
advise the legislature from a medical
point of view to be able to make these
decisions since we don't really have
that capacity
but we're still stuck with the fact that
it still is a legislative decision
unless we decide to completely
alter the statute and say that for
example the board would make with
decisions within dhhs and make all these
decisions he wouldn't come back to the
legislature but that's not how the law
any questions specific to the bill
before us no good point
that's a good point though
representative gay
thank you very much
uh is it possible that we could pass
this conditionally upon the official
well actually back up you we can pass
this we don't need because the tcup does
not you're not bound to follow what we
say we brought i brought back in a
recommendation and six to four
recommendation about sud in the past
uh against it and the legislature passed
it so we're not bound to do what tcmob
says that's our what i strive to do in
our meetings these days because these
six force kind of splits are not helpful
as we strive to finally reach consensus
with either unanimous or new unanimous
decision because then i can come back
with a strong recommendation that we
beat to death the wording enough that we
all agree on it and then you can trust
it and people are then it works quite
well so we can pass this regardless of
what tcmob says so don't worry about
that part
but i just wanted to give you the
nature of the talk we were concerned
about trying to go into the detail of
parsing out multiple issues of chronic
pain
i mean do we just keep going over and
over and over and we have to have a list
that's going to be 20 pages long
representative weber
thank you mr chairman and thank you for
taking my question and i think your last
sentence kind of got into what i was
going to ask you which is
uh
has
taken any thought to what we heard from
representative vale who represents that
her constituent
could actually qualify now for the
medical use of cannabis
but she is concerned
about the identifier that she would be
using
to obtain it and would prefer a
different one and is that
is that something we as a legislature
should be
inquiring into or
but but i what i really want to know is
is it something that the board has
considered
in terms of uh dealing with somebody
who's feeling the stigma of a particular
i didn't realize there was a stigma
attached so this is new new territory to
me so if you want to have
if she thinks she's got stigma with
chronic pain maybe she goes on
therapeutic cannabis
that is one of the major things we've
worked on in our last few months in the
tcmob is working on trying to
destigmatize therapeutic cannabis
because therapeutic cannabis patients
are markedly stigmatized which is highly
unfortunate um and there was a very
nasty editorial on the concord monitor
and i think it was november i think it
was which i had i responded and wrote
another editorial about it because the
guy was you know talking about
smoking weed smoking pot and so on and
so forth
but
many is not much of the much of the
products not smokeable and we use the
word cannabis it takes away some of that
stigma the other issue is it's important
is that no one else knows why you're
certified this is not public knowledge
it's not on your card
it's it's it's uh
we just had a long talk about privacy
that goes on your application it just
all it is is just simply you have to be
able to have
we have a check box you have to check
off that the provider checks that off
but otherwise this is not known you you
nobody knows it so the
the only person is going to know it is
going to be the department who processes
your paperwork who's highly unlikely to
know you um so i think that the stigma
she'll face much more stigma being on
representative folsom
thank you chairman and thank you for
taking my question
this is
a question about procedure about getting
the card
with a
for migraines
if a person is seeing a neurologist and
the neurologist said yeah you should
give this a whirl
only that neurologist works for someone
who will not
allow that prescription
does that person then have to go see
another doctor for six months to
establish a relationship before that
doctor can then actually write the
prescription okay several things oh well
i'm sorry i'm not yeah it's not a
um that's number one number two is yes
there are places where you cannot and
you would then see a different provider
um we are
like we are we are in effect already not
having the three-month wait correct
correct yeah we got rid of that no
longer does there have to be that
three-month uh issue because that was a
little burdensome for people who had a
provider who refused then they had to go
somewhere else that still is a problem
because we don't maintain a list we do
not publicize who certifies so the the
person has to find out by the grapevine
or whatever who they can see who will
certify them
thank you and actually by the way in
that particular person they might go
back to their pcp
who could certify them um but there are
other people around the state who do
thank you
any other questions for the
thank you mr chairman also thank you for
taking the question representative
so basically if i understand this
following the conversation
with an idc 11 which is basically
chronic pain
that doesn't really get into the subset
of the reason for the pain
which is coming from migraines and so
forth does it matter yeah i mean i icd11
is a giant book of 50 55 000 codes and
this is simply so that you can
communicate if you know you want to be
able to
code a diagnosis
or a an injury and be able to
in terms of research and all billing and
everything else be able to communicate
one another around the world it's an
international uh classification and so
there'll be when the icd-9 is going to
be a diagnostic code for pain there are
sub-categories for that for recurrent
and for persistent and and so on and so
forth
so i guess what i'm trying to get to is
that given that level of the pain with
an idc or it 11 code is there any reason
for us to get into the subsets
well yeah that's an interesting point
because the way we currently have the
standalone right thing written is just
uh chronic not order severe pain
we don't go into all the various things
there's a lot of intermittent pains
whether it be
sickle cell osteogenesis imperfecta back
pain even back pain
often it's intermittent but it might be
there for years
but the point is those are all chronic
pain issues they'd all be classified
that way and that's why tcmob felt that
one didn't need to go through it we did
respect the concern
of stigma
and i don't know how much we talked
about this
in our meeting
but we also again
felt that
this is confidential information that
nobody's going to know why you're
certified other than the people who push
the paper over their tc program so that
it's uh you know i think that's
and that's not to dismiss i'm not trying
to sound dismissive of this person's
worries
because i think that would be that would
be rude but it's simply it's
confidential no one's going to know
shelf h much more stigma by being on
representative leon
thank you mr chairman and thank you
representative for taking the question
my question is about the awareness of
this amongst the different subtypes of
chronic pain if the neurologist and
everybody else who are treating people
with migraine and these other
indications are fully aware of its use
or if there needs to be more done
that is a superb question
and indeed after writing that editorial
i've had a previous editorial i wrote in
our local paper and i got contacted by
two people who happen to know me about
difficulties they've had getting
certified not just for migraine but for
other chronic pain issues
because of people not knowing so now
wind the clock back about a year
or over a year
one of the major thrusts that we were
working on and we just were getting
started on it when uh coveted hit was
working on an education program putting
together a provider education program
which slide deck we called tc101
all kinds of other stuff and my
dream is to get out to all kinds of
places the after medical society and
pas and everybody else and give a lot of
talks we already gave one at the
behavioral health summit
virtually
but get out and do an education program
because there are a lot of mis
understandings amongst the providers
some of them even think oh well i can't
certify i've never been qualified to
certify
no qualifications they don't want to be
listed as a marijuana doc you know this
there's a lot of things that the
providers do not understand about how
the program works and that is one of our
major things we got a little held behind
until we got our educational pieces done
we're just about finalized on the slides
and we have not had the chance to get
out to the pub to the provider
people to do that but that is a major
issue
so i mean i've volunteered to these
other people that i will reach out to
their providers and explain this to them
and the department will do that as well
but there is a high level of ignorance
amongst the providers as far as how this
program works
thank you yes
representative gay
what is the mountain that has to be
moved
so that
the different components of medical
marijuana can be isolated put in pills
people can
get them
the chemicals that they want instead of
having to learn
some name of some particular
kind of marijuana right yeah what
how many million things do we have to
accomplish before that can happen the
major burden or barrier to that is these
titles the schedule one classification
of of cannabis
and the reason
when that's schedule one it means you
cannot get it easily to do research
so that has been a major problem there
are some components that are
approved epidiolex is a cbd at a very
high concentration that is used in
intractable seizure disorders in kids
um we also have some other ones marinol
side effects some other things that are
derived but the point is there's
a lot of our research comes from other
countries but we do have some that does
come here because there are some places
where cannabis has officially grown to
be used but we're getting a little far
afield here but the bottom line is
that's the mountain that has to be moved
for us to get better data
but there is already some pretty good
data institutional medicine published a
large thing in 2017 that did identify
and what the literature does show and it
keeps getting updated
so the the problem is actually the
regulatory issue at the federal level is
the primary issue thank you
any further questions for the
representative
on this bill
and i'll also point out mike holt is
here he did not plan to testify but if
there are questions or if i screwed
something up he can clarify it
i didn't see any negative reactions
behind you representative acton
okay uh thank you mr chair and um thank
you uh representative for for all you've
done for over what's been a decade
that we've been pushing this um
since mr holt push it pushing pushing
working on it sir working diligently
and i've only been working on it for
yes you have served
all right um since mr holtz is not
testimony i just wanted to ask maybe he
can give us some information
are there people currently
diagnosed um
or currently qualifying
as chronic pain with my migraine as
their condition is that currently taking
place
i think it's highly likely but since the
box that will be checked on the
application form just says chronic pain
you wouldn't know that i because
therapeutic cannabis came in right after
i stopped practice but i kept up with
i'm not quite getting feedback here kept
up with some of my patients and one of
them went off i tried to get him off
opioids couldn't do it he finally got on
tc was able to come off as opioids he
lives in the same town i'd see him every
now and then
but the the point is he's got back pain
back pain isn't listed as a condition
but it's a chronic pain
so the chronic pain
accounts for over half of our qualifying
patients
so that is a big deal and there's i'm
sure there are dozens if not hundreds of
people with migraine that probably are
in there but we would have no way to
know because we don't
drill down that's why this
information is confidential no one's
going to know it because we don't track
that
um and
if we do well i mean her concern was
being known as chronic pain but that we
still don't track that with this
de-identified data we don't have that
information and just also to clarify for
people
the primary age of people that are
qualified are in the 50s and 60s he's
not a bunch of they're not a bunch of
adolescent smokers they're very few kids
that are under age 18 they're certified
because it's a very high barrier for
them with two
certifying providers and uh guardian so
on and so forth the issue is that it's
people like us
most of them with pain that's the one
the major issues and a lot of other
issues as well
thank you any other questions for the
representative
seeing none thank you so much i have no
other pink cards can i appoint you as a
the answer is yes um but i think one of
i don't know how to word this this
weather because again you don't have to
do at all what we said in tcmob uh we
have to decide
whether we do want to get into this
parsing of different types
of
pain syndromes and listing them
look you qualify and we're not going to
expand it out and again tcm will be
didn't really want to get all the kind
of detail and make a recommendation on
that part because that's really more i
think something we have to decide
and
i would like some guidance from the
group i don't want to form it i don't
want to be a committee of one making a
decision
thank you mr chairman also thank you
represent taking a question
my concern is can you speak to this if
we start listing the subsets of chronic
pain
do we run the risk of not then being
inclusive with everything that possibly
could happen
because i know enough about idc 9 codes
or actually 11 codes now if you keep it
at the higher level you cover a lot more
things getting into the specifics
underneath this so the question to you
are we better off with the high level
versus trying to go through and lose
every single chronic pain
my personal opinion and i have to say
i'm not speaking for the board here
because we did not take a vote on that
particular question so this is me
um i agree with you i think keeping the
30 000 foot view according to
representative woods would probably be
smarter because it's much more inclusive
and my concern is that if we do have
that list you say including
so-and-so including blah blah blah blah
people are going to look at and say well
blah blah is not on there so i guess
probably not and therefore i'm not going
to certify you and that list if we
decided to put all on could be
thousands of things so it becomes very
cumbersome and that might become
a more of a barrier for certification
because the provider wouldn't wade
through all that stuff
so i i personally but again speaking
personally i think it makes more sense
to leave it as just chronic pain and and
advise the patient
uh in this particular case that it's
confidential information and no one's
gonna know that she's certified under
chronic pain she's just gonna have a
card that allows her to get in when you
go on the thing they may ask
you know you'll work with the atc they
will find out well what's your pain kind
of thing because that that helps them
decide which um mix they want to use
which product they want to use
but by this you know in terms of
delivery and in terms of mix of thc cbd
but the issue is that's again like it
with a medical provider that's
confidential they're not going to go out
and blab and say oh i saw someone
someone guess what she's got migraines
they don't do that
you know
so it's you know you walk in there if
you've ever if you've ever been in an
atc it's
it's really rather impressive they're
not they're not the local pot shops they
you walk in it looks like you're in a
high-tech uh
um
pharmacy with a different kind of
product
i'm wondering since the um since i'm
trying to address whether there should
be this amendment or not we're really
getting into an executive session yes we
are maybe we should have someone draft
an amendment and bring it to the
executive session and then we can have
this discussion
then and decide whether to
adopt the amendment while you were such
a valued member of this committee sir
thank you representative weber and and i
too was going to say we don't need to
parse that out if there's somebody here
who thinks this bill is made better by
an amendment by all means bring an
amendment to the executive session
and discuss it with whoever you want but
uh
trying not to have the chair use the
word appoint which gets us into an
official 91a
system is
better
so if
as a matter of procedure if somebody
wants an amendment by all means bring an
amendment but let's not
confuse our sessions here agree and i
will work
so you are independently with the
to work with the sponsors and if someone
else wants to give me feedback just let
me know anyone who was inadvertently
previously appointed it's voided and
you're just encouraged okay thank you
all right we're going to move on thank
you for that and that ends the hearing
on
19.
thank you we will open the hearing on
house bill 1578
and relative to including certain
children and pregnant people in medicaid
and the children's health insurance
program
i will call martha carlson to the to
testify first bless the prime sorry
there we go sorry representative shapiro
i'm new to this thank you very much
thank you madam chair
and um colleagues for giving me this
opportunity to introduce house bill
1578. for the record i am joe shapiro
representing cheshire 16
this is a simple bill albeit a difficult
one to understand if you were just to
read it
it will increase health care access to a
small group of marginalized new
hampshire residents
microphone okay
in 1996 the personal responsibility and
work opportunity reconciliation act was
signed into law by then president
bill clinton
the bill commonly referred to as the
welfare reform act imposed a five-year
waiting period for certain immigrants to
be eligible for a variety of federal
benefits
therefore many new hampshire immigrants
today must wait five years to qualify
for medicaid and children's health
insurance plan known as chip
in 2009 however the federal government
created an option for states
to eliminate that five-year wait for
children and pregnant
people who are lawfully residing in the
u.s but not yet permanent
citizens permanent residents or citizens
each of you should have a map in front
of you that indicates that new hampshire
is the only state in the northeast
and one of only 17 states nationwide
that has not yet taken this option
this bill if passed will require new
hampshire to amend its medicaid state
plan to provide coverage for otherwise
eligible children and pregnant people
that means that this will waive the
five-year wait
but
people who apply for medicaid will still
have to be eligible based on income
along with my testimony and the
aforementioned map you should also have
in front of you the july 2010
cms guidance to states regarding this
option
among other things it lists various
immigration statuses that are considered
lawfully residing and you'll see that on
while many categories are included the
largest number of affected people will
be those who have recently been granted
a green card
or are for far along in the application
process through family reunification
asylum applicants and those on temporary
protected status tps
it should be clear that this bill will
result in health care coverage for a
small number of lawfully residing new
hampshire reticent
residents
it does not apply to undocumented
immigrants
it does not even apply to daca
recipients or dreamers as they are
excluded from the federal medicaid match
professor leighton kuh director of the
center for health policy researcher
george washington university was kind
enough to do a
free of charge estimate of utilization
and cost if this bill were to go through
in new hampshire
his estimates indicate that in the first
year health care would be provided to
approximately 300 people at a cost of
just over 200 thousand dollars in state
funds
access to prenatal care and regular
health care for children is an important
investment in public health and will
save money through prevention and timely
diagnosis
lack of or delayed prenatal care is
associated with low birth weight and
multiple childhood medical conditions
when enacted this bill will will reduce
uncompensated care for health care
providers who are already stressed
this includes small rural hospitals that
struggle to maintain
labor and delivery services
amos keeg healthcare a fed federally
qualified health center in manchester
informs me that in the past year they
provided unreimbursed care
for approximately 250 children and ob
patients related to immigration status
at a cost of a hundred and fifty to two
hundred thousand dollars
while there will be a cost for easing
medicaid and ship eligibility the
federal government will pick up much of
it
eliminating the five-year wait for
immigrant children and pregnant people
will send a clear message that we
welcome and value newcomers to our state
who enrich our communities and add to
our workforce as employees and
entrepreneurs
i'm going to read a letter um
that was sent to me
by someone who would be affected by this
bill
and i'm sure i'm going to pronounce her
name
wrong but maybe somebody knows
how to pronounce her last name
hello my name is sandra neckencore
a nigerian immigrant married with three
children two boys and a girl
i am writing to support hb 1578 which
will allow pregnant immigrants and
minors to get health care
when i became pregnant in august 2017 i
was living in dallas texas i was able to
apply for a type of medical insurance
through the state which is like medicaid
that insurance covered both my unborn
child and me and included postnatal
visits as well
i was so relieved because i
didn't have to come up with six thousand
dollars or more for hospital bills
my husband was placed in immigration
detention and transferred to stratfor
county jail in new hampshire
that meant that my two boys and i needed
to come to new hampshire
before we can make a decision to come
the immigrant and refugee support group
of the new hampshire conference
united church of christ had to look for
an obstetrician that was willing to take
care of me and help me with the delivery
process
fortunately the group found dr perkins
garrison women's health offered to
donate their services for my prenatal
and postnatal care because the state of
new hampshire does not have any program
that covers pregnant immigrants
my boys who were three and nearly five
at that point couldn't get any medical
insurance through the state either
i'm very grateful for the help offered
to me and my family by the immigrant and
refugee support group and garrison
women's health
i recently learned that the reason they
needed to help me was that the state of
new hampshire hasn't opted into the same
federal program that was available in
texas
my family was recently granted asylum
during the wait i earned my
certification to be a licensed nursing
assistant
now i work as an
lna because i love helping people
i work in a nursing home and sing for my
patients to make them happy
i am also taking classes at great bay so
i can become a nurse probably in three
years time
i hope that the state of new hampshire
will opt into the federal program
more immigrant health workers like me
are needed in new hampshire and having
this insurance available would be one
less obstacle to their coming
it's only by god's grace in the form of
the immigrant and refugee support group
and garrison women's garrison women's
health center that we made it here
thank you very much i call on
representative folsom for a question
um thank you
do we call you chair because you're
taking the role oh
great
chair leon
um thank you and thank you for taking my
question
um
i've put this in the form of a question
would you like me to tell you
that all the members received the email
with that letter in it into their
legislative email addresses so they can
actually go into their emails and read
it and keep it for themselves
would you like me to tell you that
thank you madam chair women and also
representatives three of taking my
question i want to read a comment and
my comment is this prenatal care has
been shown to be cost effective by
decreasing medical costs associated with
low to non-existent prenatal care
once a child is born does that child
qualify for services as they are now a
u.s citizen of the 14th amendment of our
constitution
therefore is it better for the state to
be providing prenatal care to a child
versus having children become subject to
low prenatal care which ultimately could
cost the state a lot more money in the
you sound a little bit like you're under
water um so but
it's my scuba mask i'll take it off
so i understand that that wasn't a
question
the question is in your opinion is the
state in a better position
to provide prenatal care to these
individuals because once the child was
born
they become a u.s citizen by the 14th
amendment and therefore if we ignore
prenatal care in these individuals
and we have children born that have
higher
density of
problems medical wise that the state is
actually better off to provide the money
on the front end taking care of the care
versus the back end taking care of a
child who needs medical care long term
yes i agree and i think that everyone
would
i think that everyone would agree that
specifically health care for children
and
prenatal health care for pregnant people
is a
very good investment not only in public
health and in
individuals health but also financially
representative acton
thank you madam chair
and uh thank you representative for
taking my question
so it appears to me that the is it
correct that the
people still receiving care they're just
doing it through the
um you know through the
whatever they you know indigent care you
know they're not they're not in the
program they're not on medicaid but they
still go to the facility or are they
just not
receiving healthcare
so
um
before i started contacting people
about this bill to get to try to get
more information i had never had any
contact with amiskegh
health
which is a large
federally qualified health center in
manchester serve a lot of immigrants
you know speaking of interpreters they i
can't remember exactly what the ceo told
me but
like they serve people speaking 60
different languages
so
the answer to your question is
undetermined but i would assume
that some people
who do not have health care coverage
are receiving unreimbursed care from
various places
i know that cheshire medical center in
keene has somebody who specifically
works with people who
are underinsured or not insured helping
them get on insurance but also helping
them
with different sources of help for their
care or setting up payment plans but i
am absolutely sure that a lot of people
are just not getting care
or delaying care
i coverage for follow-up
all right uh thank you
so we're we're paying
is is it true that we're we're paying
for this anyway or we're denying care
which would be immoral
correct
yes i think that's correct i mean i
think
some people some providers
are providing unreimbursed care and for
some of them are able to do that i think
uh
a federally qualified health center is
maybe better able to do that
hospitals are doing it
and that's that's um difficult for them
because they're under stress in a
variety of other ways
um
and and certainly some people just not
getting care i mean you know some
people
get prenatal care the whole time they're
pregnant and some people don't come in
for that care until the last couple of
months because they couldn't afford it
okay thank you
representative cushman
thank you madam chair
thank you representative for taking my
question uh do we have any data on how
many people in new hampshire are not
i certainly do not um and i don't know
if um somebody is going to testify from
health and human services and they might
representative gay thank you
so if uh
i'm gonna just ask
what i think this does and
so that's my question does this program
if we pass this bill does that mean
simply that we are just uh
getting rid of that five-year
requirement to become to apply for
medicaid
yes that's what it means for only for
children
and only for pregnant
women
and only for people on a very specific
list which you have in front of you
different immigration categories
and when you say is is this simply what
we're doing
nothing is simple i've been trying to
understand these different immigration
categories for
[Music]
i first wrote this bill last year and i
i
have been speaking to this person in los
angeles who is the only person i've
i've been able to find who seems to
understand some of this and um having
spoken to her many times i don't fully
understand it
so
everything about immigration law is very
complicated
but
you should know that it's only specific
categories of people who this will apply
to for example
in keene we have a program called
project home
and they have taken in
families and individuals
who are in the process of applying for
asylum
so they are not citizens
um they are not undocumented they are
people who've made an application
um based on the fact that they have been
persecuted in their home country maybe
they've been tortured maybe they've been
threatened
and they are making a case with the
united states government that they can't
go back to their country and that they
should have asylum here it's a long
process
it can be two years
three years before you get your final
um
hearing to make for the for them to make
that determination
children who have applied for asylum
will be
the five-year wait will be
waived after 180 days of them
post-application
and for adults
um the five-year wait will be waived
after they get their work permit which
halfway
part of the process
so nothing is simple it's all very
complicated
[Music]
but basically yes we'll be waiving a
five-year wait so that people can become
insured
and get health care
recognize for a follow-up
thank you uh the map the second page
that you gave us
uh does make a difference between the
states that are dark and the states that
are lightly colored
uh right now we don't have any color so
we're trying to add that i assume
uh so i'll just specify that as of
january 2020
you would mention medical coverage for
children regardless of immigration
status
was california
maybe that's has that changed
uh
i don't i i don't believe i mentioned
that however
now that you bring it up
um
the bill that i'm passing is a very
small bill for a very small number of
people
it does not cover anybody
for whom there's not a federal match
it only applies to people who are
the term that they use is lawfully
residing however that being said
some some states around the
country
have
taken
past bills that would allow
coverage for
immigrants
regardless of their immigration status
so it is true that in some other states
like california new york oregon
washington
they use state funds to provide health
care coverage for people regardless of
their immigration status that is not
seeing no further questions thank you
next i call robert berry and don landry
from the department of health and human
services
good afternoon madam chair members of
the committee my name is robert berry
i'm chief
legal counsel to the division of
medicaid and i'll turn it over to don hi
good afternoon my name is don landry i'm
a medicaid policy administrator for the
division of medicaid services
so the department has no position on
this
bill we're here just to take any
questions that the committee may have
and to the extent we can we will answer
them today to the extent we can't we
will certainly research them uh one
question we're already going to be
researching is representative cushman's
question about
the numbers of
prenatal
and we're happy to take any questions
no thank you very much i'm sure people
will contact you if they think of
something thank you
thank you
good afternoon madam chair members of
the committee my name is maggie fogarty
i'm the new hampshire program director
for the american friends service
committee which is a quaker organization
working on human rights around the world
and because of the quaker belief that
there is that of god in every person our
commitment to the well-being and safety
and rights of migrating people
has
animated our work for more than a
hundred years uh including here in new
hampshire
and i just i'm so grateful to
representative shapiro for for introduce
for sponsoring this bill and it's an
occasion to draw your attention to an
extensive and a growing network
of immigrant hospitality networks around
the state
these are networks such as project home
which representative
shapiro mentioned in keene
there's there's a network in the upper
valley in manchester concord in the
lakes region uh the nashua host home
network
um as well as one that i'm particularly
active with called the seacoast
interfaith sanctuary coalition which
welcomes people from lee in rochester
and somersworth in dover
and these networks exist to provide all
manner of supports for immigrants
trying to make a home here in the united
states
more often than not we are supporting
people who are coming out of immigrant
detention such as sandra nakentre's
husband
as was referenced in that letter
so people for whom their immigration
attorneys
have found a pathway for them to
to
begin what could be a long and very
expensive process to to finding some
relief here
and many of the people supported in
these networks are asylum seekers at
various stages of the process
so these are volunteers from churches
from community groups they're
individuals who are just
finding in these chaotic times like a
concrete and loving way to be a
welcoming community and it's quite
inspiring
and what and it's the work is about
relationship building and it's about
learning about the complexity of this
immigration system that needs to be
brought into greater coherence
and also it's a lesson about
what's needed in terms of our safety net
for
all people in our in our country and in
our state but perhaps in a particular
way people who don't yet have a
um an immigration status of citizenship
or legal permanent res well or legal
permanent residency
so your constituents are active in these
networks it's why i noticed that the
sign-ins in support of this bill are
quite strong for something that's quite
technical and narrow because they have
realized what a benefit this would be
for those
who would be eligible and certainly the
pool of people we're serving in our
immigrant uh support networks is broader
than the community of people who will be
assisted by this bill but it because of
our experience we have seen
how important this is and what what a
positive step it is for our community so
that's all i wanted to to lift up today
thank you are there any questions from
the committee
representative folsom
thank you chairmanland
um can you please thank you for taking
my question can you please um designate
what the initials of your organization
are stand for yes the american
friends
service committee
and the friends is a reference to the
religious society of friends quakers
thank you
representative cushman
thank you madam chair thank you for
taking my question uh is there some
place that there's like a list of all of
these organizations that volunteer to
help immigrants
so i will be delighted to kind of brag
on that network and send it to you
sometimes the work is so kind of organic
and grassroots that not a lot of
attention has gone into
creating a website presence for the
network as a whole
i imagine some of the individual
programs do have websites so i'll link
seeing no further questions thank you
very much thank you
i have five more cards i appreciate the
brevity of everybody so far and hoping
we can keep that going since we have
another bill in 20 minutes next i will
call martha carlson to the chair
thank you
for having me thank you members of the
committee and thank you representatives
can you get the microphone closer
thank you for having me my name is
martha carlson i live in sandwich i'm a
citizen
of
new hampshire
and i'm the chair of one of those tiny
little groups that maggie fogerty just
told you about
our group is called po box 21 colon new
hampshire helps immigrants and i think
you have my letter
from your email
i just wanted to say
uh
of those 300 people
that adults that representative shapiro
estimates you may be helping i my group
has helped about 10
adults so a very tiny organization but
we send asylum seekers to school
while they are waiting for their work
papers
and well we've helped about
21 adults and 10 children
and
sandra and kenshore
whose eloquent letter representative
shapiro
read to you is one of the mothers we
have helped
and we are sending her to great bay with
great pride
and
many of the women
and men also are going to cna classes
and nursing classes and they're working
on the front lines right now
helping new hampshire residents during
the covet epidemic
these people are survivors they're
resilient and strong and courageous and
they want to learn
they take advantage of every minute
while they're waiting while they cannot
work to learn and boost their job skills
and
so to help them and their children be
healthy
will be a great advantage to
new hampshire
and these wonderful people will be great
new hampshire citizens someday so i urge
you to
approve health bill
1578 thank you
oh perhaps if you have a question i'll
be glad to
will you take questions representative
delemus
thank you madam chair thank you for
taking my question
um
now asylum seekers i i sort of have a
general idea of what an asylum seeker is
but as an asylum seeker someone who is
legally here
yes an asylum seeker
has as soon as they
um come to the states or within a year
they must ask for asylum and they have
to they're interviewed by ice and they
must prove a credible fear
that if they go home they will be
tortured or killed
or
abused in some way and they are given if
they pass that test they're given an
asylum number
that's their only id
but that is their legal right to be in
the united states
thank you very much thank you for asking
that question
thank you madam chair thank you very
much for your testimony
next we have i hope i say this right i
i
from madbury new hampshire i i can't
quite read it so i don't want to butcher
your name i apologize if you could read
good afternoon
um my name is sandra strauss
[Music]
see i apologize
i didn't know my handwriting was so bad
i'm here
to support
this bill that
extends
medicaid
i'm going to read from my statement i
did send this to everyone
i live in madbury new hampshire
i was born in new hampshire
and have taught english as a second
language in many area schools
durham rochester dover
the civil rights act of 1964 says that
children cannot be deprived of their
education due to national origin
so
we help immigrant as well as native born
americans
to learn english and understand their
lessons
it is well demonstrated by research that
children learn better
when they are healthy
i have hosted
many people but i've hosted a family
seeking asylum for about a year and a
half
and witnessed first-hand the difficulty
regarding health care
children need immunizations
and physical examinations in order to
attend school
these cost money
asylum seekers
have to wait six months before they can
get a work permit or earn any money
and then a long time before
other kinds of help can come
we as a group
probably close to 20 people
had to scrounge together
rides friends friends of friends
and search
to find affordable services
as we have noted lately in this epidemic
immunizations
keep help keep everyone safe not only
the individual
research also demonstrates that early
health care and intervention saves more
difficulties and ultimately money later
on
during my teaching career
i witnessed many children go without
health care they needed
they often miss school and sometimes
couldn't come to school because they did
not meet the medical requirements
so i support hb1578
to extend medical coverage eligibility
eligibility which has helped
to pay for by the federal government
to cover these vulnerable pregnant women
and children
i support it because we as civilized
people
need to care for our children
if compassion is not enough
then realize it is economically
practical
as health care provided in a timely
manner saves money later on
many of these children will become
citizens
do we want to raise underdeveloped and
undereducated people
let's not let new hampshire a state with
the reputation of caring communities and
thrift
lag behind in caring for our children
let us be leaders and examples of a
actually seeing none from the committee
thank you for your testimony
next i call eva castillo from the new
hampshire alliance for immigrants and
refugees
thank you mom chair good afternoon and
thank you representative shapiro and
every co-sponsor of this bill
i agree with everything that has been
said before so i'm not going to repeat
it because i know you're in a rush
and if or anything
you know if you don't do it for moral
reasons and for
for
empathy do it like representative
merchants said
for economical reasons
it is better to prevent than it is to
cure
uh immigration is a mess is complicated
these are all people that are here in
the country
legally the peop the five-year bar for
green card holders
after five years you of becoming a legal
permanent resident you can become a
citizen a lot of people live here for 30
40 years just as legal permanent
residents
so i mean it really makes no sense
whatsoever to not do this bill so please
do the right thing thank you for new
hampshire and for immigrants thanks a
lot
thank you and will you take questions if
there's any from the committee although
seeing none thank you so much
next i'll call bruno de brito from the
good afternoon uh madam chair good
afternoon members of the community uh my
name is bruno de bruto and i am
president of the new hampshire uh
brazilian council
and oh
oh
absolutely i'm sorry i tend to speak
slowly but uh you know four because i
know you guys are in a rush
okay i'll try i'll try to
speak slowly sorry it's not a rush we
just want to make sure that as we're
moving along but you guys are doing
excellent all right thank you fantastic
um
so i am the president of the new
hampshire brazilian council and also an
immigration attorney
um our organization help folks
um you know from finding
a you know like a dentist that they
speak their language in the community
you know to you know representing them
uh immigration court
um
so as you know some of the folks uh
mentioned here immigration is a mess
even for us that practice every day it
is chaotic immigration laws change every
day and that's why you see a big push
for uh immigration reform in the country
is because our laws have been so archaic
that uh it doesn't really
uh conform to what we're living today
um so
i'm just going to to speak a little bit
uh you know about some of uh you know
these immigration
like statuses so there are different
categories over here from mr shapiro
representative shapiro's list
so these individuals uh you know they're
usually
they have some sort of permission from
um
the government to stay here
uh lawfully so there is a difference you
know between uh lawful presence and
authorized presence um you know
sometimes you know they they may overlap
but in these cases someone that applies
for asylum fur for example
uh someone was being generous before me
they said three years so asylum can
actually take uh 20 years uh so the
average is between 10 to 15 years for
someone to to get asylum so the laws uh
you know like have changed uh in the
past two years as to
uh you know someone
that is able to get a work authorization
when they plot they apply for asylum
before i used to have
to wait 150 days and uh and apply you
know to apply for work authorization um
the total was actually 180 days because
you had to
wait another uh an additional 30 days so
we actually say 180 days um so but it
has been changed to 365 days now uh
until someone that in like a
files for an asylum application and you
know uh tries to get a work
authorization that enables them to you
know get a social security uh and like a
driver's license um so this bill clearly
would you know like enable these folks
uh you like not to wait 15 20 years you
know to to be able to
you know like apply for uh you know like
a benefit for for their children i work
with a lot of folks from from
massachusetts and in massachusetts you
have you know the mass health um and
some of these you know families that do
have
um you know they're mixed families you
know the parents are typically
um
we we say undocumented not illegal
and the children are
us citizens or sometimes they're
non-citizens
uh you know these children you know
they're still able to to get some some
coverage uh through you know through
mass health clearly that's not where you
know representative shapiro is trying to
do uh this this would you know limit the
um you know the amount of individuals
who would qualify
um so i'm going to stop here and thank
you for your time i'm open to any
questions but i know you're not rushed
are there any questions from the
representative cushman
thank you madam chair thank you uh for
taking my question can you just clarify
the the process
like where
where
at what point can someone apply for
asylum at what point can they get a work
permit
and
like how does that interface so for
asylum uh typically you know like it
works um
there are different like i like to say
there are different steps to it so
pretty much you have to claim to to the
government that uh you were unable to
return to your home country uh because
of the fear in lack of a you know
persecution um you know for race
nationality political opinion uh and
like and so forth
um
and uh as someone mentioned you know
there is a credible fear that the person
has to um you know has to to meet the
burden uh you know like in order to uh
especially when they are in detention in
order to move forward um
with you know the application so there
is a credible fear application
uh so the person then submits the
application
uh to
uh the the court
um
and after the application has been
uh submitted
um you know the person after uh there we
call it clock
so after you know the clock starts
running
so the law right now says that the
person has to wait
365 days to apply
uh for work authorization so that's you
know that only gives them the ability um
you know to you know to get a driver's
license and then social security it
doesn't give them you know the ability
to seek out any uh you know like
benefits that typically you know like
lawful permanent residents and u.s
citizens are entitled
so it can be you know 10 15 20 years
thank you very much you're welcome are
there other questions from the committee
i'll take off my scooper time
can you help me understand something as
far as an immigrant who's here in the us
during the five years with awaiting
the mother at this point in time
are they required to pay social security
tax or income tax so therefore to
putting into the system and not really
get anything back out of it
no absolutely as a matter of fact uh you
know there is a big misconception
that you know like undocumented uh
people don't pay taxes uh as a matter of
fact you know like they they do
uh in new hampshire alone uh you know
like uh there is a data i'll be happy to
share with you in uh 2019 which is the
last data that that we have
undocumented folks
paid almost 80 million dollars just in
taxes and these are money that you know
they cannot you know uh claim back
so that's what they paid in taxes alone
just undocumented people we estimate
that we have about 15 000 documented
folks here uh but again you know these
folks are not really considered
documented they're considered you know
lawfully and um you know i can pretty
much
uh all immigrants we have um you know
about a hundred thousand uh you know
immigrants in the state which um you
know these immigrants including myself
we paid almost a billion dollars in
taxes in 2019. so yeah so we do pay
taxes
representative delemus
thank you madam chair
i uh
i'm relatively
good friends with
some people who are from mexico
and they own restaurant and one of the
workers comes and stays for six months
and then goes back home
and i know he can work legally and he's
here i i imagine on a green card i'm not
quite sure how well i don't know i'm not
quite sure how that works and if
undocumented
how can they get a job because you have
to fill out ein aya 9s
yeah so uh so in in this case he
uh he likely i cannot say for certain
but he likely uh you know like has a
temporary visa which pretty much that's
the folks that you know like when you go
to canopy lake uh you know these uh in
like parks that's what they usually have
so it only authorizes them to to stay
here for a certain amount of time and
upon the determination of that time
period uh they ought to return to their
home country uh in regards to to working
uh in like um unauthorized uh what
happens uh constantly
is uh you know uh the majority of uh you
know like
immigrants in uh in the state and you
know like in other states as well uh you
know like they the men typically work
uh you know doing construction
landscaping you know like snow shoveling
uh women typically uh you know like
house cleaning
so pretty much these individuals they
create
uh you know their own company including
in new hampshire you don't need to be a
u.s citizen
to start your own company they open
their own business and they subcontract
it out
so
pretty much you know they get a big
contractor the contractor
hires them and they perform the job and
that's how they file the taxes
and yeah the other option is the
uh the itin itin number i think number
other questions
uh actually i have one since we have an
immigration attorney here with us so
thank you
we had heard the term immigrant
detention a few times earlier and i was
just hoping you could just help us
understand exactly what that is
um so immediate detention so
um
yeah so unfortunately um
in the past couple of years we
um
we had a lot of immigrants you know like
being detained uh you know simply for
being here uh unlawfully uh prior to
that um you know like anyone that would
come to this country um could
i stay here without you know the
government uh you know like bothering
them or you know coming in contact them
um i should say
if uh you know they haven't uh you know
committed any crime
if they
uh you know uh had showed up to all of
the you know their immigration court
uh there what we call it in like a
priority uh categories
um
but unfortunately uh that had changed
that you know like anybody at any time
uh anywhere could be uh placed uh could
be detained uh simply for being here um
undocumented so that created in like a
chaos in our communities because
uh you know like a lot of you know these
children
um
especially children um you know like
we're having you know the father who
would be you know like undocumented and
placed in removal proceedings and this
father you know typically um you know
like would be the the bread winner of uh
you know the family and the in some
cases you know the the wife would be a
u.s citizen uh you know the children
would be us citizen and only the father
would be undocumented and that you know
created a chaos uh
because you know like now you know the
the mother would have to find means you
know to you know um you know to to pay
you know for you know the day-to-day you
know uh costs
uh in lack of living
and you know and pretty much there was
you know like a mass uh
a mass detention uh you know
unfortunately without any priority
thank you and then the other question is
it seems like people are living for a
year or longer without being able to
have certain support do we have a very
strong charity network here in the state
that's helping these people
start off their life here
um not necessarily
unfortunately no uh so these individuals
uh you know they they come here
uh and the majority of them especially
undocumented uh they are in the grace of
you know the folks that have been here
before them you know to to help uh you
know like navigate uh you know like the
system and you know pretty much in like
99 of uh you know the the people that
come to me is because someone you know
directed them to me
um so you know usually you know that's
how it works you know um as
it was there was a question before
regarding you know the clinics how they
provide support so yeah so some of these
clinics you know unfortunately
mostly you know like southern new
hampshire uh you know they
you know they do have a system that you
know they work uh you know like with
undocumented folks
you know to provide uh you know health
uh you know care to these folks
thank you so much we greatly appreciate
the testimony thank you and i will now
all right good afternoon madam chair
honorable members of the committee my
the mike just went out thank you sorry
about that
my name is jake barry i'm the vice
president of policy and new futures as
many of you know new futures is
nonpartisan non-profit health policy and
advocacy organization as new as new
hampshire's authorized kids count
organization we advocate for data-driven
policies that support all granite state
families i do want to note that i'm here
today not just on behalf of new futures
but on behalf of
thousands of granite state residents who
don't feel they can safely access
the legislature and testify at hearings
at this point in the in the pandemic
i don't want to repeat too much of
what's been said but i do want to
emphasize our strong support for this
bill
data shows that on average immigrant
families are often disproportionately
lower income and have higher rates of
uninsurance or under insurance
here in new hampshire only 55 percent of
legally residing residents who are
eligible federally for medicaid are
enrolled in the program according to the
migration policy center
the rest are left to depend on
employer-based coverage public exchanges
or other high-cost options or in many
cases left without insurance coverage
entirely
of course we know that health coverage
is a key contributor to access to access
to health care and overall health and
wellness
further health insurance is critical to
overall financial health and stability
without it children especially are more
likely to experience poverty or other
adverse childhood experiences which can
impair brain development and lead to
negative effects throughout their
lifetime
by allowing legally residing immigration
immigrant children and families to more
immediately access medicaid and chip
this bill would help to provide better
health and stability to this important
part of our population it would decrease
long-term costs facing the health care
system and it would help to improve the
health and wellness of our state overall
with that we ask you to vote this bill
ought to pass and i'm happy to take
questions
there any questions from the committee
seeing none thank you very much and i
closed the hearing on house bill 1578
and i open the hearing on house bill
1480 relative to eligibility for
individuals for developmentally
disability services
and i will call to the stand the prime
sponsor representative richard abell
thank you thank you very much i have
written testimony
and if we
can wait just a second i will
pass that around both from me and from a
constituent
yes
there are two
two sets of testimony one person could
not be here so i'm passing that out
um
thank you madam chair and thank you
honorable members of the committee
my name is richard abell i
represent grafton 13
which is the city of lebanon
and thank you for giving me the
opportunity
in fact i'm going to just go like this
thank you for giving me the opportunity
to introduce house bill 1480
entitled relative to the eligibility of
individuals for developmental disability
services
the bill itself actually deals with one
particular
medical condition
and i will
tell you something about that in just a
second
i'm sponsoring this bill at the request
of three constituents each a member
of a family in my district of lebanon
whom i have known for more than two
decades
the condition the medical condition
excuse me
that
we're concerned with today
is called familial
dysautonomia
it's also known by two other names
hereditary sensory and automatic
autonomic neuropathy type 3
and riley day syndrome
the three
children of this family
who
have had this condition since birth
one of the three
passed away in 2018 there are two adult
surviving
members of the family
fd or familial dysautonomia
is a genetic disorder
that presents at birth
fd disturbs cells in the autonomic
dysautonomia
the autonomic nervous system as i i'm
sure most of you all of you know
uh controls involuntary actions such as
digestion
breathing production of tears
regulation of blood pressure
blood pressure
body temperature
it also affects the sensory nervous
system
including activities such as taste
perception of pain heat and cold
fd is a degenerative disease
as one gets older disabilities increase
the symptoms in school-age children
include
bed wetting vomiting reduced sensitivity
to temperature changes
pain
very poor balance
of abnormal curvature of the spine
poor bone quali quality
and increased fractures
and also kidney and heart problems
i
i'm glad you're letting me go through
the the symptoms the the conditions
because this is a rare disease
and i didn't know all this until i
started doing research
um
as i said as one gets older uh
disabilities increase
um
and uh this affects individuals
uh
through their very poor blood pressure
regulation
they may
experience a sharp drop in
blood pressure when they stand up
causing dizziness blood blurred vision
or fainting they can also have episodes
of high blood pressure
uh
with all the all the things that go
along with that
about one third of children with
fd have learning disabilities according
to this
medline plus
source
and require special education
by adulthood
affected individuals have increased
difficulties with their balance
and really
an unaided walking they
uh the the individuals in the family i
have been talking about
are wheelchair-bound they're legally
blind um
other complications
include lung damage because of the
frequency of of lung infections
impaired kidney function
and uh
and worsening
vision because of atrophy of the of the
optic nerves
the reason uh that this bill is is being
submitted
um is
uh
because
we
feel there may be
uncertainty
among people who
might be providing developmental
disability services as to whether
this qualifies because of the language
in
in the current
rsa 171 a
definitions of
qualifying
qualifying conditions
and
our goal
is to
do two things really
to
[Music]
underscore
what we'd understand to be the
that
this condition
meets the requirements
and
let's see um
well
and als and also to clarify for the
public
that that this condition if you decide
that if the legislature decides that it
does in fact as i believe it does
meet uh meet the
the requirements in the current
legislation that it's clearer to them
that whether they can uh they can uh
apply for services
and i i will say just for just for a
quick interlude uh the family that i
that i'm representing here
has dealt with this for over 40 years in
their family
and they're
unclear
uh as to whether they will
they would uh be eligible because
they've gotten different
uh
uh and opposite uh uh
answers to their questions when they've
when they've asked that and i have also
talked to a number
of of people uh who operate in the field
and they don't all give the same answer
they're not clear this is a rare
condition
and
therefore
it may be the first time that it has
come up before
the department of health and human
services
i'm not sure of that but i i would not
be i would not be surprised
if we look actually if we look on the
bill itself
you'll see
the existing language and you'll see and
this is in the definitions
section of the bill
which
which defines developmental disability
yeah again if you don't mind i'll just
read it um
our developmental disability means a
disability a which is attribute
attributable to an intellectual
disability which is the first thing
given and in this case
is not applicable
because the individuals i'm talking
about
don't ha they they're both sons or
college graduates they were able to work
growing up and so forth but they're now
they're now
unable to do so because of the
the the growth of the disease um all
right is attributable to intellectual
disability cerebral palsy epilepsy
autism
um and then i've asked that we put
familial dysautonomia
into that or
a specific learning disability or any
other condition of an individual
found to be closely related to an
intellectual disability as it refers to
general intellectual functioning or
impairment
in adaptive behavior or requires
treatment
similar to that
required for persons with an
intellectual disability as a former
english teacher i that's that's a tough
that is a tough uh
sentence to parse
but i think the
and i'm not suggesting
re
uh revising all of this
but if we look at it carefully i'm quite
convinced
that
other conditions like cerebral palsy or
epilepsy
that are not intellectual disabilities
if one reads it right from the beginning
attributable to an intellectual
disability one could stop and say oh
well in my in the case of my condition
that's not there i i hope i'm explaining
why why we think there's some there's
some uh
it's possible to be ambiguous it's
possible to to have different uh
different interpretations of this oh it
also
means that fd also meets the conditions
in on line 9 b
which originate before an individual
attains age 22. these are all present as
i said
at birth a person is is born with is
born with this
um
i've given you two sets of written
testimony
my own
and that of
uh miss bobby gross who is the mother of
these three children and i and and
at your leisure please read this because
it will give you more
of an idea of why we're
why we're concerned and would like to
add this
the sponsors of this bill wish to
clarify
that it's the legislature's intent that
the conditions found in this particular
i'm not sure to call it
syndrome disease
but in this in this
case um
meet the meet the criteria that are
already in the statute um
and some people have suggested that this
could be accomplished through the
department uh legislative rules
our cons our concern with that is
that we think members of the public
don't know where to find the rules
and that the place that one would look
would be the rsa
and and uh so
that
um if if this condition is deserving of
of
developmental disability services the
the way to make the public understand
that
would be
best served by
uh by having it in in the uh
in the rsa i mean yes in the rsa and i'm
happy to answer any questions and if i
don't know the answer i'll get them for
you
okay thank you very much for the
presentation i'll call uh
thank you madam chair and thank you for
taking my question i had
i'm sorry i was inattentive for a moment
for which i apologize but i
wondered as you were speaking i
certainly understand the problems of
construction of the sentence here and
particularly as it applies to this
particular condition
what i wanted to know uh reasonable
people could certainly come up with
different conclusions but what i wanted
to know is have has this family applied
for services and have they been denied
or
have they applied at all they have my
understanding is that they have applied
they're in the
application process and they have not
not gotten an answer as of now thank you
i'll confirm that for you thank you
representative folsom
thank you madam chair um thank you for
taking my question out actually it's two
parts one is
this is a very rare
disease i'm assuming um do we know how
many are in the state
uh
miss gross says there are two in her
in her uh testim written testimony i
don't know that for sure but it uh
i guess there probably are some people
who probably
may have this and don't know that they i
mean they know they have a problem and
don't know that it's this but
uh i believe the number uh in in uh is
a few hundred in the united states and
maybe
several hundred more in the in the rest
of the world so it's it's rare
thank you my follow-up to that is and it
might be answered better by one of the
doctors in the room
uh
when we were just discussing the
pain issue
with diagnose for marijuana we talked
about did we want to get into the
details
is this
do you
and
yeah
i'm looking at the doctor sorry
i'm not sure how to answer that i'll
repres recognize representative kenner
but i was not going to state it as an
answer to that i wanted to just point
out that now point out him to ask
we just went through a long discussion
about the hazards of making lists of
diagnoses because then if it's not
listed then it seems to be excluded and
this is the same problem we're running
into here
in the sense that
that i'm asking would not this fit
under the
umbrella of
forgetting about intellectual disability
but closely related to intellectual
disability
or should we just simply change that to
something closely related to a
developmental disability so you get rid
of that word intellectual and improve
the size of the umbrella because i'm
sure there are a lot of other
developmental disability issues
besides what we have listed here even
adding fd that would appear to then
still be excluded
um
and so
i'm caught on how to do it do you think
that if we just got rid of the word
intellectual in
six
or in four change that to developmental
so we took out the concept of
intellectual
that that would be sufficient
to
open up the umbrella a little bit bigger
but not have the exclusionary aspect of
a list
um
that that that might be
a
a solution i i don't know the only state
that i know that has passed
legislation
uh that include speaks to this
fd
condition
is the state of new york and they went
through and wrote a whole
new section
uh that covers that takes many of the
things that are in
um
what's the number here uh 171
rsa 171 and put it into a new statute i
don't think that's necessary in new
hampshire i think everything's pretty
clear
so follow-up
the second question that comes into that
same issue is there's often a very broad
spectrum of development disabilities for
example even the whole thing of cerebral
palsy can be quite severe or can be just
a mild limp that's still cerebral palsy
is there a mechanism further in statute
or is it in rules in which the severity
of the developmental disability is
assessed to be sure that the person
actually needs
services since some of these
may never require services because
i don't again i don't know the answer if
someone is from uh department of health
and human services we may be able to get
it from them uh these particular
individuals whom i know
uh and have known for a long time
uh they have very severe physical
uh
problems and i would think if they would
meet the criteria but
that's a very good question
the chair inquires as to whether there
is anyone from any of the 10 area
agencies
here present in the room
or i realize jonathan ruthier has moved
on but his replacement in the group that
looks over the 10 area agencies is there
anyone here from that group
i've had some conversations
with them
and um would you believe representative
that
what we've just heard is virtually word
for word what they've said to me
in that they do not in any way dismiss
this specific
issue but they would much rather make
broader categories otherwise we left one
out and we've got to come back next year
and so on um
with
would you be um well it's our bill i
realize but you are the prime sponsor
and would you think it an apt thing to
do that perhaps we reworked the bill to
make broader categories
rather than single out this particular
one and then another year another one uh
i agree with you completely i wrote the
bill this way to make it to do it as
simply as i could
knowing that that was a
weakness in the bill i i think that's
what my committee commerce would do with
the comparable
uh comparable situation
thank you so much
thank you
uh
whatever's the matter with the bill you
didn't write the write it somebody else
wrote it
that needs to be rewritten and one of
the problems is
as
i'm i'm so glad that if everybody wants
to rework this because it is so
important
but we can't exactly substitute in this
developmental for intellectual because
this whole paragraph is supposed to be
defining
developmental
disability
so we're going to have to
think really long and hard
how to make the umbrella big and not
yes i mean it it's it's very possible
that there could be
a new
a and b or an a b and c and where there
was a place in which
it was clear that there were several
kinds of conditions that that would be
would fit and it wouldn't be necessary
to
have lists and so forth
anything yet representative weber
thank you mr chairman and thank you for
taking my question
would it possibly be a fix
grammatically and
in terms of the sense if we simply
add
in intellectual or physical disability
uh intellectual or physical disability
uh i think
sure but would the problem there not be
that we don't have any idea
how many people with how many different
conditions
we may then be adding
unless there's somebody here from dhhs
who might be able to help clarify that
for us
is that true
oh i'm sorry
isn't it true that if we add in the word
physical disability we've solved the
problem of the umbrella
but we have created another problem
which is we don't have any idea
how many people we are bringing in under
that umbrella
and uh
unless
because you can't answer that question
for us so maybe there's somebody else
here who might be able to answer it
um well i would say that that i believe
that the intent of the of the current
legislation is
that all the people in with many
different kinds of conditions could
apply and this would seem to indicate
they're already
already are eligible but there's
it but it seems to be ambiguous
so i think your your suggestion is good
um
i i believe also in in terms of of of
the uh
expansion of
the number of people
requiring or requesting
uh
services
is really going to be answered by
how much money is appropriated and
whether people how many people could be
eligible i don't think this is a
zero-sum
but i think that that would
that would seem to indicate what what i
think would happen in the future
and i think would happen under under the
current language as well
representative might you guessed that
i've had exactly this conversation
already with the developmentally
disabled community because while they do
wish to bring in appropriate very small
groups such as this group and the
language they used with me is we believe
there's two in the state
they don't want it to be a free-for-all
because that would sink the boat
would you believe
i i i would i would i would believe it
thank you i would believe it and that's
why i only put one into the bill
but this gets a go this gets us going
representative shapiro
thank you mr chair
and and thank you for taking this
question which
it's not quite a question but i'll try
to make it into a question
um
since i since i believe that there are a
lot of
genetic anomalies
that
are categorized as developmental
disabilities but might fit more clearly
under the umbrella as it's written
i'm wondering if this wouldn't be a
place to do some research about how
other states rsas are written
with the definition of developmentally
disabled
that still wasn't a question would you
uh to the degree that i understand that
yes i
i think that's a good idea but i i would
like to say that my hope
is
making progress on this because we were
studying it for another year
representative woods while i asked the
fourth floor to do research
uh thank you mr chair and thank you for
taking my question i just need to
understand a little bit of the actual
physical process by which these services
would be provided
my understanding is that almost anybody
regardless of diagnosis can apply for if
they feel that the need is there
for supportive services
then they have to go through and there
are physicians who are either dedicated
in the department or
ancillary services outside the
department to provide those diagnoses
and say yes they need the following
services
and we physicians especially
orthopedists do this on a regular basis
like for workers comp
you know you have an injury are you
impaired can you not do this job blah
blah blah
and provide
restrictions and
on their work area
is that the same process such that
making a list doesn't help they still
have to get
the physical exam by somebody who then
through the state says yes
they have a criteria to provide services
so then the backup question is do we
i i think that this committee really
would be able to decide that
um i
i'm in favor of whatever is the best
best solution for that
representative woods
thank you i guess simplifying the
question
even though i have a diagnosis of
familiar autonomia
it's autonomy excuse me um and i applied
for services i would still go through
the physical exam and get uh that then
would be certified that in fact they do
need services so the title itself
doesn't guarantee you service no it
doesn't guarantee it doesn't guarantee
services
and i i believe there are other criteria
about perhaps about family income and so
forth that have something to do with
this but i i don't know how that process
last one representative gay
thank you
uh this brings up the subject of how
many other people who are seriously
handicapped because this sounds like a
physical handicraft rather than an
intellectual now i'm curious as to what
services they are asking for under this
this title
maybe this is the only service they know
about you know the only title of
services they're familiar with because
we
surely we have some kind of services
that are for people who are physically
handicapped because that's what it
sounds like it's developing here
and that seems like that ought to be in
consideration
uh
because obviously they need they deserve
services but
where what category do they go under and
are there already people in that
category that they ought to be put into
it's the developmental
disability category is serviced by 10
area agencies overseen by the state this
is just naming out one specific their
concern is again as we've said
you may be missing a few once you start
specifically doing it what but this is
to something that already exists serving
can i clarify my question
don't we already have i
i absolutely want to help these people
don't we already have services that
take care of people with physical
advancing
illnesses
they're physical rather than
intellectual
if i can piggyback that then the
question to the representative is
i'm sorry i came in in the middle of the
hearing but
why does this one need to be broken out
specifically if that's so
um
i don't know
that that if that is so and others would
have to talk speak to that this is the
only
only program that i'm aware of
but
someone else could probably answer that
and again with apologies for coming in
late
has the family
attempted to get services and have been
rebuffed
hence the need for a breakout
listing of this diagnosis an excellent
question and we discussed that a little
earlier uh
the family has uh
is in the application process
and they have not it has not moved
to its conclusion yet so i we don't know
what the response will be and and it may
be yes
um
i i just don't know i guess i'm ahead of
the curve a little bit no but what
you've done um thank you is open up a
good topic here for broadening of the
care as necessary so thank you so much
for coming you're very welcome thank you
for letting me yes oh yes sorry before
you look you leave
representative abel uh
a question relative to dealing with the
area agencies
and specific to the funding mechanism
that's coming from the state it's
medicare medicaid as well
for it is that is identifying the issues
that need addressing and the everything
has an acronym and what it is it's
called an isp or an individual service
plan
has that uh does that sound familiar to
you at all and what the folks have
addressed
uh in dealing with through the area
agency
i i'm i i i'm familiar with the with an
isp i don't uh
and uh
i believe uh until
now
uh this family has uh
used its own resources
uh i know they had 24-hour care and so
forth and now
with the mother
being in her late 70s
she's concerned what will happen when
she's not there and so i think that they
are perhaps only applying now for the
first time
uh and i i will find that out for sure
and i will get back to you
representative could you email me
uh the chair could you email me as to
where this person is located i don't
need to know their name so i can contact
the appropriate area agencies
there in lebanon new hampshire west
lebanon new hampshire it would be west
central i believe all right i'm sorry
i'm i took it you said okay i will um
call the area agency to see if i can
expedite
thank you
no privacy here i i got it now thank you
representative soloway
thank you mr chairman um
representative you know what deep
respect and affection i have for you and
your entire family
and i must add for the gross family
their oldest son used to pack my
are they not eligible for
a disability under social security which
would provide them some income in
medicare
i
will ask
i would imagine they would be and i will
find out for you and do you think it
would be possible to reframe
this uh legislation uh under an
amendment process so that we have a
larger umbrella without identifying
specific diagnoses
yeah i think that would be an excellent
idea if you can look at that thank you
so very much for doing this and when you
see the grossest please send them my
warm up i will do so thank you chair
recognizes representative
yeah i just want to give a point of
information that is if you go to 171 a6
that talks about the entry and they do a
comprehensive screening evaluation to
determine the scope of the disability
and what is needed so it would seem that
the diagnosis is irrelevant as uh
representing wood said because you have
to know what are the needs because
there's a spectrum for almost all these
diagnoses so if you look at 171 a6
that'll give you
that's the bolts of how it works once
and the chair recognizes attorney
melissa is it nameth
good afternoon mr chairman and members
of the committee my name is melissa
nemeth it's n e m as in mary e t h
yeah
it gets pronounced different ways all
the time so uh no words welcome
counselor
thank you
um
i am an attorney with the department and
specifically i provide legal counsel to
the bureau of developmental services
and we wanted to come today to provide
information
and a lot of what we were going to
provide has actually been addressed
with respect to
creating lists and and the hazards that
that can create um but hearing some of
the other questions from from members of
the committee what i would also say is
with respect to
you're changing
maybe taking this diagnosis out but
otherwise changing the statute there
would be a lot of considerations that
would would have to go into play and i
know one one question was about funding
and um of course this these services are
primarily funded through
medicaid waivers
and so we have agreements with the
center for medicare medicaid services
that would have to be addressed and we
have created systems in such a way that
we you have described how we provide the
services so it's not to say that you
know it can't be done or couldn't be
done but i think there's a lot more that
goes into it than perhaps making some
editorial changes to the statute as it
sits currently
and i did also want to clarify for this
individual if it's in west lebanon it
would be pathways of the river valley um
i think it was indicated it might be
west central but that's the community
mental health center in that area
pathway river valley
yeah so it's pathways of the river
valley
and i would be happy to take any
questions
representative
i just i'm a little bit confused as to
where you went with this because we
talked about funding it would seem
though since you still have criteria
that is done in terms of the screening
and because
it is already written in a rather vague
fashion
uh whether you could
i wouldn't call it loopholes but there's
kind of a lot of ways to continue
potentially qualifying this already yes
uh with the vagueness of closely related
to intellectual disability et cetera et
cetera
that if we just cleaned up the language
a little bit
that we wouldn't be opening a floodgate
to all kinds of new care because you
already have criteria you use
as i just point out 171 862 and then
also in your whole process
that determines what
needs and then of course we all know
that there's funding issues but they're
there currently yes so would it really
open a floodgate i think it would depend
on how
changes were
uh proposed to be made to the statute
that we'd have to look at i agree that
there's a
it's i think intentionally made made to
be a wide door so that it captures as
many people as possible um but i know
there was i was hearing words but you
know creating a bigger umbrella and
potentially a bigger pool of folks to
fall into this um that maybe wouldn't
fall in as it's defined so um there's a
potential it could be no difference
and there's a potential depending on how
the edits are made that there could be a
difference
follow-up could we ask you to perhaps
provide some language that would not
open up an umbrella that includes
everybody in the state of new hampshire
but would
would
open it for what we're actually that
people were actually talking about in
other words maybe
we talked about going to the for to oh
well sorry research services and getting
some information on the states but
perhaps you know a better definition
that could be used and if you could
provide that to us
that would be very helpful dhhs often
gives us some draft ideas for amendments
and then we wouldn't have to make a mess
of it
we could do what would potentially work
would you be kind enough to do that uh
yes i can certainly take that back on my
you know obviously there's
other layers i have to go through as
well but um you know what i think what
we would say is the the hope would be
that um you know potentially these folks
given the nature of their condition and
going through the the evaluation you've
described in
171a6 that they may in fact
already qualify um so but to the extent
that maybe they wouldn't or
um
you know there's a desire to have some
edits i can certainly take that back and
thank you
mr chairman and thank you for taking my
question uh
it would be wonderful if we found that
this umbrella as it is written would
would you agree that the problem with
word wordswhip mything here
is that we have some of these things
already in the list that are not like
the others
the statute speaks very clearly in
almost every place to intellectual
disabilities
not physical disabilities
but
i know of people with both cerebral
palsy and autism who are fiercely
intellectually competent
who are nevertheless disabled
and their disabilities may be either
physical ones or ones of relationship
depending on the condition
so
if we tried to simply broaden the
category by adding physical disability
and this is what i was trying to hint at
with with representative abel and i was
not doing it artfully and i'm sorry
but is it isn't the problem that if we
simply add the word physical disability
in here
we don't know how many people we are
adding
and we don't know how many conditions we
are adding
and if we
on the other hand try and draft by
putting in one more condition
we are
opening both opening the floodgates and
making an already confusing statute more
confusing is that is that the drafting
problem that we're asking you to take on
i think so
yeah but but i would agree that with
adding you know the just the word what
might seem like a quick edit to add
physical disabilities um if we were
asked for example to do a fiscal note
worksheet with that only that language
we it would be undeterminable because
there's just no way to know how to
capture that universe
and also to to representative gay's
question
previously about are there already
services for folks with physical
disabilities
i am not counsel for the bureau for
elderly and adult services but i knew
they do administer the choices for
independence waiver and i think for some
folks um
with and i don't know i can't speak to
you know these two um people that we've
been talking about here today but there
is that is another medicaid waiver
program that is administered by a
different arm of the department so
it could be that some of those
disabilities would be under that
umbrella of services
thank you
very helpful
i believe representative merchant
had his hand up
oh representative robert answered my
quest to ask my question so thank you
thank you and um i have a feeling we're
going to have a little uh
discussion group formed on this
and uh
you're invited to join us oh well thank
you you're welcome
and thank you representative abel very
much this is uh getting some things
going for us
that concludes the hearing for 1480. the
chair now opens
with at the suggestion of representative
weber a discussion on
1619 the cannabis program
um representative canuck left
that's fine
that's perfectly fine
uh representative nemeth i'd like i
could have a card as well from you
please and so we're going to open this
up for 10 minutes before the next
hearing is scheduled for further
discussion on this it does not mean
we're going to vote on it we probably
won't but it does mean we are going to
what are we having discuss it
representative weber could you approach
no representative approach come up here
you the only representative webber in
okay
this is an executive session therefore
it is legal
and um we can talk for about 10 minutes
on this if everybody is relatively quiet
and representative knurk
kick us off thank you i actually don't
want to make a motion yet but i do want
to no we're not proceeding necessarily
yes that's fine the point is
you know i want people to understand
that i do have my own personal feeling i
have to separate that from speaking for
the board but we had a really difficult
discussion on this because of opening
floodgates talking about trying to start
redefining the pain issue and the
difficulties that would be
um what representative sent me some more
information and i promised her i would
convey this to the committee because i
want to have her have a fair shake or
her constituent
she is concerned again about the stigma
of chronic pain and not meaning just the
stigma as people think of her but
access to things such as life insurance
disability insurance the reason she says
that is i made a comment that it is
confidential within
tcmob that is correct however the
provider will probably document
today i filled out a certification for
therapeutic cannabis for so and so on
the basis of their migraine headaches
using the diagnosis of chronic pain they
might not say that they may just say
using their migraine headaches
that would be in there because tc
program might contact them and say you
said chronic pain you said the medical
records that confirmed that they they do
have the authority to do that
the point is once it's in the medical
record that should be protected from
hipaa we know that for medical insurance
uh under the aca you're prohibited from
doing medical underwriting so that will
not make a difference there
as she points out and she's been texting
me nonstop since the hearing
um you know if you get your triple a
thing for disability or or life
insurance or something the little fine
print at the bottom says that they can
seek information they'll they'll pull up
let's say the pharmacy record see if you
had another opioid then you had chronic
pain but of course that's a separate
issue that's an example she used because
we're not talking about opioids here
we're talking about tc you don't get
those at the pharmacy
so i think this is a complex issue
that conceivably a person could have
what would be viewed as a blot in their
record that might impact other aspects
of either
occupation however personally
i think there's a real problem when we
get into these lists and that's exactly
what we just went through on this one it
is totally analogous
that it you have the exclusionary aspect
of it and the confusion i get our job
and what i want to do in ccmob when i
finally get this moving is to get out
and get our providers educated that is
my big job for the next couple of years
in addition to this if i get re-elected
you are running again please
well luckily i'm i'm i'm appointed as an
orthopedist so even if i don't win an
election i still get to serve on the
board
and i will still be here pestering you
because i'll probably still be the
legislative liaison thank you that'll be
the chair okay in any case
so
personally i i'm worried about trying to
start splitting hairs and adding more
stuff for the very reason it's been
brought up
um i do respect the concerns that
suzanne has and i'm wondering if anybody
else has any experience in this room
knowing that maybe lucy is an attorney
might have more knowledge about this
again medical underwriting you can't you
can't take into account that's not a
problem but for life and disability
insurance can they access your medical
records to identify that you have
something that would cause them to
rate you differently does anybody have
knowledge on that represent
i wouldn't exactly call this knowledge
but i do have an experience of someone
um who i was treating
for psychotherapy
closer
i do have the is it on now yeah i do
have the experience of someone who i was
in treatment with me
having to give
a release of information to me in order
to
anyone else for the discussion this is
not
necessarily question time but
i do understand what
thank you for mr chairman for uh let me
speak in regards to the underlying
bill and the requirement for it i think
it has
a lot of merit however i think it's a
slurpee slope and therefore if we start
getting into parsing things out
then we may leave something out that we
shouldn't have been
and therefore we run the risk of not
being inclusive enough
in regards to the issue of insurance i
can't speak that i'm not an insurance
agent i would make the assumption that
which is
what you should be careful what you're
doing consumption but when you want to
apply for any kind of life insurance
i believe the insurance underwriter
probably has access to anything they
want and if you don't want to provide it
to them
they can probably deny it doesn't mean
you have to but they don't have to issue
the policy to you that's just my logic
to it so at this point in time i'm
i hate to say the word but itl because i
think at this point in time we're not
per se an exact question mr chairman but
i think that's kind of we are in an
executive session and i would like to
make a motion to itl the bill if we can
yes this is this is not an opinion about
whether we should um add another um
category or not but i think that when
we're talking about stigma
we're assuming that we're talking about
stigma from the point of view
of other people looking unkindly on a
certain diagnosis but i think stigma
exists for the person themselves
who might be applying for
the use of therapeutic cannabis and i
think specifically for chronic pain
there are a number of illnesses that
there's a lot of contention about
diagnoses like for example fibromyalgia
and um you know there are people who
anyway i you know
there are people who don't believe in
certain diagnoses and therefore people
who have those diagnoses
feel um
stigmatized so i think we have to you
know
have to consider that stigma might not
be only from the external world but also
from the internal yeah
that's not necessarily a reason in my
opinion that we should go one way or the
other but i think that's something to
consider
representative canuck you were asked to
be an amendment person
on this
um
are there others who wish to serve with
you
may i answer that or speak to that i
mentioned you yeah yeah well i i think
the issue is the amendment that i would
bring forth would be simply to change it
to the proper location in the statutory
language that's the only job that i
would do as far as an amendment because
i'm not going to start parsing out all
the chronic pain syndromes in fact we
did talk about that tcmob and we decided
we did not want to open that can of
worms because we felt again that would
then if the difficulty would be
exclusionary issues again
this is all
because we did not have a quorum
we we did not want to open that can and
go down that line so you would bring it
in that would give us time to think
about this okay then reopen this
executive session
the amendment would be available and if
we decide to itl then it doesn't matter
if we decide to go with the
with the past we've already got the
amendment at hand so i would be glad to
put that in i don't really need any help
on it because it's not a high cognitive
job that answers my question thank you
i'm going to close the executive note
i'm going to close the executive session
i didn't hear it okay i did not hear a
motion here so he does not have to do
that
because
you need to overruled the motion sorry
did i receive that motion did i receive
it
it was not seconded
open the hearing on house bill 1455
relative to state enforcement of federal
vaccination mandates the chair
recognizes the speaker representative
packard
thank you mr chairman and members of the
committee
very simply
it isn't because we're anti-vaccine
i got my first shot in january my second
in february and i got my booster in
december
i am not against the vaccine in any way
shape or form
what i am against
and i will fight
every single day that i am here is the
mandate from washington dc
and that's what this bill does
it does not have anything to do with
being against
a vaccine
i urge people to get vaccinated
but i will not be blackmailed by the
federal government
and this bill
says we will not
be blackmailed
i've been fighting this
blackmail from the federal government
for 45 years of my life
on other subject matter
and when this came down
it was wrong
i believe in my heart that this hurt
the vaccines more than it helped
so all i'm saying to this committee and
all i'm saying to you the members
is that this is not about the vaccine
this is about
i believe an unconstitutional mandate
from washington d.c
and that's what this bill does
it says we will not comply with federal
blackmail
that's it will you accept questions from
the committee mr speaker
i will accept
and i please don't anybody take this
and it's my job to determine that thank
you
representative knurk uh thank you and
thanks for taking my question um just a
question about the breadth of this to
sort that issue out because obviously
this was written a few months ago yes it
was since the
supreme court has upheld the cms mandate
regarding
funding of medicare and medicaid the
question is is there any state role for
enforcement of that mandate or not
anyway and if not
how do we deal with the fact the supreme
court has ruled that that is
constitutional do we need to put a carve
out in for that specific one which could
be a problem because of them parsing
each thing as it happens
or or not i just i'm trying to figure
out if there is an applicability there
well as as you said representative this
was written i think
two two and a half months ago
and um i'm not going to sit here today
and say that i'm inflexible
because i that's not
what i am i will be flexible
if
some language needed to be
changed by the committee to accommodate
circumstances that have happened since
this bill was written
i'd be open to suggestions
follow-up follow-up
question because i'm trying to figure
out how one would achieve that though do
you have any do you have any suggestions
i i honestly at this point i do not
represent thank you
representative
cushman
thank you mr chairman and thank you mr
speaker for taking my question
um
mr speaker are you aware that so far
a few other states have issued broad
vaccine mandate bans and so far the
federal government has not taken any
action against those states and it's
also been speculated that a
duly enacted state law would hold more
i'm not a lawyer
so i'm not going to i'm not going to
attempt to comment on legal issues that
i don't feel when i'm capable i'm
qualified to comment on representative
cushman a question from the chair to you
okay you may ask a follow-up
thank you mr chairman uh mr speaker
um would you consider
if there was no language that
permitted us to have an outright ban
but instead to make the exemption
process easier um that way businesses
could
still like
cms uh regulated businesses could still
issue their mandate but just have a very
simple exemption process
i i believe
as you are aware representative and i'm
aware and i think every member here is
we have numerous bills that address that
issue as far as the exemption goes and i
i believe that that's the path we
probably should go down
we reject
mandates but we work
to accommodate those people that have a
legitimate reason whether it be
religious medical
or
actual fear of this
this vaccine and i know there are some
people out there that have legitimate
fear of this vaccine
so
i'm i'm understanding your point about
but i think what i'm trying to get at i
think maybe what representative knurk is
trying to get out also
is
the intent of this bill with respect to
there is a federal mandate
but the federal mandate has been held to
be
federally constitutional
because of the close relationship
of the mandate
to
the medical issues involved so
that
my understanding is and i'm not this
kind of an attorney so and i'm not an
attorney at all at this point in my life
but
uh
the the federal the u.s supreme court
has said that the cmc
mandate is constitutional
it has also said that broader mandates
are not have have exceeded the authority
so
when when you started talking about
exemptions i wasn't i was thinking about
the exemptions for
certain mandates as opposed to the
exemptions for certain particular
conditions or or religious objections or
things like that
if
would you object to a carve out for
uh
say
mandates coming from the federal
government that have held to be been
held to be constitutional under the us
constitution
the opinion of the supreme court
i i i haven't actually read it i've
heard of it and i've written i've read
about it
um frankly uh representative
i reject
mandates period
i i i believe that it's a form of
federal blackmail
and i will i will not go along with them
whatsoever that's not to say that i am
against
a business
or
a
health care facility
saying that
they believe that they have the right to
have a mandate
and i probably wouldn't disagree with
that if it was done on an individual
business basis
but for the federal government to tell
me that we have to do it and it has to
be mandated i reject that
thank you for the question and that's
why and that's why i i say that
i would also i also support the carve
outs
for you know any employee that is
working for that
particular business or institution that
has a um
a some type of a mandate
i'm against mandates
and i'm against the state mandating
against mandates and i made that
perfectly clear i'm against federal
mandates and i'm against the state
mandates
thank you for the clarification mr
speaker
representative soloway
thank you mr chairman welcome mr speaker
please forgive me i i have a number of
questions i'm going to bundle them all
as one to make this bad
um i i've heard
you say that you are not a lawyer
i've heard our lawyer say that this is
not her area i've heard from one nurse
and a physician
and i'm looking for some legal expertise
here which i don't have
i have pink cards and i'm not afraid to
use them
and i will get to them
and
so
is it not possible
that
people acting under this draft
legislation could be accused by the
federal government of
obstruction of justice
sedition
unconstitutional acts vis-a-vis federal
versus state jurisdiction i don't know
that i'm asking and
given that these are legal issues rather
than health related issues why is it
this bill was put before this committee
because of the statutes that it was
under and that's how we in
in most cases when we're unsure of where
a bill goes and i've done this numerous
times is that we go to the statue we
look at the statue
and whatever that statue
depicts as to what part of the bar it's
under is where we end up sending the
bill finally
i mean we look at
you know we look at
house rules
we look at statutes we look at the
recommendations i think you had did this
representative webber we look at the
recommendations from uh ann fitzgerald
and her group and we take all that into
consideration and that's how we do it
are we perfect by no means
but
we try and do the best we can
representative gay
thank you
mr speaker are you at all concerned that
new hampshire medical providers
won't follow the requirements by
medicaid and medicare
because
well personally i don't think they're
going to be afraid they won't break the
rules because they want to be paid so is
that really a concern
mr speaker the supreme court ruling on
the osha that was cited cited the lack
of congressional authority
uh does this bill address future actions
by the federal government or just the
ones in place presently um
well again as as as we have stated it
was written about two two and a half
months ago so i i
i'm sure the expertise in this committee
has a chance to look at that and if it
has to be amended it could be done thank
thank you mr
chairman and thank you mr speaker for
taking another question and i
uh
honestly don't know the answer to this
but
is there any possible way that you as
speaker can get this bill out of health
and human services because it does not
deal at all with health policy
and into judiciary or even state and
federal
regulation but but i think most likely
judiciary which is where they might have
more expertise in the subject matter
i know that vacation has to happen
before
a bill is assigned to committee and set
for hearing but is there any other
process by which we could get it
over to judiciary well when we when we
meet to uh send the bills to a second
committee
we could at that point
add this bill to that if we if we if we
felt it necessary
so i i mean i know that's happened many
many times in the past the bill isn't
initially sent to a second committee but
you know once it's gone through the
committee process of whatever committee
it's in
it has gone whether it be finance ways
and means or another committee so the
answer your question is yes it could be
sent to another committee
follow-up
thank you so
if but if it were to be sent to a second
committee it would have to be we would
have to have it out of here by february
8th i think
i know that's not the actual date but
it's the last date that we're meeting
yeah the though i i our our deadline is
attend thank you sir
representative
uh thank you very much and thank you
again mr speaker for taking another
question i guess i'm i'm still a little
confused because we kept talking about
not wanting the mandates to apply but
that's really not the point of this bill
actually the point of this bill is that
we're not that the state will not engage
in helping with enforcement and i think
relative to what representative gay's
question is i presume in the cms the
enforcement would come from the federal
government anyway they don't have to
check with the state to see if they're a
provider they would just say hey we're
not going to pay you
so i would in a sense i'm not sure that
we necessarily need to carve out for
that because the feds would already be
doing their own enforcement that's why i
was wondering
do we have a role actually in enforcing
this is why i put to go forward
representative because i
absolutely
do not want the state of new hampshire
forcing what i consider illegal federal
mandates
thank you
and with that mr chairman i'm sorry i
have a bunch of people waiting in my
office
on some other business if if i could be
excused you are excused sir thank you mr
chairman
chair recognizes kate horgan from the
nash the new hampshire
what a slip huh
not national associate the new hampshire
association of counties
who has 20 copies we'll make some more
we have 21 of us but we have a machine
so pass them around and
they are on their way around
mr chairman uh thank you very much
members of the committee my name is kate
horgan i'm the executive director of the
new hampshire association of counties
which represents all of your appointed
and elected officials in county
government
so in this case in particular i'm
bringing forward the concerns of your
county nursing home administrators
we are opposed to this bill we see that
this bill sets us up to be in conflict
with the federal statutes and that could
create conflicting policies
for
our county nursing homes so we think
that it is important that each county be
able to set their own
policies around the coveted vaccine
some counties have already done that
rockingham and grafton
and merrimack did set
vaccine policies but that was not
something that say belknap or
hillsborough wanted to presume
to enforce so we need to
ensure that counties have the
flexibility to enforce what works for
their counties i'm happy to take any
questions mr chairman representative
shapiro yes thank you mr chairman and
thank you for taking this question
excuse my ignorance on this but
um the bill as written states the state
shall not engage
et cetera et cetera et cetera
so would the counties be considered a
subsection of the state
i would argue yes we are a political
subdivision of the state i would also
say that state survey
is connected to our medicaid
uh procedures and making sure that we
qualify for medicaid so i'm not sure how
that would resolve itself if this bill
were put into place thank you very much
representative cushman
thank you mr chairman thank you for
taking my question uh so as far as this
bill goes i understand that the county
is saying they want to set their own
um
you know policies for vaccination and
it's my understanding that such policies
have resulted in
many health care workers leaving
employers who required the vaccine
before the cms mandate came down and
in the interest of
you know
ensuring we have enough people for our
workforce it's important to
refer back to the new hampshire
constitution are you aware that the new
hampshire constitution gives the
legislature the supreme legislative
authority in new hampshire and not the
counties i would say thank you for the
question representative and i do
understand that i will say the comments
that you made about losing staff has not
been the experience of the counties that
have put vaccination policies in it has
been
less than 10 members of the staff that
we have lost that we weren't able to
come up with some sort of accommodation
around the current exemptions that are
allowed
follow-up
thank you for that um what you may not
be aware of are are you aware that i
know that merrimack county has a
significant shortage all the time uh
being an agency nurse and i see that
you're constantly posting shifts that
don't get covered
so i would argue that you still have a
shortage and had your policy not been in
place many nurses who work for agencies
would be coming and filling that need
thank you for the question
representative i would say we had a
shortage before the vaccine policies
were in place
anybody else with a question i thought i
saw a few hands did i see your hand i
see part of your hand representative i
see now all of it you may ask all your
question
thank you mr chairman and thank you for
taking the question
i'm trying to
look at this bill and i heard before
that it would not apply to a business
and i think of a nursing home is really
being a business
so i'm trying to figure out
dice dices through here
is
when we talk about a government business
versus a private business we're looking
at
basically
saying that if you're a business owned
by the government you can't do it but if
you're in a business owned by private
you can
thank you for the question
representative merchant i'm not sure i'm
the right person to answer that question
but someone coming behind me probably
anyone else thank you so much for coming
thank you say hi to your sister for me i
will all right
uh
chair is calling steve annan from the
new hampshire hospital association he
has 25 copies
which is good
thank you mr chairman good afternoon mr
chairman members of the committee my
name is steve ahn and i am the president
of new hampshire hospital association
representing all of our state's
hospitals the new hampshire hospital
association has concerns about h.b 1455
which would seek to prevent state
government from
enforcement of federal vaccine mandates
as i believe many if not all of you know
the new hampshire hospital association
and its member hospitals announced in
august of last year prior to the biden
administration's vaccine announcements
in september a consensus statement in
support of requirements of our health
care workforce to be vaccinated against
coba 19 in order to protect the health
and safety of our patients our staff and
our communities hospitals have announced
their own individual policies um and
have been implementing them with robust
education for their staff about the
importance uh benefits of the vaccine in
doing so hospitals have sought to be
flexible and have complied with all
relevant state and federal guidelines
including offering medical and religious
exemptions
as presented we read hb 1455 to not
interfere with the ability of private
employers including hospitals from
making decisions about what health and
safety protocols are important and
appropriate for their employees
customers patients and organizations as
has been said the u.s supreme court
recently found that the federal vaccine
mandate requirement for healthcare
facilities that participate in the
medicare and medicaid program is
constitutional and can proceed
even though new hampshire hospitals have
already begun to implement coba 19
vaccine requirement policies they must
comply with the federal government's
rules hospitals that participate in the
medicare and medicaid program must be
certified to do so many hospitals in new
hampshire receive accreditation from
private organizations such as the joint
commission on accreditation of health
care organizations dnv and others
but others do not and in fact all of new
hampshire's rural critical access
hospitals all 13 of them receive their
certification through the new hampshire
department health and human services
bureau of licensing and certification so
how would hb 1455 affect the ability of
the bureau of licensing and
certification to conduct their review
and certification new hampshire's
critical access hospitals for
maintaining eligibility in the medicare
and medicaid programs participation in
those programs is essential to the
mission of our hospitals and to serving
all in our communities it would appear
that hb1455 could place added costs and
burdens on our small rural critical
access hospitals if they were no longer
able to rely on certification through
the bureau of licensing and
certification again we appreciate that
hb 1455 would not interfere with the
ability of private employers including
hospitals for making decisions about
what health and safety protocols are
appropriate for their employees
customers patients and organizations but
we do have concerns about the
implications for critical access
hospitals thank you for the opportunity
to offer our comments on this bill be
happy to respond to questions that you
might have representative shapiro
thank you mr chairman and thank you for
taking this question
um you say that
some new hampshire hospitals are
licensed by the department of
health and human services is part of
that licensing process to
um
measure compliance with federal laws um
it is to ensure compliance with federal
rules and regulations so they would be
required to ask as they are now if they
were complying with medicare
rules and
regulations would that be out of sync
with this bill
it would appear to be yes thank you very
much representative cushman
thank you mr chairman
thank you mr bannon you referred to
a statement that was issued by the new
hampshire um hospital association over
the summer yes um i read that statement
also and i and i noted in it that um you
refer to a study by the josiah bartlett
society and when you look at that study
i i followed it and it's actually a blog
post were you aware of that
um i was aware of their uh post yes
okay so you're aware a blog post is not
a study um it was that is how they
characterized the work that they had
done
okay thank you you're welcome thank you
representative gay
thank you
uh are you concerned that any of the
hospitals i have asked this question
before are you concerned that any of the
hospitals in the state or providers
general providers will be at risk for
not following the mandate from the
federal government
because they
because they already depend
on financial repayment by medicare and
medicaid as i just as i just noted and i
thank you for the question um i think
the the real question becomes for those
facilities that receive their
certification to be a to be able to
participate in the medicare and medicaid
program they rely on state survey and
certification so if they can't rely on
the state to to do that they will then
have to find some other alternative
generally a much more costly alternative
to receive that certification so that
they could continue to participate in
the medicare and medicaid programs
even if the
even if the um
certifying
body
well-certified hospitals without
without
verifying their
adherence to the medicare medicaid rules
wouldn't it be up to the hospital to
request that they certify that they do
it would be the requirement of the
agency to certify that they are
compliant with those rules and
regulations
the hospital can't say
we'll ask can we
be certified that we're following these
rules but not those they have to follow
all of those rules and
the agency would have to ensure that
any other questions
representative acton thank you mr chair
and thank you uh mr banner for taking my
question
um
in light of the the fact that the the
vaccine is not stopping transition
transmission from one person to another
i'm triple vaxxed but if i
get coveted i can still give it to
others uh have any hospital reel that
reevaluated the the
mandate that that was put in place to
try to stop transmission from one person
to another um i would say no um that has
not been reevaluated and the reason is
because you know the vaccine is very
good at preventing
infection but it's incredibly good at
preventing serious illness
hospitalization and death and what our
hospitals tell us we meet with our
hospitals every day we met with them
today at noon we'll meet with them
tomorrow and every day over the coming
weeks to talk about
managing the capacity of patients and
you know we are seeing you know some
patients who are breakthrough patients
so they are vaccinated they are boosted
and they are ending up hospitalized
those patients tend to be those who have
other comorbidities so they have other
health conditions that make them more
susceptible to serious illness but when
we talk about you know those patients
that are in the icu those who are very
ill that are intubated those tend to be
overwhelmingly the unvaccinated so the
the the ability to prevent that
from happening is so vitally important
you know right now there are over 400
patients who are hospitalized with copa
19. and you know that's on top of
hospitals that are incredibly busy and
full you know we have very few beds um
very few icu beds trying to manage you
know if a hospital is struggling to to
care for those patients trying to get
them to another hospital
to care for them those beds are hard to
find so we have to do everything we can
to preserve that hospital capacity so
that we can take care of all of our
patients you know our hospitals have
done an incredible job at caring for all
of their patients over the course of
this pandemic and they are going to
continue to do so but they need our help
to prevent more patients um from coming
to the hospital that we can avoid that
that are avoidable
this is the chairman asking a question
i'm part-time ceo of a medical facility
on the massachusetts new hampshire
border so our people go to facilities in
both states it is our experience and we
only have 2 000 patients so it's not a
vast number that the number of people
who
were recently described as
overwhelmingly unvaccinated
that's decreasing as we see more and
more and more people
who have been triply or troubling
vaccinated and boosted and as i have
been and so on so we're seeing under
omicron the numbers are not in the ratio
they were a year ago is what we see
would that be accurate outside of our
little patch it actually is very
accurate and in fact
the new hampshire hospital association
provides data and you can see it every
day on our website
that shows
the number of patients who are
hospitalized those patients who may
still be hospitalized and no longer
infected with covid um but are
recovering they're still very ill
they're still in the hospital but it
also shows the vaccination status and as
of last night
those numbers
were 43
were unvaccinated
23.1 percent were vaccinated fully up to
date meaning they had their their
initial course plus if they were
eligible they had that booster at the
appropriate time 15 and a half percent
were partially up to date with their
vaccines and then another 18 percent
were unknown and that's um you know we
just don't know what their vaccination
status is so we are seeing as i said
those patients who do have breakthrough
cases they tend to be those patients who
have other health conditions that make
them much more susceptible to serious
illness but again
the ability to prevent serious illness
hospitalization and death the vaccine is
is our best uh path forward to do that
thank you representative canark
thank you very much um
would you believe that
it is true what
representative acton said that if you
are infected you can transmit the virus
but that the rate of infection
is diminished 14-fold in the working age
group by being vaccinated and therefore
if a if the healthcare facility does not
vaccinate their workforce they are
exposing a patient who comes in for care
to a 14-fold increase in the risk of
becoming infected because 14-fold
increase in the number of people who
would be able to transmit
are would you believe that that is
correct that's absolutely uh correct i
do believe that and it's why we need to
do everything we can to protect those
vulnerable patients
when when a patient comes into the
hospital they are incredibly vulnerable
they're one of their most weakest points
their immune systems are very weak and
are susceptible to those kinds of uh
transmission to that kind of
transmission so again that's why we need
to protect our patients we need to
protect our staff and we need to protect
thank you sir thank you appreciate it
and now as promised
john williams esquire that means lawyer
abby rogers i believe
esquire no i'm sorry that was not meant
chairman pearson and member members of
the house health committee i'm john
williams for the record i'm the director
abby rogers legislative liaison dphs
but not a lawyer
legislative liaison
but she does think like a lawyer and
she's going to get credit with placement
as to where this might belong in the rsa
so thank you abby for that uh we are
here today uh like very much like the
new hampshire hospital association the
association of counties that we have
serious concerns about this bill to the
point that we will be registering our
opposition to the bill as as introduced
i do want to state to this committee we
have great respect for this body the
body of the house so we are here
committed to working with this committee
if this bill were to go to a
subcommittee for further conversation
discussions but i think that you've
heard really good testimony and pretty
much what we'd be testifying to in terms
of the impact that would have
relative to our licensing and
certification
unit within the department we are
required when overseeing licensed
facilities under 151 and you've
certainly been educated about what they
are
by virtue of other bills we've talked
about it it goes the whole gamut it
includes nursing facilities at the
county level private nursing facilities
hospitals rehabilitation centers and so
forth and so the concern here is if
we're being
as a state not
allowed to enforce the laws from the
centers for medicare and medicaid
services it would put new hampshire at a
very significant risk we think in terms
of the fiscal impact not only to the
loss of funding to those facilities
under 151 because if they can't comply
with the cms requirements they would be
at risk of losing those funds and i just
want to acknowledge that representative
gay certainly did her homework on that
particular point
i would also say that the bill did not
receive a request from the legislative
office um rather strike that the
legislative budget assistance office for
a fiscal analysis so we we didn't get an
opportunity to weigh in to let you know
of this so we want to let you know that
we would have preferred to um providing
this information earlier to the house
and to this committee uh relative to the
concerns that we had uh that were well
stated by mr annan from the hospital
association as well as ms horgan from
the dupont group and representing the
new hampshire association of counties
so with that there's just a couple of
items in here to just put out for your
consideration that the wonderful and
should be an attorney i guess if we
could wave people in certainly ms rogers
would qualify but the placement within a
new chapter and we have to recognize it
this is not embedded in a current
chapter under public health but it was
actually extended as an add-on so it has
its own chapters so
uh our suggestion would be to look at
the labor chapters and particularly
under rsa
275 it starts with a dash a and it works
its way all the way up to an h so if you
can do the alphabet better than i can
late in the day that would be an i so we
would recommend that this be placed as a
new uh placement in rsa 275
i which would be a brand new chapter
following 275 h would you email me to
that effect i would be more than happy
to do that and relaying it to also to
your uh committee researcher as well so
we will certainly i'm not i'm not
jealous um just send it out
we will do that we will do that um so
with that i i also think that in terms
of it going to a second committee i'd
heard judiciary certainly that would be
a committee that may be considered for
this but i think because of the fact as
you see identified in line eight that it
talks about
employers and employment that we're
talking about that setting that probably
the labor and the
industrial and rehabilitative services
under representative infantine might be
a good place for this bill to go to for
further consideration
i did think there was really great
questions asked by this committee and
i'm looking over at representative
cushman because she always asks really i
think really great questions that
require some advice in legal counsel so
again i would defer in this case because
this is obviously an important bill to
the house that you may want to defer to
an objective resource that you have
which is the house council attorney jim
cianci is wonderful uh he will give you
clear and objective guidance on this if
you do have questions related to the
bill with that also um attorney melissa
saints here who's our chief legal
officer for the department who actually
was able to give both ms rogers myself a
little bit of
information to be able to share with you
she also wanted us to extend to this
committee that she would be available as
a resource to this committee
on this legislation because she oversees
legal and regulatory services which
includes the health facilities
administrations which are charged with
the oversight of these facilities and
compliance with cms rules and
regulations so with that i'd ask miss
rogers if she has anything she would
like to offer
uh no i think john's covered it thank
you very much we'd have to take some
thank you mr chairman and thank you very
much for taking my question being very
unfamiliar with the labor statutes
i'm wondering
how
moving
how or if moving this to the labor
statutes
presents any advantage
when it comes to the concerns about the
regulations of hospitals and and nursing
homes and other things because
that's still state action
whether it's in the labor statute or in
and and uh if i can respond to
representative weber's question i think
it's a very fair question because
certainly there's overlap but because
the focus is on the employer employee
relationship we would
recommend
reviewing to look about appropriate
placement within the labor statutes and
you'll see other similar bills like this
that have in fact if you look at this
week's calendar i think you'll see no
less than five or six bills that are in
that same category and you'll see that
they're all housed somewhere around the
rsa275 range so it's not not by
happenstance that we figured out that
might be a place and again giving credit
um to ms rogers for coming up with that
follow-up
what i'm really concerned about is
trying to figure out
uh whether
this
statute wherever it's placed is going to
endanger our medicare and medicaid
funding from the federal government
which is going to be
a complete disaster for all of our
patients who
need that funding to say nothing of all
of our institutions
um
and
i just want to be clear that
if we keep the same language even if we
put it in a different place the same
risks that exist now are still there
as regards our our medical and nursing
yes thank you
it is our belief
thank you
counselor and most esteemed legislative
liaison
now we've got a
batch of cards from
the folks
in our state
and you're all asking to speak for three
minutes and
we're going to hold you to it
but you can say a lot in three minutes
thank you committee chair thank you
committee members um i'm coming here
today um
in support of this bill
and the reason is is that
i think we all have got some
understanding right now that some of the
things that's going on in our in our
country is not okay
and we are basically enslaving to the
federal government um because we have
taken money and with all the federal
money that we've taken for this robust
response for covet 19 has now forced us
into a situation similar to what's
happening in washington state right now
do you folks are you folks aware that
people within health and human services
that work at the state level are being
told that they have to go house to house
and strongly encourage vaccination for
all members if all members do not comply
then they are separated so children are
being removed from their families now as
we speak in washington state because of
the federal money that we took for our
robust response to covet 19. this bill
is to try to prevent that from happening
in the state of new hampshire bottom
line i don't care how much it costs
i don't care how many rules we break
with the federal government
this is our citizens and our children
are we truly truly willing to sacrifice
the live free or die that we have in
this state to comply with federal money
that's all i have and i'm open to any
questions
seeing none thank you so much thank you
the chair calls james monahan from the
community behavioral health association
mr monahan asks for one minute
well one of our members um maggie
pritchard spoke this morning and you i
think you said you want to have her make
a video on concise testimony so i'm
going to try to live up to that by the
way what you just said does not count
against your minutes oh great thank you
um but thank you mr chairman my name is
jim monahan i'm with the dupont group
and we represent the community
behavioral health association which is
the 10 community mental health centers
across the state um i'm here today in
opposition to the bill and will gives
representative gay
uh while if this is the first time i've
prepared before the committee this
session i expected it will be here on
multiple occasions for other bills would
deal with similar topic topics
and you'll see a similar refrain in our
message to you and that is and it's
incorporated in the letter here and that
is the association has adopted a policy
position with regard to a number
of the public health bills that are
before the committee and the legislature
this session i won't read it to you but
summarize it to say that
first and foremost
the statement thanks our thousands of
employees who have been vaccinated and
are taking appropriate mitigation steps
around the pandemic
it also expresses support for the
efficacy of vaccinations
and then goes on to remind the
legislature that the mental health
centers are
non-profit employers
and we're trying to avoid excessive
regulation and administrative burdens
associated with managing our employees
so that's the nature of the the
statement but i think it applies to to a
lot of the legislation you have before
you
and spit specifically with regard to
house bill 1455
we concur with what you've heard from
the department uh and from the county
nursing homes that there is great
concern that because we are
excessively regulated by the state and
the federal government
there is concern that
the disruption in that
oversight of the
federal regulations by state authorities
could be disruptive to not only the
proper operation and our compliance with
those regulations
but also has the potential to put
medicaid funds at risk
with that i'll answer any questions uh
either now or as a consequence of the
letter that you've read if folks want to
reach out to us we'll do our best to
chair recognizes ian hewitt
i have submitted electronic written
testimony uh mr chair
um ian hewitt on behalf of cornerstone
we take no position on the current bill
although i wish i'd marked pro so that i
could counterbalance my fellow orange
name tags on the other side there were a
number
um we do have a proposed not a specific
proposed amendment but we we would
propose an amendment which is discussed
in the written testimony i've submitted
electronically and which i can outline
here
we understand the intent of this bill
and i'm surprised this comparison hasn't
come up yet in this hearing to be very
similar to the sanctuary state
legislation that many democratic states
have enacted except it concerns federal
vaccination policy instead of federal
immigration policy
this is an area that interests us
because we expect that similar kinds of
state action are going to be required in
the coming years to protect fundamental
constitutional rights like religious
liberty and freedom of speech
we would propose that this bill be
brought structurally into line with the
way democratic states often enact
sanctuary state legislation and i'll
give the example of our neighbors in
vermont which is a traditional
immigration sanctuary state i can go
into more detail in questioning but in
brief vermont's legislation has
basically two components
the first component is a general
statement of policy that vermont
officials will not enforce federal
immigration law and will not collaborate
in any way with ice
that's roughly analogous to the proposed
title 141 k in this bill
the second component is a statute 20 vsa
which directs agencies in vermont
to adopt policies to implement that
first component and to provide for the
suspension
or termination
of
officials in vermont who fail to comply
with those policies
so we commend the intent of the sponsors
of this bill and the speaker's remarks
we think that the what the speaker has
proposed is an excellent analog of the
first component we think what should be
added in order to make this analogous to
sanctuary state legislation we see
elsewhere is the second component
statutory directives to implement the
general court's goals as articulated in
this bill analogous to vermont's 2366.
i would be happy to take
any questions including legal and or
constitutional questions this is the
chair asking you a question um
if we're running these two things
in parallel at least for purposes of
argument
to your knowledge has the feds
swooped in on sanctuary states and done
all kinds of things because they're
clearly doing shots across the federal
bow as we
are possibly going to do if house bill
1455 passes
well if i could mr chair provide a bit
more context by giving a bit more detail
on vermont statute
the first component that i mentioned
which all state and law enforcement
agencies in vermont are required to
follow
very systematically and comprehensively
provides that there can be no
enforcement of federal immigration laws
in vermont that there can be no even
communication with federal agencies that
are attempting to enforce federal
immigration laws
in vermont's case that statute 2366
compels
all law enforcement agencies around
vermont to adopt policies
that allow for no more communication or
cooperation with federal agencies than
under that first component that i
mentioned so we have vermont
very directly
not just firing a shot across the bow i
would suggest of the federal government
but directly substituting its own
judgment for the federal government's
judgment on a matter of important
national policy
and as you correctly indicated mr chair
the legislature of vermont has not been
rounded up and tried for sedition or
other similar crimes
there is no preemption issue when it
comes to a sanctuary state law because a
sanctuary state law like vermont's law
or like this bill simply provides for
what the state will and will not do
it would not stop in vermont's case
immigration and customs enforcement from
coming in and arresting someone in the
case of new hampshire it would not stop
a federal agency from cutting off a
federal participation in a federal
program to a hospital where the hospital
to fail to comply with federal policy
thank you mr chairman also thank you for
taking the question you sort of touched
upon what i wanted to ask and that spout
to the issue with
cms in regards to reimbursement what
what i'm hearing is the concern over the
state losing the funding coming from the
federal government for healthcare
programs
in the ice situation
that you're referring to is there any
exposure for the state of vermont to
lose significant federal funding for not
complying with the federal mandate
well theoretically the federal
government could try to say condition
highway funding for example on vermont's
enforcement of federal immigration laws
i think that the last federal
administration for example would have
liked to do that and would have liked to
compel sanctuary states to enforce
federal immigration laws but it wasn't
able to do so
constitutionally
the federal government can't do what's
called commandeering and use conditions
to kind of forcibly take over state
agencies and reduce them to auxiliaries
of the federal government compelling
them to enforce federal policy what what
you're getting at as the federal
government could well determine if there
was a particular
public program
in new hampshire it could determine to
cut funds to that particular program
if that program was not in compliance
with federal policies this
nor would this bill prevent that
that the federal government is going to
be responsible for enforcing federal
policies and can continue to do so
this bill would just prohibit any state
official from acting to enforce federal
policy
representative cushman
thank you mr chairman uh thank you
um ian
mr hyatt hewitt um
my question is to the ideas of an
exemption so if we were to carve out
something for cms regulated or cms
certified businesses and say um
you know this
this bill doesn't stop
them from complying
um would
a
would language in there to allow for
a streamlined exemption process meaning
anyone who submits an exemption based on
our um you know our uh constitutional
right to religious freedom or our
constitutional right to um
con our right of conscience or for a
medical reason
because my understanding is that
i know
firsthand that a lot of these cms
certified
facilities are
using the exemption process as a
religious inquisition and they make it
very difficult and getting a medical
exemption is nearly impossible you have
to have had anaphylaxis to a previous
dose of vaccine to even qualify for that
and many doctors won't write it because
they're being told that they can't
um so my question is if we were to
streamline that process and just say
exemption shall be granted
so that that would allow for the you
know the rights of conscience of our our
citizens
while allowing the businesses to still
have a mandate in policy
would that solve the issue
well
excuse me there's two separate issues i
think when it comes to hospitals there's
the issue of if there is a public
hospital for example um
i think it would make far more sense for
this committee to have a carve out for a
public hospital
perhaps of the kind you're describing
when it comes to
the state certifying private hospitals
in that case i don't see what the
constitutional issue is in that case the
state can choose what it's going to do
and what it's not going to do and it's
up to the federal government if it so
chooses to enforce federal policy so i
just want to make sure i'm drawing the
distinction between public hospitals and
the state issuing certification to
private hospitals in the in the latter
case there isn't any kind of issue of
constitutional preemption any more than
there would be in the case of of the
immigration
laws that i've discussed
up
thank you um
so
if if we put constitutional issues aside
and we're talking about the concern for
the hospitals to continue functioning
and serving the people of new hampshire
would that be a
useful mechanism to protect the rights
of employees on one hand and the state
and on the other hand to continue
receiving federal funding and not put
the hospital in the position where they
can't be medicaid cms certified
i i may be misunderstanding your
question but if if your question is
whether the state could through state
statute
change whether certain healthcare
providers are going to be eligible to
participate in certain federal
programming i understand that's not your
question
okay
no so the idea is to allow just
streamline exemption processes because
currently they're allowed in this the
except for
they're
becoming a very difficult
thing to achieve
and the hospitals are
making it difficult deliberately in a
number of ways
and
the idea would be to make that
streamlined make it
easy
and so they can comply with the cms rule
but also accommodate the rights of the
employees
right i i do think i understand your
question and the the state unfortunately
i think wouldn't have the ability to
change the exemption
process that exists under the cms rule
because the federal government could
always simply elect to terminate
thank you mr chairman and uh thank you
ian for um or mr hewitt for taking this
question which is a real simple one
i just checked my emails and i didn't
see the electronic testimony so if you
could send that for our records i i
appreciate it can you do that
i certainly can i did upload it uh
through the sign in process the general
court's website hasn't has an upload
your written testimony option which i
used but i can also simply send it
directly to the committee i do have um
one physical copy with me if that would
we have a machine right next door here
that can do just that fantastic
representative
you cofold you mr chairman and thank you
mr hewitt for taking my question
um my understanding is that cms takes
the position that their rule
preempts any state and local laws
the bill before us includes a
severability clause
which
in my in the way i read it essentially
says
any parts of this
that are not applicable
uh don't invalidate the rest of it
any situation in which this is
found to not be applicable
uh doesn't render the rest of the bill
um
invalid so can you elaborate on that a
little bit and and
let us know whether you think that that
obviates the need for a specific carve
out or does it essentially cover us in
the event that there are
federal
laws rules or regulations that would
conflict with
this law counselor before you answer
could you give your single copy to my
clerk so we can get many more copies yes
proceed thank you
um representative kofol your question
was about preemption and the
severability clause it is always helpful
constitutionally to have a severability
clause in the event that a court finds
there is some unconstitutional
application of a statute they can be
helpful in protecting the statute
so i suppose my answer is yes it is
helpful to have that but i think the
example of sanctuary state laws shows
that there isn't a preemption issue when
it comes to a state saying it's not
going to cooperate with
enforcement of a federal law or policy
there's no there's no direct conflict
there with federal statute federal
agencies can enforce federal law
they can
to a certain extent withdrawal funding
for example to
you know participating medical care
providers that are not in compliance
with their policies
but what a sanctuary state law like this
one would do would be to say that state
agencies simply can't enforce those
rules and can't cooperate with the
federal government and the enforcement
of those rules and as i indicated
earlier if there was some way for the
federal government to commandeer the
states and force states to enforce
federal policy
sanctuary states on immigration i think
we all recognize would not exist the
last administration would have found a
way to dispose of those
representative weber
thank you mr chairman and thank you for
taking my question my question is
as i listen to your analogy about
sanctuary states your point is well
taken
but
is
let me pose a different analogy which is
that
when
a law that i
deplored but when we decided federally
that everybody needed to drive 55 miles
an hour whether they were driving in the
middle of new york city or somewhere on
i-93 north of concord
any state had the right
to have any speed limit it wanted but
federal highway funds were not going to
flow to that state
that was the consequence
and
my recollection is because i confessed
to having a heavy toe
that every single state that i drove
through had a 55 mile an hour speed
limit for a number of years until
somebody worked out that we were losing
work time that
offset
the gains in
gas savings so
would you believe that my concern is
that your analogy is
in apt and that
the
federal government has ways of making
our lives very miserable
if
we choose to interfere
not with individual build
individual hospitals or other nursing
homes can comply or not comply with cvcc
guidelines as they choose this doesn't
change that at all but if the state
refuses to certify on the basis of this
that they are complying with federal law
we risk
a much greater penalty than people risk
when they simply enact a sanctuary state
law
to my knowledge representative there
there isn't a federal condition that
mandates state enforcement
the federal government i understand has
conditions which require that in order
to for a particular hospital for example
to participate in such and such federal
program it must comply with certain
conditions
but that's a separate question from
whether the state is going to enforce
that policy or not
it sounds like i know all the concerns
here we're discussing are about the cms
mandate
as speaker packard indicated this was
written before the osha mandate went
into effect primarily written to address
the ocean mandate and it sounds like
implicitly we agree the ocean mandate
would be a pretty direct analogy to the
federal immigration laws and sanctuary
state laws
bill as written also says that it
addresses any federal vaccination
mandate uh rule or law so it could be
understood to be primarily prospective
in that sense and to anticipate any
future federal law a rule that might
arise
as far as
the state withdrawing funding the
federal government withdrawing funding
from hospitals the federal government
could do that and that wouldn't be
in conflict with this law
now i should i should mention you also
raised the issue of the federal
government conditioning federal highway
funds on having a certain speed limit
there is a law in federal constitutional
law between
appropriate conditioning of funds and
commandeering there is a certain point
that that case law delineates at which
conditioning of funds rises to the level
of commandeering that's unconstitutional
i wouldn't be able to speak at this
moment to exactly where that line is but
i think we can see when it comes to
in general
state enforcement of a federal policy or
non-cooperation with
that federal policy which is what we're
talking about in this case not what
policy the states have like in the case
of of speed limits then there isn't a
preemption issue and the state decides
not to enforce or cooperate with
thank you mr chairman thank you for
quite taking the question
i spent 10 years on the board of
pharmacy and i'm not an attorney
but we spend a lot of time with
attorneys
and you're raising a very interesting
point because
one of the questions that would often
get raised
is why do we have to
put into
rules but the government federally has
and what i've been told time and time
again and probably could have been wrong
is that the federal government can force
federal laws
the state government enforces state law
and why this duplicate duplication
between the two is the fact that if the
state
agency wants to enforce a law it really
has to reply upon state law not per se
federal law that they are sort of
co-mingled but they really are somewhat
separate
so can you help me understand the role
between the federal agency and its
enforcement versus the state agency and
its enforcement
well states often do cooperate in the
enforcement of federal laws and that's
why democratic states enact sanctuary
state laws we see for example in states
that are not sanctuary states
immigration and customs enforcement
frequently will call up local law
enforcement departments and ask for
their help
in enforcing federal immigration laws in
sanctuary states that simply doesn't
happen
which means it's up to the federal
government to enforce its own laws and
and that is the distinction we're
talking about here is it's a federal
policy this bill specifically
anticipates any federal policy or rule
requiring vaccination and says the state
will not cooperate in the enforcement of
that policy
i mean likewise with the vaccination
mandate back when it was anticipated the
osha mandate would go into effect we
were seeing osha say we expect to
cooperate with state departments of
labor for example in state law
enforcement and ensuring that this is
enforced
so it is quite common for the federal
government to look to state agencies to
help them enforce
federal laws but there is no
constitutional preemption reason that
the state needs to cooperate with the
federal government enforcing its own
policies
representative cushman
thank you mr chairman uh would you
believe that florida actually passed an
exemption bill um like i was describing
and it's working quite well
nurses just submit a one sentence um i'm
i'm exempt for x reason and it's granted
and it and that cms actually doesn't
dictate how exemptions are granted it
just allows for them
um i would believe that i would be
interested to know how that policy has
interacted with the supreme court's
holding
in the recent cms case
and whether there have been any new
developments in florida since that
holding was issued but i would believe
that
any other questions
mr hewitt thank you counselor
and we'll look forward to well we
actually got it already thank you i
it's just handed around
it's got his name on the back
were we short a few how many did you
oh i got two
thank you
the one who has to share with the one
who has none thank you thank you
and how are we doing
wonderfully appear five loaves two fish
multitudes
the clerk needs two one for herself one
for the files the chair recognizes i
think this is karen if not please let me
thank you mr chairman and members of the
committee um i'm actually here in
support of hb 1455.
um what representative cushman was just
referring to i think is a very very
vital point of
i think as we discussed this i'm not an
attorney
but when i do think about religious or
medical or even natural immunity the
exemptions
it really gets down to
being unconstitutional as far as title
vii and i think this whole pandemic has
been you know uncharted territories for
for many
and i sit here today unemployed because
my exemption was denied um and then it
got even worse when i filed for
unemployment and it was due to supposed
misconduct because my medical religious
exemption or natural immunity was not
um recognized so i think you know i
understand the hospital associations in
the the elderly folks homes you know i
think that their my concern comes in as
someone that has
dealt with
cardiologists primary care physicians
hematologists oncologists for the last
20 years i'm very confused as to why
physicians are being penalized if they
potentially want to prescribe ivermectin
or
hydroxychloroquine that has been proven
to be effective and helpful in early
treatment why are patients being sent
home and told wait till you're sick and
then they come back and the protocol
being passed out by anthony fauci
is for folks to be put on ram desevere
that causes kidney failure and promotes
fluid to the lungs so i'm very confused
by
a lot of these
things that are being rolled out so i'm
encouraged to hear things that are
happening in florida that potentially is
something that we could consider here in
new hampshire
i don't think it's a republican or a
democrat issue it's not a vaccinated or
unvaccinated issue
it's really about the constitution and i
think that's what our founding fathers
developed the constitution was for to
avoid overreach of government and i
really that's what i hope that we can
come to a conclusion i think this bill
just stops the mandates that it's a very
slippery slope if we allow the federal
government because of funding to start
to dictate what we
we actually happens to our own
individual bodies whether whether i
would want to take a vaccine or not i've
taken vaccines i've played professional
basketball over in switzerland i had to
take the typhoid shot i'm not anti-vaxx
but this particular vaccine does not
have enough safety and efficacy data
and when there's people that that
actually created
the
robert malone said this is about
totalitarianism
and he is the inventor of the mrna
delivery to system
so i would highly encourage you if you
want more details
covid.daystar.com someone who's very
knowledgeable about the law is the
healthyamerican.org
and i think we are all looking for the
right solution for the granite state
people so i thank you for your time
thank you and welcome any questions if
anyone has any
yes
no i get to do that sorry sorry
sorry no no no no no
i'm just learning to do this
okay representative gay
are you aware of the most recent cdc
determinations that
for
covet
delta
the people who have
natural immunity have more protection
than the people with the vaccines all of
them correct
that is correct
yes and actually the cdc in 2002
actually was a part of the patent of
looking at sars kovi ii
which is interesting to me
any other questions
thank you so much you're welcome thank
you for your time and
i'm sorry to do this but we're done
so this ends
did i hear groans in the neck thank you
so much
we don't have any bills quite ready to
exact
so we're not going to do it
but this ends the hearing on 14 55 and
thank you and see some of you next
chair would like to see representatives
acton and cushman up here please
i have a mundane question for you
so
we used to have coffee to the
[Music]